the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
winning moves were in abundance at the
u.s juniors and senior championships in
saint louis it may have been saturday
but nobody took the day off with players
quickly getting to work maxim delugey
became the third legend to win a game
vaulting him to the top of the senior
standings along with larry christensen
and igor novikov young christopher ew
defeated pedro espinoza joining andrew
hong for co-lead in the juniors the
junior girls games were unanimously
decisive but sophie mora suzuki refused
to relinquish her lead remaining
undefeated the race for a national title
is on round four of incredible chess
coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day four of
the us junior and seniors chess
championships held here at the sa louis
chess club we started the in the world
chess hall of fame at the q boutique
store where you can purchase all of your
chess needs you can buy a chess set you
can buy a chess book pretty much
anything chess related well the players
are ready and re-energized ready to
battle it all out on the chessboard
let's go to the studio and start today's
action
welcome everybody to the capital of
chess in america it's st louis missouri
and we are hosting three national
championships this couple of weeks the
2022 u.s junior u.s junior girls and u.s
junior championships are being played
for here at the st louis chess club to
bring you all of that action i'm grand
master alejandra ramirez with grand
master yes sir sarah won alejandro as
always a great pleasure to be with you
in christian studio it's been wonderful
it's been great and we've had a bunch of
interesting rounds three already in the
books and it felt that yesterday it was
a rollercoaster of emotions no question
about it things snapped
yesterday hello everyone and thank you
for joining us for this
live broadcast of these national
championships we're still terrorized by
the loss of a wonder liang yesterday
chess is a cruel game and boy did we
live it here on the panel alejandro
what's happening in our current
standings begin with the ladies please
in the latest we have a very clear
leader with three points out of three
sophie mori suzuki has so far put
herself away from the field did a
perfect score three out of three
including a very important victory there
against rochelle wool in the second
round talia cervantes is the only player
half a point away and in the juniors in
the junior sections we have two
leaders and they've done it in very
different ways andrew hong
showing absolute mastery of the white
pieces superb superb preparation and
christopher you being great kg won an
interesting game yesterday against pedro
espinosa but the blemish you have to say
from these standings the unexpected a
wonderly young number one seed with only
half a point out of three twenty seven
hundred languishing and it's high for
last and in the seniors
in the senior section more of a close
affairs we have three leaders larry
christiansen igor navikov and maxine
dulugi we haven't seen as many decisive
games in this tournament all of these
players have won one game drawn the rest
and the only other player to have won a
game vladimir akopian actually ended up
losing the first round so he's on 50
and christian well pardon me first of
all let's do the format
we have three 10-player round robins for
you a classical chess time control of 90
minutes for the first 40 moves you then
get 30 minutes for the rest of the game
and through the entire game from move
number one you get a 30 second increment
you you mentioned that the three rounds
have already been done that's our
remaining schedule we have one round a
day except for tuesday july 12th we will
have our rest day and nice that will be
very welcome not just for the players
but for ourselves right and we start at
1 pm every day including the last round
july 16th we will have the playoffs
after the tournament is over if
necessary on the same day
and christian i was so excited i wanted
to get to you a little early there nice
to see you in studio my friend who's our
gladiator for today
great to see you yasser great to see you
alejandra and it's great to be back
casting uh the games of the best juniors
as well as the best legends that we have
here in the united states and we've been
profiling a lot of very interesting
players but the one that i have my eyes
on today is this young lady sophie
maurice suzuki she is in fact the only
player right now that is still on a
perfect three out of three in all three
sections
this lady has just been playing
brilliant chess and let's take a look at
how she got to where she is in round
number one she defeated zoe tang with
the white pieces after that very
difficult matchup against rochelle wu
but she defeated her graciously and in
round number three against gracie
prasanna well what a game that was back
and forth and unfortunately for gracie
she resigned in a drawish position but
let's take a look at the last career of
this young lady she's 20 years old
she learned chess at the age of 11. very
similar to when you learn chess yasser
she took second place in the under 14
section of the 2016 all girls national
championship well that was not
everything she also won the 2017 new
york girls state championship and the
under 18 section of the 2017 all girls
national championship she played this is
her third time that she's playing in the
u.s junior girl she also participated in
2018 and 2020. let's not forget if she
wins this tournament she will be
punching her ticket to the u.s women's
championship sophie is also an avid
music enthusiast and enjoys writing
music
and look at her she plays at this lee
today this one is going to be a huge
clash because we know 13 years of age
alice lee is out for revenge after a
very difficult start guys we have so
many amazing games today indeed let's
talk about that alejandra set the stage
for our viewers and tell them what we
can expect in the pairings let's begin
with the girls absolutely we have a huge
matchup here in the girls section i
would say two big ones uh rochelle with
the white pieces is playing against
talia cervantes i think this is a very
important matchup absolutely yes
currently in second place but i think
we're gonna have our eyes on
alice lee she
mesmerized us at the american cup yes
she did got all the way to the finals in
the top bracket lost to crush got to the
finals again and lost to crash a second
time but what a performance by alice lee
she's going to be playing the leader of
the tournament sophie maui suzuki and
let's be honest alice has had a rough
event here in san luis she hasn't
performed well
she saved a couple of lost positions but
she did lose game three and what about
the juniors as uh the pairings for
four have a headliner in this one no
questions
andrew hong specially with the white
pieces will be trying to impress us and
his opponent grand master christopher
you as these two players currently
sitting in two and a half points are the
leaders and they face each other what a
great matchup and in the seniors in the
senior tournament we have a lot of kg
matches but there's a match match-up of
the leaders christensen with the white
pieces will be facing maxine delugi both
of them with two points that is going to
be our match-up of the day no question
about it our marquee match up also
dimitri gervich versus igor novokov
we'll keep an eye on that one but it's
nice to see the tournament leaders
clashing
in at this round four again reminding
everybody we will play tomorrow and then
there will be a rest day on tuesday so
we see larry with the white pieces what
a classic matchup this one is i know i'm
just thinking to myself i feel this is
like icing sexy days
this is like internet chat club when you
see you saw larry c against lugi yes
there was this matchups of one minute
chess that never stop i remember
watching those
exactly and what are they uh playing for
um aleandra in the pro we have big prize
funds here we have the us junior girls
uh 20 600 for them 6 thousand for first
four thousand per second and three
thousand four third we doubled this one
from last year thank you to the st louis
chess club for that one absolutely and
in the junior championship we have forty
thousand dollars up for grabs twelve go
to the first place uh eight to second
five for third and remember that in both
the us junior girls and the u.s juniors
they're also fighting for a ticket to
the respective championship whether the
u.s women or the u.s championship to be
held next year not this one exactly and
in the seniors you have 75 000
in price fun 20 000 for first 13 for
second and then for third
and larry checking out the pairings the
competition shout out to emily they're
in the back exactly i mean without her i
don't know what we would be doing for
our meals and everything else that the
club provides a really big shout out to
st louis chess club staff for making our
stay so enjoyable so pleasant and i have
to say the playing hall looks marvelous
it does this was put together in just a
couple of months so kudos to everybody
that worked tirelessly
to get us to where we are i just wanted
to share that yesterday i was talking
with chris bird the international
arbiter you see him there in the middle
of your screen
uh stan this is chris berg our
international arbiter i was talking with
him and he was explaining the pandemic
as we've been talking about these
tournaments are tend to be qualifiers
for the open championships including the
ladies championships and this year's u.s
championships in october will be 14
player events that's right because of
the pandemic qualified qualifiers that
took place and so we're going to be
instead of our usual 12 player fields
we're going to have 14 player fields i
didn't know that so i just thought i'd
share that yeah we're going to have
humongous tournaments when you think
about it we're going to have a
traditional 13
round tournament in the us chess
championship that is about as long as
the candidates for those in the
production crew just thinking about how
long that is right it's about the same i
remember my u.s championships had 16
players 16. was it a 15th round how many
addresses did you get though
oh uh a lot of rest days but also a lot
of i want to say um
no i don't even remember
when you were during the game adjourn
game days and
uh well there we see our key match up in
the juniors as the two
uh leaders uh face off just a second
where's my
i don't think i
chose my juniors i'm looking for the
juniors help me out here
my go-to guy i got them i got them guys
if you want uh
if you want some updates on what's
happening right now go forward it seems
we have a french and the big game
between andrew hung and christopher i
was quite a surprise i have to say i
haven't seen christopher you play the
french as often but i have to say i
haven't been following that much these
games either so this is more or less a
surprise in my opinion the french is not
a great opening but a lot of players
specifically after nepo started playing
it in the kansas in 2020 a lot of top
elite level players started playing the
french and we see that from christopher
early on a surprise in my opinion now
another big game is pedro espinosa
versus abimanu abimanu well we cannot
avoid it he got lucky yesterday of
course he got lucky he's on two out of
threes a very decent result he could
have easily been he should have probably
been on one out of three minus one but
he's on plus one and right now he has a
big match against the lowest rated
player in the event and once again a bit
of a surprise at the beginning because
he decided to go with d take c4 the
queen's gambit accepted now after the
move e3 in general
this position is considered to be
quite equal if white wants it to be if
white doesn't go for uh the very
aggressive e4 e3 is a tamer approach and
it doesn't seem like black has a lot of
ways to complicate matters you can try
to go b5 or you can try to go
e5 at some point but
for from what i'm seeing he's taking
more or less a quiet approach as black
and this is surprising to my eyes let's
wait and see where this game takes us
thank you christian i also turned my
attention the game between a wonderly
yang a wounded animal
in a wonder losing such a
painful game yesterday he's up against
carissa yet
karissa losing her first game of the
tournament she started
with two
i want to say nice draws and brandon
played a wonderful game against her
yesterday i mean seriously i mean
i don't think carissa has to feel bad
about that game as uh but today she has
a real challenge she's black and she's
playing a king's indian defense i know
that's a part of her
repertoire but
wonder also plays the king's indian
defense we saw it earlier in the
tournament by him uh taking some risks
taking the bull by the horn and this
move bishop e2 seems to have stalled
carissa right i mean which is a big play
d7 d6 and it could be an overbox system
with bishop gt5 well one of my favorites
that's one of the ways now i think we're
going to see uh h4 h4
that's a good memory of this h4
variation uh-huh why is h4 the way to go
uh christian well that's a new way to go
in a new way yes yes yes um h4 i think
after d6 creates some very serious uh
troubles and i have some good memories
alejandro was saying that
good memories sure but also bad memories
at the same time oparin my student
played it against nakamura in the grand
prix and he got a completely devastating
position and naka escaped so
that was unfortunately a big problem a
big wrinkle nevertheless it does seem
like h4 is producing serious trouble for
a black if you go h5 then you're also
going to give me this g5 square as well
as a potential attack after f4 and g4 h5
is not considered to be the best move
what black needs to focus right now and
this is why i'm a bit concerned
about karissa if she doesn't know her
theory and if she doesn't go for the
counter attack immediately with the move
c5 then she might fall under a
tremendous pressure in this game let's
take a look and wait and see and you
made a very good point yeah sir a wonder
is also a kings indian player so he
knows these variations he has prepared
them with the black pieces and why is
karissa already thinking after bishop to
e2 and by the way she played the move c6
oh that's old school stuff old school
stuff i faced it actually myself i think
it was against julio sedora
many many years ago and to be honest h4
is a very decent move uh at this point
creating some very serious problems for
black thank you for that uh christian i
want to turn our attention he made it
there it is yeah it's on the board
i want to turn our attention to the game
between rochelle wu and talia cervantes
i thought that this
is a really important game for talia she
stands at two and a half points a mere
half point away from first a queen's
gambit accepted and after e4 she played
b5
a4 c6 takes takes
knight c3 i'm familiar with bishop b7
i've seen that before the queen b6
man i don't know my theory at all knight
jumps to d5 queen dropped back to b7
bishop to f4
and on first blush you just go oh my god
this is devastatingly good for white is
this theory
i mean
isn't this the chicago game against
levon ironian where they go e5 serious
theory yes this series
but e5 and tell me how the theory goes
now that we're here then i guess we take
with the bishop bishop yeah you take
with the bishop
you go
you move the knight out but i don't
actually play this line i don't remember
if it's 97 or 1997 it's 97 right 97 to
d7 how does this go again you give a
check
no you don't give a check giving a check
is bad i don't think you give a check
you go bishop g3 if i'm not mistaken
because i can see that bishop e4 check
and queen 24 e4 check
so you have to go bishop g3 right go for
it um
christian how does it continue then yes
bishop uh g3 knight f6 knight c7 and
it's a complete mess
i see there's one game in the database
in this one game i get something like f3
just to
be able to sidestep bishop before check
maybe bishop yeah f3 f3 rock beard was
the game
oh really yeah okay bishop e2 also who
uh
decides that bishop default check and
the database seems right quite uh
quite delayed because there's been a lot
of games of that right i want to say
that there was a hikara yes i'm in this
position there's a big game between
aromian actually with the white pieces
and dominguez
also and aronian one with the white
pieces he made some novelty at move 16
or 17 or something along those lines so
the theory is just beginning right now
wow i mean again to my
naked eyes i'm looking at bishop takes
e5 and i'm just thinking
i'm cruising as white uh cool that this
stuff
is being analyzed by the chess engines
again i wanted to go to our tournament
leaders i always like to do that where
is
there she is alice lee
uh versus uh
sophie sophie 3-0 and again we've got a
grunfeld very nice grunfeld with h3
hello what's that
uh bishop b7 a greenfield with h3 what's
that
h3 h3 is pretty serious is it yeah yeah
it's very serious oh really
yeah vladimir kramnik uh espoused uh h3
wow uh
look i'm gonna turn it to a resident
grunfeld expert here uh it is a
christian after all i might as well make
him work
exactly the reveal the goods i'm
defining the remember the theory so i
have very extensive files in this h3
because i recently prepared it against
uh some of my students but as it usually
goes for a coach you prepare so many
things you forget 99
of them and this is exactly what's uh
happening but h3 is uh one of the main
lines recently and it has been played
magnus has played it kramnik has played
it swiddler has played it wesley so has
played it so a lot of top level games
and if you see zvidler on the white side
you know that this is probably a very
testing option because viddler in my
estimation is probably uh the best
expert in terms of a groomfeld opening
and groomford knowledge so h3 castle
bishop to e2 b6
castle and now we have bishop to b7 on
the board and there is a very easy way
in which white can continue and that is
to actually give up the pawn with the
move d5 now
black doesn't have to take it black can
just simply play the move knight to d7
or even queen to d6 and focus on the
idea of playing the move e6 and
targeting this uh over extended pawn on
d5 if white manages to stabilize the
position in the center as it is get this
rook off the long diagonal and then play
the move c4 white is going to have a
tremendous advantage you cannot allow
that to happen so queen to d6 focus on
the idea of playing e6 as fast as
possible is one option of course bishop
takes c3 should be the most a testing
option nevertheless you are falling and
you are allowing white to develop quite
a tremendous attack after bishop to h6
probably you have to go back rook to ea
doesn't make a lot of sense because i
can even uh bring my rook with temple
rook to c1 i don't even have to move the
rook if i want to so bishop to g7 makes
the most sense in my estimation take
take and now we have this position which
is actually developing into more of a
quiet position i gave up a pawn but your
pieces are a bit uh misaligned this
bishop on b7 not tremendous specifically
because of the pawn on d5 and you no
longer have the dark square bishop this
is the key um
factor in this position factor of
assessment because without a dark square
bishop your king is quite weak right so
what i'm going to try to do as white is
focus on the attack i'm going to expand
with h4 at the right moment stabilize
first once again stabilize with
potentially bishop to c4 stop you from
playing the move e6 at least momentarily
and then try to go h4 h5 put my rooks on
the central files and take it from there
you're going to have some difficulties
stabilizing the position as black in the
absence of the dark square bishop so
very very complex battle is going to be
ensuing in this game and it's all about
who knows this type of positions better
who is better prepared than right now
well
after bishop to b7 it seems like sophie
one hour and 31 minutes definitely
within her preparation it seems and
alice lee want to run 27 minutes so
let's see what happens in this one if
alice goes for d5 and sacrifices the
phone on c3 thank you for that christian
then just looking at the seniors event
larry christian versus maxim delugey
queen's gambit accepted really becoming
a very popular defense i see in these
championships maxim max has been playing
the queen's gambit accepted in his
entire career this certainly won't be a
surprise for larry but what has larry
prepared the game i wanted to draw your
attention to alejandra for just a second
i've always called this move knight
takes d4 queen b6 the benko
variation pal banco blazed
uh the trails for this what
you're laughing you're gonna think
exactly i can see the name of the
variation that leeches is giving it
right the godiva variety like the
chocolate godiva variation no no no no
no we just no
we don't accept it right exactly i mean
pal banco played this uh i mean in the
50s and 60s i've heard it called the
grievous sicilian because i mean guys
but grievous is like
50 years the junior
what uh i jumped in you don't know who
the the expert is in this line who's the
ex you're looking at it dude i played
that since i was 10 years of age so you
know i've learned it from the source
i've learned it from grievous himself
grievous taught me the student of the
grievous school of chess right but
grievous learned it from pal benko
probably
i mean come on now the the strangest
thing about this system that i learned
and i'm not even
an open sicilian guy
is that you don't play bishop e3 that
the move queen b6 was designed to push
the knight out of the center
and you're so often tempted to play the
move bishop e3 because you develop with
a gain of tempo but in truth the queen
is poorly placed
on b6 and i was told that you're
supposed to play king h1 f4 this queen
will voluntarily move anyway and you
kind of save
the question of where does my bishop
belong maybe it goes to g5 well i can't
tell you but we have the rest of an
expert exactly
let's let him have it
tell us
what's going on in the la in in the
position uh
christian so just to build up on your
point yes sir because it's a very
important point and yes you are right
king to h1 is uh one of the main lines
and no you're not going to leave the
bishop on c2 actually the difference uh
compared to the move bishop to e3 is
that you're going to develop the bishop
so let's say f4
king h1 king h1 sorry
castle f4 d6 queen f3
and now probably i have to go queen to
c7 it's at some point i'm going to lose
this move because i need to expand that
queen
b5 b4 and try to create some tension now
you're not going to leave the bishop to
go to g5 you're actually going to go
bishop to d2 and now the difference
between the bishop e3 and the bishop on
d2 is that
the follow-up is pretty obvious you're
going to get the rook from a1 to e1 and
that's going to be able to support a
potential push e5 in the center much
easier with the bishop on e3 e5 is very
very difficult to be
supported yes exactly so
also king2h1 is sometimes a very useful
move right because you're getting off
this diagonal you're also potentially
going to expand via it's all about the
expansion who's going to get uh to their
target first am i going to be able as
white to go g4 g5 and pretty much
checkmate you because i'm not very
subtle with white in this position g4 g5
queen h5 rook f3 rook h3 and try to
checkmate you that's my idea right put
as much pressure on the h-file as
possible black's idea on the other hand
is create tension on the queen side and
then respawn potentially in the center
as well once
you uncover your king so
these are the battles that we're seeing
now
on the other hand in my estimation um
queen to e2 is a much better option at
this point quintuito and i still haven't
found a clear way to equalize
this position
yes queen tuito and you will be able to
buy the dvd maybe who knows
grievous is
hurting to hear such words well in fact
grievous just published a book um an
update on his initial book on the grieva
sicilian recently so if you are curious
about what he recommends i'm sure he
won't be upset if you buy that book
queen to e2 bishop to e3 followed by
long castle uh this is a quite testing
for black so definitely queen to e2 is
one of them bishop to d3 has been played
and let's take a look because these
players are speeding up to uh through
the moves f4 d6 you cannot allow e5 once
again you have to respawn therefore with
d6 otherwise you're pretty much lost
queen to f3 and this is the position we
currently have on the board once again
i do believe uh that more testing is the
line that you showed yes sir with the
king on h1 and the bishop on d2 now we
have the bishop e3 and the rook on a1 so
let's see where this one takes us once
again
black is going to try to go b5 b5 is one
of the ways in which you can start you
can also start with the move knight to
b4 you can also just prepare for the
expansion on this side with the move
rook to e8 followed by bishop to f8 and
then g6 try to meet uh the onslaught
that white is going to deliver uh white
is forced to deliver the onslaught on
this side either with g4 g5 or with e5
or f5 at some point so there's all sorts
of breaks and you have to be ready with
the black pieces to meet them wonderful
thank you for that insight absolutely
feeling like an expert now in this bank
of greece right like let me in there
i'll take off the microphone i'm ready
to swing the paddies just want to turn
our attention to nick defermion and
alexander chevalov seems like the day of
the open sicilian usually we're seeing
bishop b5 check and all of these ways of
avoiding
c2c3 you know avoiding the open sicilian
not nick
he went for it uh no bishop b5 no
rasalimo he goes take takes and now i
want to again the naming for me i've
always associated bishop c4 with bobby
fischer but i've also associated this
position as like the vela merovich
attack you go like queen e2 bishop b3
and g4
uh yeah when i was growing up for me the
difference was that the villa
velomirovic was with knight bd7
instead of developing the knight through
c6 okay and then i knew it as the sozen
just because the soviets convinced you i
mean that's as i said when i was growing
up in costa rica a lot of our books were
directly translated from russian to
spanish right now going through english
right so they just you know whatever
they call but yeah exactly uh i knew i'd
like that and it it's it's again
the senior is really bringing the whole
theory right we were talking about
players of
that's decades ago exactly this is such
an unpopular line of the sicilian
currently especially for white
with bishop c4 bishop c4 i mean black is
supposed to be completely okay yeah i
remember an absolutely model game that
vasily ivanchak won against nick the
fermion where
nick played this early bishop c4 and
vasily played knight a6 to c5 to
neutralize the bishop many times this
bishop on c4 is eyeballing this e6 bond
so that sacrifices can be made as well
as f4 f5 we'll keep an eye on this but
where would you like to take us we have
to go to the wonderliang against
curiosity game because that one has
blown
up
now if it's good for carissa i don't
know okay h2h4 is where we left it
refresh oh sorry yes you're right
but that would mean if i refresh that
would update the game i know right right
crazy crazy concept
so we left it after c6 and yeah somebody
was saying old school i was like
how can that even be a move isn't like
e5 and g5 just like
e5 and h5 a dream
uh
you mean like right away like would you
just play e5 here you but it's oh hold
on
i'm sorry
it was a move earlier ah no then i've
got it wrong i i apologize mm-hmm we're
good now e5
g4 c4 okay
i've never seen this position in my life
i'm coming to get you so that i get g4
right and then
d6 makes sense you know battle in this i
don't know if it's good but why did you
play h5 if not to stop g4 you're
supposed to take it aren't you now check
out a wonders move
e6 isn't that a shocker oh my gosh he
played it instantly i'm assuming like
he's
right
but e6 e6 help us out here christian is
first of all
where's the novel where's the novelty
what's going on and is e6 a computer
engineer
novelty i mean this is novel play all
the way it
it hasn't been played as much in my
database in one of the games is mine uh
this has been played six times six so c6
h4 supposedly um so i played it against
sedora milov versus uh void kiavich from
2000 this is some really old-school uh
games right the 2000's
me love against curler in 1998 rochelle
in 1988 against austin these players
were alive
who knows yes who knows who the these
players are i know who milovis i don't
know who roshlaw is but
it's not supposed to be good for black
c6 is not supposed to be a good move
against bishop to e2 is specifically for
this reason because after h4 you're just
falling under tremendous attack now what
surprises me is that actually a wanderer
is just blitzing out his moves so
somehow he anticipated karissa to be
playing this move as c6 e5 knight to h7
g4
following up with the top
recommendations of the engine as well d6
and e6 once again
probably the top
engine move at this point now the idea
is clear right you have two options you
can take on h5 or you can go e6 either
way you're going to lose the e-pawn now
the question is what is the best way to
lose the e-pawn right is it with an
additional effort at destabilizing your
central structure after this pawn lands
on e5 and the response that the wonder
is giving us is that no i want to see
the dark square bishop closed for as
long as possible and i don't want to see
any tension against this very important
pawn central pawn on d4 so
what he does is he goes e6 first this
file stays closed for the moment bishop
takes e6 which hasn't been played yet
on g4
g4
g4 and what surprises me is that okay
she's not thinking as long as i would
expect her to be thinking this was a new
position right with so many
wild stuff happening right there you
have so many options as black take on g4
is a move i would expect bishop takes a
g for right now
is it on the board no no no no hg is our
last one why are you expecting this over
ef because i i felt ef once again uh ef
it does seem like it's just helping me
because i will take with the rook and
i'm going to have some counter chances
on the f file so bishop takes a g4 and
now once again it's all about activating
my pieces as fast as possible because i
know you're getting a tremendous attack
on this side i need to find my counter
chances your king as white is still in
the center that's true so where are you
going to castle
short side most likely not you're going
to be focusing either on leaving it in
the center or trying to go on the queen
side and if you do go on the queen side
i would love my bishop my dark sword
bishop to be open that's why i'm
focusing my attention in the center like
this so
well
there's liang i wonder the end of a
rating favorite coming into this event
he's been having a disastrous event up
to this point drew her uh his first one
actually he lost his first game drew at
the second and then lost again yesterday
what a miracle for abhimanyu that was
but right now he's out for blood i can
tell you that much
yeah i think that with the white pieces
looking at the second lowest seed in the
event
you gotta say hey
i got to write the ship right
sorry charissa
uh i need this point and uh boy
guns blazing at the start but of course
we've got to play our respects
to the tournament leaders
in the junior section i'm going to the
game of andrew hung uh versus uh
christopher you and that was the french
defense because i think christopher
doesn't really have the french in his
repertoire andrew hong against
christopher u exactly and i'm i'm saying
that uh the french i mean
after what andrew did yeah with his
first two white games i'm not playing
the sicilian i'm saying 10 10 feet away
from the sicilian aleandro i can see
that that seems to be the the prevailing
thought process there in the playing
hall and christopher does play the
french he doesn't play it very often
okay but i have seen him play french
before i think he's more of an e4e5
player um
i must have
what rook d1 is a surprise move for me
uh
probably still theory as far as i know i
remember i played the black side of this
against nick defermine back in the day
of the us championships i played it with
a a6 and b5 as black we made a draw but
rook d1
not that i know of okay i know long
castle i know bishop b2 i know d4
yeah those are very common rook d1 okay
i see it's still part of the database
and so
so we'll we'll we'll let the players
stew on this one where would you like to
take us well just a little note that
strong is thinking so that's the first
one for him with the white pieces as
christopher i would like cheer the fact
he got it he's actually slowed him down
you know andrew has been uh i think the
french was a bit of a surprise for
andrew it must have been right right
yeah because rook d1 actually there is
at least in this database there's no
more games that's it yeah that's it and
z1 is the novelty wow wow castle was
also not a move according to the
database and it was actually dtake c5
yes which was by far
exactly
exactly d4 takes c4 which is surprising
i mean rook d1 is a very natural move
right it's
it's okay it's an okay move
you're signaling the fact that you're
probably going to take the king either
to f2 or castle shortside right
but rook d1 for me is one of those moves
where you're being a little bit too
clever for your own good in other words
i think you're going to take on c5 and
you want to control the d4 square right
whereas you know i think you really want
to play bishop e2 and castle short or
play d4 take c5 for me uh the questions
are okay first of all can black
counter punch in the center
because again
you're one two moves away from castling
and maybe there's an issue let me make a
very very bad move i apologize to
everybody who plays the white side of a
sicilian pardon me white side of this
french dinettes i mean you've got to be
careful that your center just doesn't
fall apart
if your bishop was on e2 if your king
was castled these exchange sacrifices
probably would not be working but f7 f6
might just
question the move rook d1
like uh
so this is your first thing that was my
first instance yeah can i can i counter
uh the i mean probably you have to take
on f6 take on f6 yeah exactly what else
are you gonna do and i take
and probably you're going to take on c5
sure like what else are you going to do
take on c5
and now
can i use the fact that your king is
still in the center to do
something if i can great if i can't i'll
take it all back uh let's go to g1 i
shift to g1 and now
so h3 so if i can't play e5 is the
problem right
so i'm
thinking you would play h3 you're really
trying to stop me from i'm trying to
stop you from castle and making a
i'm sacrificing a pawn
but the king is in the center i have
reasons that i might want to pursue
these
types of ideas
in any case
rook d1
novel
novel move cool
again where would you like to take this
novelty and
let's stick with this one for just a
second to try to understand the nuances
of the position because there are so
many ways in which both sides can play
especially uh white as you mentioning
and you guys gave a lot of moves right
castle long route to d1 queen to f2
bishop to e2 d4 there's a lot of d takes
c5 of course which is uh the main line
what are the differences compared to the
main line for example so
rook to d1 and this is what i wanted to
ask you what is your first instinct my
first instinct as a black as a player
that doesn't play the french would be to
go b5
to try to create some sort of initiative
on this side unfortunately with a rook
on d1 it doesn't seem like
b5 is a great move because after we take
take now queen to f2 and you have to
retreat you have to go to d7 knight to
e4 is no longer an option not only that
but generally you reinforce this knight
on c5 with the move b7 to b6
in certain cases that one is no longer
possible because you already extended
with b5 so
it's more of a waiting move more of a
reinforcing move on the default
potentially after queen to f2n the
opening of the d-file we could see a lan
a knight land on e4 taking advantage of
the fact that uh the pawn on d5 is
pinned on the d-file so
definitely an intriguing move and right
now christopher u
is
trying to understand what the
differences are based on what he
knows about the position
right
again two things that would come to my
mind right away as black one would be
the capture
on d4
c5 takes d4 knight takes d4 knight takes
d4 bishop takes d4 again i do want to
counter strike in the center with f6
especially as again your two moves away
from castling bishop b2 or bishop d3
uh if you take you're still
uh
not castling the pawn on f4 is a bit of
a weakness and the other thing that the
the second thing as a french defense
player i would have in mind is the move
b7 b6 a moment ago you saw me
sacrificing the pawn on c5 with the move
b7 b6 essentially i'm telegraphing the
idea of f6 and again we're seeing
that the center kind of blowing up if i
can ever provoke d4 take c5b takes e5
then i think white's going to regret the
fact that he captured on c5 so i see b6
f6 i see the immediate f6 i see d4 take
c5 and christopher is certainly weighing
those three
choices i'm kind of kind of warming up
actually the more i look at it to the
move b7 b6
i like b7 and b6 it's a kg move because
b5 seems to correct because it just gets
the space
when you analyze it a little bit deeper
right right now it's a little bit deeper
it's actually the dark squares that end
up being weakened for black exactly and
the committal move b5 you just can't
take it back
you're going to be wait you're going to
be worried about your dark squares
forever on the queen side i like i like
b6 a lot maybe we can update some of the
other games let's look at the marquee
matchup that we have in the seniors okay
uh between larry christensen and maxine
deluge and that was the uh queen's
gambit accepted that's when we left it
maybe you can give us a couple of
insights of this position uh for sure
with the move bishop e2 bishop b7 a4
b4
knight d7 knight
i mean knight d2 knight d7 and fe-5
knight fe-5
okay i like what white is doing i like
what white is doing you play this
against la mi exactly
and i played it very well i had a very
nice advantage
where was that play game played was it a
dutch league i don't know what does it
say it doesn't say okay just as it was
in 2003. okay uh yeah no i mean
obviously from a white's perspective
it's all about
trying to use
i want to say just a slight advantage in
development my king is already castled
uh on a good day b3 bishop b2
but more importantly i think bishop f3
in a fight for this long diagonal
is what white wants and by the way let
me just update the moves after knight d7
are both players playing very quickly it
feels like they are bishop e7 came
afterwards i think pretty
look at that for seven minutes on bishop
e7 well
but
and look at him go i mean he is like he
knows this position he plays bishop d5
more or less with a
for a firm like i got this and it's not
such a natural move right it does invite
knight c6 it certainly does
i should actu it doesn't matter let's
just have a quick gander this one i'm
guessing i guess you take
everything
like seven i think
no no
i think you play queen c7 right right
well now with this guy hanging i think i
take
why don't i take on e7 sorry i was oh
it is hanging also yeah holy smokes
there's a lot of captures going on right
right takes
takes
at the end of the day you do have queen
takes a6 if not bishop f3 i think white
is better
okay so wait a minute what's going on
knight c6
uh i have to take it then
uh bishop takes i mean you could take on
e7 i guess but
like directly
sorry uh
queen c7
could i consider it just
yes it's illegal
uh does look a little
funny yeah
keep the key there i mean
i'm wondering why
what is the compensation i'm having for
keeping the king there right well
there's two things you need compensation
for first of all the two bishops second
of all why is your king at the center i
don't like it i don't know i don't like
this but maxim is
playing like he must have been here
done that um christian jump in
this is a very peculiar twist we're
seeing in this queen's gambit accepted
yes absolutely i wasn't watching that
game at all i have to say i was looking
at the game in the grievous sicilian of
course that's got your attention from
the senior section as well and it does
seem like
white has a slight a slight edge in the
game that you guys were looking at the
one between christensen and maxim bluge
probably not that much um it doesn't
matter six we wanted to play yes knight
c6 is a perfectly playable move of
course queen to c7
we were taking
c7 and i take
three and we liked white after b3 right
right right right it's probably a good
position for uh white nevertheless
bishop takes c4 seems to be at least
from an objective point of view
evaluation uh equalizing after rook two
c8 or at least creating a balance in the
position zero zero it's it's still a
very complex position two bishops
against two knights is always complex
absolutely so um
despite the fact that it's zero zero
forget about it yeah it's going to be a
game a very very complex game now let's
take a look at what's happening in the
kaidano versus akopian uh game because a
lot of things have happened after
looking a to e1 b5 as we were expecting
white uh is trying to attack on this
side black is trying to develop on the
queen side king to h1 bishop to b7 queen
to h3 again not very subtle yeah e5
e5 and i i'm threatening to give you a
check mate right so you have to defend
against that
one way to do that is to interfere on
this diagonal with the move g6 or to
play the move knight to b4 take
advantage of the fact that a3 is not yet
on the board and you can target the b
spawn d3 now the problem is you are
losing a couple of tempes also after you
do take on d3 which will happen because
actually white forced matters with the
move a6 knight takes e3 c takes d3 a lot
of things have changed and the whole
character of the position has changed
because
now i'm no longer looking to attack you
on the king side anymore i'm actually
looking to put some pressure on the c
file and in the center
focus on the pawn e6 and try to create
weaknesses structural weaknesses in your
position so
from
what i remember from uh my days of
analyzing this position i haven't
analyzed it in quite a while is that
white generally is quite happy with this
position uh e5 was definitely not in my
notes akopian just played it
in my notes was more or less waiting for
you to try to force me to play e5 rook
e8 was one of the ways trying to go rook
to c8 and put some pressure on the c
file was another way
a5 just giving up upon like that was uh
another move if i remember correctly and
this is uh seems to be the best move in
the position as well a5 with the idea to
go b4 try to destabilize this knights
for white and try to invade via the c
file after that so that's one way in
which black could have played he played
the movie e5 now this begs the question
what if i just continue with rook to c1
where do you put the queen right because
you don't have the b6 square
you cannot uh go on that side if you go
queen to b8 this looks extremely passive
queen to d7 probably yes but how do we
assess this end game
after knight to a5 i'm not liking this
one at all
i'm going to take uh get rid of the
bishop on b7 follow it up with the move
knight to d5 and this is a play for two
results i have full control over the c
file
no actually the more i look at it this
is looking horrendous
for uh black so you cannot allow that i
guess after rook to c1 you have to go
queen to d8 but once again queen to d8
doesn't strike me as a great placement
for the queen
especially and if i remember correctly
one of the ways in which
black could have played was actually to
go rook fc8 first and that would prepare
the move queen to d8 right because at
least the connection between the rooks
is going to remain intact uh in this
particular fashion so
e5
i'm uh
i'm concerned about this move i don't
like it
um i think he doesn't know exactly what
to do and i have a feeling white is just
slowly slowly getting a very stable and
significant advantage so
this one was another game that i was
looking at first of all let's update
this one
between alice lee and sophie mori suzuki
and maybe you guys can take it over
what has happened after queen to d3 d5
was not played
no sacrifice on c3 c takes d4 c takes d4
and now black had a way to win a pawn
and i'm actually kind of confused why
she didn't go for it and that is bishop
to a6 bishop a6 you have to remove the
queen from that diagonal take take on d4
knight takes d4 and by the way this has
been played quite a few times and it
does seem like this position leads to a
very balanced position equal
by
the estimation of a lot of engines so
also by the games
i'm a bit curious why she didn't go for
this she went for knight to d7 but after
bishop f4 knight to f6 knight to d2 it
seems as if white has stabilized and i'm
just going to be able to focus my
attention on the c file play the move d5
when if you allow me to do that and if
you don't what are you how are you going
to stop me with the movie e6 i don't
think you want to do that because once
you play the movie 6 this d6 square is
going to be a big problem for you i'm
going to stabilize with f3 close the
diagonal for the bishop follow it up
with the move knight to c4 knight to d6
i'm starting to like white's position in
this one guys what do you have yeah well
very stable looking advantage in the
center with the central fondues duo's i
find my eye drawn to the game of nick
defermion versus alexander shabalov
i don't know what the current theories
are but i remember as a teen looking at
these what i would call the ultra sharp
double-edged sicilians and uh they're in
a very hot looking kitchen what what do
you think alejandro about this position
it's one of those positions that people
kind of started to shy away from this
battles that clash immediately crashing
immediately right you see this position
black is down in development and bla
white is using the fact that black is
low in development to just try to crash
through exactly queen f3 bishop b3 f5 is
ready f5 is played it was played in the
game there's not a lot of subtlety here
for the right side no there really isn't
i found my eye drawn to the move e5 and
i was just going down some
rabbit hole
uh of modern chess theory the crazy part
is when you see these open sicilians
where you see a move like e5 and you
think to your yourself oh my god you
know everything is explosive and it's
it's it's an amazing game
whenever there's just really really
sharp tactical calculating lines it
always ends up at zero zeros
on a perpetual right and f5 and uh f5
played yeah uh assuming it's well
is e5 no
e5 has to be the move here right or do
you take on b3 i don't know if it
matters
it might it might matter right if you
take on b3 first a takes b3
and then there's a tempo
on the b5 pawn right but is there
yes
for example i have two options right i
can go e4 but i could also consider
going e5 if i take on b5 and i go queen
b7 and let's say your knights on a3 uses
vashnikov
yeah but you're missing the b5 pawn i
don't know i mean this is how people
play this facility nowadays right like
why doesn't you should see i don't know
i don't know if it's good here but i
like saying that before you can throw
him before wait let's let's show you
with that one so c5 take on b5 why not
queen c6
okay and then bishop b7 and how do you
defend the pawn on e4 okay you know
you're talking yeah
yeah you you got my attention there uh
christian yeah i like that but wait a
minute wait a minute you got to go down
the rabbit hole you're here and now you
have knight d5
nice trick yup so knight takes e4 is met
with knight e5 that's important yeah
very important yes
in seattle we call this a fork yeah this
time
a barbaric northern west
an infraction in st louis um it was
super cool a double-edged position but i
got to tell you guys my my instant
reaction is
theory the theory books have worked
these uh
double edged positions out to some kind
of uh
uh quality but you can you know that
neither one of these players has any
clue right who's bluffing the best is uh
what's going on here and if you're if
you're uh
part of our audience are wondering why
is this not played at the candidates
level and stuff like that objectively
these sows and sicilians they're not
they're not sure sicilians please
whatever the fish are so sincere
they're not holding up too well no for
the white side that's correct yeah the
engines really have thought that the
black positions are doing very well
despite the lack of development taking
that bishop on b3 really puts such a
capacity to the attack in so many
variations right that people are not
afraid to play this as black now that
being said it's still a really cool and
interesting game there's not like white
of course
yeah no question about it i just noticed
by the way in our marquee matchup
between larry christensen and maxine
delugi
our two tournament co-leaders
well one of the trio i should say uh
the move bishop d5 has
caught larry and he's just stopped he
has not responded so he's probably into
what something like a 10-minute thing at
the moment
it's something like that it's ticking
time's ticking away 11 minutes i think
an 11 minute thing i also wanted to jump
to dimitri gervais versus igor novikov
boy they played it really slowly
i mean i seen this position many eons
ago check
not going for the
what do you call this gambit marshall
you have it
you're talking about frank marshall the
other day yeah you remember
he's got his he's got his name
associated with a number of gambits too
i think there's also a martial gambit in
the dutch defense
marshall david and the touch defense i
do believe there's a marshall gambit in
the dutch is that the one that goes like
d5 f5 e4 yeah that's the marshall yeah
with knight c3 and f3 at least giving up
upon in the center consistent right yeah
exactly there he goes
and uh but he did pardon me demon did
not do that he dropped back with the
knight uh safe variation i want to say i
mean i hate repeating myself at the old
school lineup right
right
the quiet this is the funny thing about
igor navikov i think this is something
that you see less nowadays mvl probably
one of the last bastions of this style
of chess where you just play one opening
your entire
life
no deviations no ramifications you just
study one thing you know it better than
everybody else you get out prepared once
in a while you'll lose some gains to
preparation but
very often you get out prepared and you
just know the position so well
and you save a fortune on an opening
library yeah exactly you don't have to
buy the banco campaign books
by the open sicilians and igor has been
playing the slav and this is
specifically the triangle system without
knight f6 right and specifically
the e6 variation of the night or not all
the night or right
e6 i did hear of a story i don't know if
it's true or not that igor navikov got
invited to one of those high-level
soviet camps okay he's there to
work with one of the high-level people
right he was invited because he was a
known knighter of expert okay
and they wanted to look at this line
with the english attack bishop e3 e5
okay igor said i've never played e5 in
my life
and he was playing he was playing tennis
the rest of
the rest of the weekend
nice i see that you've got the carissa
yep game uh going there we got it
updated it's a fascinating struggle it's
not immediately obvious to me that white
has
that much for the pawn i mean i saw the
engine
evaluation that uh christian had bishop
takes jesus that bishop takes and they
wanted to go bishop takes e6
i think we were focused mainly on no no
we we like bishop g4 okay yeah christian
was saying that's important
uh to keep the central a little bit
controlled i thought f5 was a pretty
logical response to bishop takes g4 yeah
i mean you
you want to capture on e6
with the bishop of bishop right and not
suffer a double pawn and uh
yeah be able to deal against h5 so you
do bishop takes e6 this is the current
position okay uh black has a clean pawn
up even you could even argue the better
structure as well
no no question about it yeah so
it's it's a race it's a race to see if
black checkmate okay you cannot wonder
liang chuck made karisa yet before she
gets her pieces out exactly yeah and do
we let let's go let's let's ask the
question
like that but let's say that we do let's
say that we play h5 i think it's such a
logical move oh yeah sorry i was trying
to play h5 and it was like the arrow
took over sorry i apologize i don't know
if we want a sidestep this is black i
have the feeling that we do g5 i think
g5 makes a lot of sense right right just
try to keep it keep it close as much as
possible right
now the question that i wanted to say is
how do i rip it open that's a question
right because if you even try to move f4
i can just keep closing things i don't
have to actually take it's not checkers
i can close the position with you closed
no i'm not i'm not happy about that at
any knight move i think i answered with
f4
just to shut your pieces okay my bishop
on c1 is kind of crying i get that maybe
rook g1 yes but g4 is a problem
g4 f3 and it's me who's attacking your
f4 g4 no no no after f4 after f4 that
i'm threatening you you mean if i play
rook chief jihan then g4 g4 is an issue
right wow suddenly this pause march
well it's kind of
funny
you want to play are you sure you want
to play f3
i mean there is an issue isn't there on
the g file could be potentially
if you take i mean i was going to right
yeah maybe too happy right you got
yourself excited there against rook g1
but i don't know what the problem is
if i go bishop f6 then you take on f4
right so
h6 which page six is the only move but
then knight t4
knight e4 pardon me knight e4 right yeah
well here it feels like i'm getting i'm
prying
the king's side open i think we didn't
see something you get a pawn you get
your palm back
am i that scared at the end are you or
[Laughter]
uh i was i thought i was getting at your
king this looks good for white
does it huh i feel like yes you wanted
to go back uh christian please i just
don't like this so h5 g5 play by the way
the move knight f3 uh maybe prepping
perhaps i'm a smarter way to do things
right because it's just to make sure
that yeah that h5 there's no g5 yeah it
makes sense it makes a lot of sense but
why not knight h3 is my question with
ideas even of h5 but also knight f4
i don't like the knight on f3 also this
knight on f3 is blocking the action of
the bishop and the queen so h5 is is not
as supported i understand the rook is
now supporting h5 after knight f3 but
sometimes you're never recapturing with
the rook i am sympathetic to knight h3 i
can easily imagine
that uh
variations with h5 my knight would be
uh on f4 beautifully placed on f4 with
or without d4 d5 this is a this is
shaping up as a really great game dare i
ask you christian what the engine's
evaluation is after knight f3 let's take
a look
all right so knight to f3 it still seems
to be very good favorable for white plus
one plus one
really yeah and
give us let's say the next
three best moves of the engine for both
players e7 makes a lot of sense why not
develop the pieces and also support e5
at the right moment getting some pieces
closer to the king route to g1 not h5
but rook
h5 no so if you go h5 which is also an
option i will take on h5 and now finally
we understand why this knight is coming
closer to the king right because i'm
going to support all my pieces after
knight df6 um continue the line knight
g5 for just a moment knight g5 i take
this is always a bit problematic
i wanted to play bishop takes h5 of
course maybe sex geez
i'm doing my own thing on this side and
you're not in time
it doesn't seem like you're in time
still complicated position by the way
even broke the g1
by the way bishop f7 none of this will
happen she played a very logical move in
my opinion bishop s7 yeah it does two
things right maybe even three things it
defends g6
it prevents
i don't know if it prevents it but it
makes h5 less appealing okay and
it allows you to play the move e5 where
i
think
she's starting to think well where's my
counter play i have more pawns in the
center at some point i'll hint that this
is a move exactly
so it doesn't actually uh stop me from
playing h5 because
it's quite easy to see that after knight
h4 it's a double attack you're going to
regain your pawn right
and i'm sure a wonder is calculating
this type of situation well i think it's
actually forced h5 h5 because if not the
best move no no no
h5 already played i mean i i i the panel
here agrees i don't i know the computer
what did they go but i mean not playing
h5 here is insane h5 from a practical
perspective makes a lot of sense right
you play the move knight f3 exactly
anticipate the move bishop to f7 and you
know that you want to play h5 to get the
knight to h4 makes a lot of sense
correct g takes h5 is pretty much forced
at this point but what did the computer
like beside h5 g1 rook g1 was
supposedly a better alternative
nevertheless h5 is quite close to it
okay so um rook to g1 king to h8 and
knight g5 this was a different idea try
to open up the h wow
um h5 was played take knight to h4 we
assume that this is going to come on the
board and by the way once again
knight h4 is not the only move queen to
c2 or queen to d3 to try to put some
pressure on f5 is another way but
once again from a practical perspective
from a human's point of view knight h4
is almost on automatic right e6 and
bishop takes h5 how do we assess this
position how close is white to
checkmating the black king
how close is black from stabilizing the
position and just being a pawn up this
is a big question i somehow i think that
black is doing okay because the knight
on h4 doesn't feel comfy okay i like the
knight on f4 let's play some moves
i think right
i mean this one's queen to f6 if you can
go back to christians yes queen two four
six percent board for a second because
this is such a crucial
queen of six i see the i see the engine
behind you the engine loves wise
positions for whatever reason so bishop
takes f7 and queen h5 an immediate
attack do you have a threat immediate
attack
i would assume knight g6 might be a
problem
i would assume knight g6 as well right i
mean i'm trying to use the h file but
okay let's go like knight df 97 knight
d7 the best move yes and now i actually
go knight to f3
so knight on knight
something to f8 i don't even know which
one like this let's say knight d2 yeah i
was trying to defend g5 right yeah right
yeah so it's actually a slow play
situation it seems like i'm just going
to go rook to g1 then i'm going to put
the bishop on e3 and then i'm going to
go long castle perhaps no e5 but e5 is
going to be
e5 and then this this bishop h6
it feels like black has anticipated
that's the way i kind of well black's up
for fun
right as well right
i'm kind of chilling i'm gonna go kate
one day and absolutely absolutely no i i
don't see this and by the way the engine
once again is saying that white is doing
tremendously well in this position but
from a human's perspective it doesn't
feel that way right
i i feel the opposite of a gorilla
whatever is the opposite of that
yeah
and what an important game it is for
both of these players alejandro yeah a
start that has been less than stellar
for both karissa had two nice draws with
the black pieces but fell to brown white
pieces jacobson sword yesterday in a
sharp italian and i wonder liang just
having a disaster of a tournament losing
his first game against justin wang
drawing his second game but the big
surprise yesterday against api manu
mishra
not just drawing a completely one
position but actually losing the whole
point i mean again going from a position
a wonder liang had that was plus ten
to minus four in one move it's not like
you blundered your queen it's like you
blundered two queens in one move i mean
that was an extraordinary turnaround it
was very very very painful for us to
watch uh let's jump to sophie's game uh
yes
it's painful for her to play it yeah
exactly for sure
poor commentators i wanted to sorry i
just jumped to the uh girl section for
just a moment because we had this really
super crazy game that was going on
between rochelle and talia the move e5
is kind of where we left it where we
were looking at bishop takes e5 and i
was stunned to realize
that a lot of lot of top but really
really big names have been playing it
strangely enough uh rochelle re actually
recaptured on e5 with her pawn d4 takes
i don't think this is a lie i was about
to say uh the very different approach
you put her knight
g1 knight
to c3
and says okay on a good day i'm gonna
play bishop e2 castles and i'm gonna
have a tremendous grip on the center we
have 97 on the board oh a challenging
position there is
i'm anticipating bishop b2 well i was
thinking of knight takes b5 works but it
just doesn't work so i don't know what i
was talking about knight takes b5 looks
like a tactic but i mean the first
impressions are like can't i take the
pawn sorry yeah but bishop takes d5 i
think just stops stops everything right
yes
bishop c6 yeah yeah honestly
okay bishop
isu one side castles the other side
castles yep yep yep i really like
black's position
i think that if i go knight c6
the knight on b8 to c6 knight b8 to c6
yep i can see that you want to make a
home knight d4 i think it's a threat
knight g6 starts becoming a thread
just simply clipping clipping the pawn
on e5
um
i'm
looking at knight f6 checks i'm already
feeling like
talia is the first to connect her rook
so
okay
super super sharp game uh alice lee
let's go to alice lee
now
again alice comes into the event
a little bit of a favorite kind of a
dark horse everybody loves alice of
course
uh but she started badly yeah no you
can't under overestimate how badly her
start was and that she still has one
point out of three speaks to her
resilience as a player exactly more than
how she's been able to handle the
positions in this event now she's on the
black side of a grunfeld defense where
really
pardon me uh the white side of a
grunfeld defense where opponent has
really given her the
the opportunity to
advance in the center with the move a d4
d5 i love advancing with space but i
believe it was actually christian we
just mentioned that you know what you
can do is you can play the move f3
um
you know say the wall uh uh on e4 is not
going to be broken but why not d5 first
specifically in this movie and d5
already played by
listening to
f3 in general i wanted to play after e6
oh yes because you were mentioning that
f3 e6 then you would go knight c4
remember there was a connection with
that but d4 d5 i like alice's position
uh i've always liked the space and uh i
see
um where my pieces are going so to speak
knight to c4 we always compare this to
what we normally see right what is what
is this compared to a normal groomfield
exactly and it feels that unless you get
e6 in
right this second right
you're going to have a bad group field
you're just going to be in a position
where you don't have a lot of space yeah
and white is going to have the ability
to maneuver around whether it be knight
f3 to
e5 or knight to c4 to e5
something right right and for the moment
as often happens in the grunfeld you're
not utilizing your queenside bonds so i
feel like my majority in the center is
giving me a
significant pull we'll see i think that
if you play e6 i don't actually see
anything wrong with just pushing it
let's go
we can maybe even anchor them
that pawns is two squares away from
coronation and most importantly my pick
to win uh the girls section was uh
jennifer you she was the three proud
recipient yesterday of a free point yeah
a free half point um takes on d4 takes
on d4 knight to e4
knight to b5 knight to e4 knight to be
fun phil's are we still in theory by the
way because this is not a groomful actor
it feels artificial though for white
right yeah it's very artificial for
white like why am i moving my knight all
around also what happens if i go e5
does she have a good reply to e5 excuse
me right she's already playing she's
already playing knight takes c3 but e5
is a
darn good question if you ask me
if i have to play bishop g3 you will
take and i presume play d4 that looks
very good i could also pour black or
black i could also throw in like queen
a5 or some move like that that might be
time i'm not that dangerous right i'm
not happy christian jennifer might have
what do you think on e4 after e5 i
thought i could take on f4 and take on
d5 sorry wha
[Music]
how is that position
and what did he do so take on e4 first
but here right here yes yeah but i
wanted to take on
f4 you take i take on e5 on d5
oh man i was like looking at f takes e3
bishop
i love black's position ah but now but
now he's defending right what i'm just
trying to defend uh
right what does the engine think of uh
of e5 instead uh pardon me again zoe has
already taken us knight to take c3 which
can't be a bad move
we think an opportunity missed e5
but very close to knight c3 and then e5
yeah but this also looks good now that i
think about it you still can go but e5
was by far the best and it's happened
knight takes c3 e5 knight takes c4 that
was actually the variation that we were
looking at knight take c4 take on f4 and
take on d5 bishop takes b2 or f takes e3
all of them were working at this point
and yeah
right pretty much a decisive advantage
at this point that's what i thought
minus 2.1 uh
big big big moment uh knight 63 was
played but e5 was the follow-up which is
still very right direction okay still
the right direction open up
let's go let's go
and d4 is on the board by the way right
so yeah
it does seem like zoe tang has the
advantage and has the potential of
actually upsetting the rating favorite
in this one
with the black pieces this would be a
huge result yeah i was just going to say
that jennifer's opening play looks very
very shaky in this game i don't like
what she's done whatsoever and i think
to be frank jennifer's opening play has
been shaky every single game yeah
yesterday only
position right she goes g5 h5 and just
kind of comes to a full stop against
talia uh she didn't get anything
anything she played her opponent but got
nothing from the opening she outplayed
her later on yes and then she got all
played herself but still out of the
opening nothing right
okay uh
and let me just check in on talia's game
yep we're expecting uh bishop e2 in
castle's castles right um
ellen this game oh oh back to the neo
vienna yes
for your course man i mean for those of
you who don't know uh
for 19.99 a month i mean it's
how could you say no the best 1999
you're ever going to spend and did you
did you suggest these positions what's
going on i actually looked at this
position exactly in this in this video
course so the ladies could have learned
from your video oh and what did you
prescribe uh what's happening in this
exact position i actually remember uh
you i remember this position exactly
after the move knight d2 okay and knight
d2 is
it's slightly mistimed
okay and then she played it and she
played it yeah when ellen plays 92
slightly missed time there are other
dangerous moves in the position okay i'm
not going to like go through all of them
but right including knight c3 right away
is it's a dangerous way of playing for
for an advantage 92 here is particularly
if i remember this correctly
it's particularly badly timed because
knight takes e3 f2 c3 usually solidifies
this uh center for white right
but i think it's in this position that
the move bishop g5 has switched c5 c5 is
okay as well yeah but bishop g5
asks a very uncomfortable question what
are you going to do with your problem
what are you going to do how are you
going to defend the party i have no
choice i'm looking at rook f3 to the
exclusion of everything else and then
you drop down the bishop
with bishop c7 and then again you say
well yes i don't want to move i i'll
hang around you could hang around but
then you lose your tension on e4 on c4
on c4 sorry and this this spin is
annoying true
true true so uh i have to move the rook
but black is fine because your rook is
now i'm not a happy camper like why did
i rook over would have been great if i
had bishop on h7
okay this is uh
this is this is good stuff and christian
let's turn it to you what has caught
your eye well actually i was looking at
the game of david brotzky versus brandon
jacobson and we haven't checked this one
uh yet but it does seem like brandon is
getting an advantage once again with the
black pieces in a joke of piano
yesterday against karissa he came with
an incredible preparation and got the
normal winning position after rook takes
f3 uh and that exchange sacrifice let's
see what happened today so c3 d6
a6 a4
not
right not rook to e1 followed by knight
to d2 what we've seen yesterday from
karissa which was wrong once you play
rook to e1 castle you have to start with
h3 not allow the move knight to g4 right
knight to d2 and check this move out
knight to h5
immediately knight to h5 and there's
been three games three players
yes with the move knight to h5 castle
hundreds of games h6 a very normal
alternative as well knight to e7
still pretty normal knight to h5 i've
never seen this move in my life it has
been played at the top level by
alexander pratke from russia in 2018 who
by the way is a very very good
politician so definitely brandon
jacobson is taking a page from uh
pretzek pretka's recommendations knight
to h5 d4 knight to f4 g3 and by the way
not only that he surprises his opponent
but he's putting tremendous pressure
early on this knight to h5
knight to f4 is not a neutral maneuver
right no i'm getting very close to your
king with the knight on f4 very
aggressive uh maneuver and also if you
just stay still i'm going to go g5 next
g5 g4 this is the way that i'm going to
try to break your structure in front of
your king g3 knight to h3 is on the
board king to g2 h6
and now we have the move knight to h4
what do you do after knight g5
this is turning into a uh
melee a tactical melee right now because
i have a clear threat bishop to h3 right
right how do you defend against i assume
knight f5 i was thinking about rook to
e1 i2 f5 i understand it's it's the top
engine move locking but after g6
are you sure you want to start
calculating this no you have to go f4 by
the way oh my word if you don't go f4
then you're in trouble so you have to go
f4 and then we go into this type of
crazy stuff oh my goodness yes i'm not
really sure what's happening right now i
understand i'm probably going to get
this pawn and in return what i managed
to do as white is block the dark square
bishop because there's no more pawn on
e5 there's no more um attention and no
way to open it up at the same time the
g-file is opening up
all towards your king so
let's wait and see what's going to
happen and by the way none of this
will happen in fact because knight to f4
came on the board after knight to h4
can you take probably not after queen
takes h4 bishop
h3 is coming also queen h3 followed by
bishop to g4 is coming this one is not
looking good so knight to f4 almost king
h1
right right yeah so how do you continue
now as black bishop h3 is one of the
ways i like
queen f6 from a practical point of view
i don't know guys but it feels to me
like if i'm playing against brandon
jacobson i'm going to stay away from the
joker
piano
i mean you know this guy is dangerous he
really is
on
the black side of the joco pianos he
came
well prepared in his matchup with
carissa yesterday and
it looks like he really caught david
brodsky unawares
as well as ourselves knight h5 come on
never seen it and it's a it's a
wonderful idea just this early
aggression i didn't even knew
you're like we needed a new theory in
this right right like we needed new
ideas right they seem to be endless they
really do seem to be endless
true
true remarkable as we're preparing
ourselves for our first break i mean
it's uh it's important that we update
our viewers about cue boutique
absolutely we saw that beautiful open
from pew boutique that's the
location but you can visit us online
cubitiquestl.com we have all kinds of
apparel for you and today specifically
we have a chess capital usa t-shirt yeah
baby celebrate city of st louis the
official chess capital of the united
states there's a document out there that
says that and you see the back there
with uh all the logos of the st louis
chess club campus including the world
chess hall of fame and q boutique
they're available only at
qboutiquestl.com
mentioned that yasser sarah won't send
you and you'll get a five percent and
they'll try five more dollars
a tip it's a tip for our staff and as we
get ready for break we're gonna we asked
the players in the seniors
what's it like for them coming or
returning to st louis and playing chess
here are their answers
how does it feel to once again be back
in st louis playing in this prestigious
event oh it's always great to be here
i hope to be invited in the near future
as well um
and i'll do my best that's all i can say
very well i mean i'm the first time here
in general
and first time i see the chess club
i'm very happy to have this opportunity
to
play in
this tournament
heard too much about of course all these
events and it's always very beautiful to
be a part of it
always when i come
to saint louis it's
great
very nervous
yeah this is probably
the most important tournament of the
year
uh nervous and excited at the same time
it feels incredible it's my first time
in saint louis and i
felt fantastic when i qualified to be
here and i was really looking forward
and i'm happy to be here always awesome
to get back to saint louis it feels like
a second home
for many years and
well aspirations are always flying high
and we'll see what's going on it's
always great coming back here
it's a tournament that i look forward to
all year long
and
i hope that i can show some good form
here oh it's fantastic i mean this is
the mecca of chess the place to be and
you you get such a warm welcome here
it's the best place to be for chess well
i was here three years ago before the
pandemic it was a lot of fun i haven't
played a
nice round-robin tournament in
ages before that so this is always a
nice opportunity to play as you prepare
for the games
i mostly coach now so this is a great
opportunity to try to
play and feel how it is for my students
um
and
like actually uh
a couple of my former students actually
playing in the in the journey event here
so um i'll be watching how they do and
uh
i'm gonna enjoy it
wonderful i feel great to be here yeah
i've been playing here a few times and
us championship long time ago 12 years
ago and played on the tournament four
years ago it was always great it's a
great place to be
and also it's wonderful to see my old
friends
some of them from
londongo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody we're here round
four of our championships the us junior
us junior girls and seniors are still
going on we don't have any results so
far so let's take a look at where we
stand
and our pairings for this round four and
the girls yeah the big matches we
believe are going to be rochelle wu
against talia cervantes currently in
second place but alice lee seems to be
nursing a small advantage with the white
pieces against sophie mori suzuki our
perfect leader with three out of three
points and in the juniors in the juniors
we have a huge matchup as christopher
you is defending the black pieces
against andrew hung in a complex french
this is going to be definitely the one
that we take our look at but we've been
fascinated as well by a struggling a
wander liang who seems to be going all
out against carrick yep sacrificing
already two pawns and on the hunt
absolutely all in yeah seriously
absolutely and in the seniors in the
senior section we have a battle of
leaders as larry christensen with two
points is facing maxine dulugi with two
as well and we are keeping an eye a
close eye on two important matchups as
well gravish against navikov and i wanna
see the game between grisha kaidanov and
vladimir akopian
really a lot of nice games going on
before we get into all of that however
i've got a question for the panel and we
welcome of course our viewers to ask us
any questions you like through the
social media there's lots of ways to get
in touch with us sabine foiser is
monitoring uh the chats and this is how
you can do it ask the commentators
uh we have joined the conversation with
tweet at st louis chess club you can ask
all of your questions here on chat we
are on twitch we're on youtube we are on
instagram we're even on facebook guys we
know all but tell very little i wanted
to join
and just to show something
we never really see david brodsky
walking a lot but he doesn't take a page
out of the larry christensen school of
walking no not so much
you got to walk 10 000 steps a day
according to larry and larry's trying to
pad his numbers
uh
he likes to take a walk but he never
really straves too far away from his own
board
yeah were you a walker at the board oh i
was totally a walker really oh i i
couldn't sit at the board when i was a
young player i make my move and bolt
like it was just like this
okay i wanted to turn our attention to
the game of pedro before we do that guys
breaking news right now
alice lee just blundered into a
completely losing position
d5 was played queen to a4 and now you're
setting up a trap
a move such as queen to b3 or queen to
b5 try to get into a better end game
right easily uh accessible better end
game because you have this point already
on d5 trade the queens queen to b1 was
her choice
which allows the simple pickup of the
pawn on
d5 not only that you pick up the pawn
but this knight is going to jump to c3
if you do take on d5 i am going to take
on f4 and not only that you're upon down
i have the two bishops cutting the board
in half i have absolutely no weaknesses
as black and you're going to lose
another opponent
completely no she's chic two pawns
completely and they don't decide right
yeah it's an easy tactic i think we've
all fallen for this bishop to d5 was
played but now i can just keep the queen
on the fourth right point to b4 or queen
to d4 both of them any reason not to
play queen b4 right it's just so easy to
calculate before it's so much easier yes
sure i mean maybe queen d4 works
but you know you look at knight f3
knight p3 and that means
right now sophie could be going to four
out of four wow what a dream start and
taking one of her key rivals down with
her she's running away with the event i
mean christian you did an excellent job
choosing her for the gladiator today
exactly your presentation
how did he know
how did he know
uh i'm sorry i think i finally got the
opportunity to talk about the game that
i wanted to talk about for just a moment
is between pedro and misha
uh pedro
i haven't seen this gambit before in a
very well known position he said bishop
e3
take my pawn on e4
you should said
that is a pawn
i'll take it knight takes e4
queen c2 that knight just dropped back
knight c3 and bishop b3 bishop b7 queen
f5
rook a8 we're catching up with the
players and i'm sitting there scratching
my head and going okay i understand pawn
sacrifices
um
jump right in here your first impression
when you see this
is
it does white have sufficient
compensation or
it looks like a pog it looks like a
but this is an important pawn it's the
center of the board sometimes we talk
about sacrifices of a pawn and sometimes
you sacrifice the h pawn who cares about
the h-bone you open up
but this is an important e-pawn that's
really controlling a lot of things like
i'm trying to make something like knight
g5 work but
knight g5 hitting f7 but it doesn't do
very much even if i'm setting i i was
looking more directly okay takes takes
bishop here and now if just to show you
what i had in mind right this
and you know i'm trying to justify my
sacrifice by saying your bishop is a
little bit uh i feel it i feel it i but
i i don't know
yeah the issue is that i think that i
don't take on f3 you don't i think i
throw in the move bishop c8 okay but you
drive me to the square i thought i
wanted to go all right i keep driving
you to wherever you want to go i
understand and you want to play
something like
no
no h6 is going to keep
keep kicking you right bishop c8 is a
very good move that just threw me
right off of killed her oh my goodness
um do you actually play the move bishop
c2 after rook 88 rook a e8 bishop c2 now
again i'm thinking that pedro came into
this game right with some prep yeah
right it's like i
look i'm up against this kid uh nishra
who's a grandmaster at 13. everybody
thinks he's the great hero
i
pedro i want to upset him right let's go
now
is this prep what do you think christian
this was prep this
e3 first of all was
a novelty
and it was his novelty because he didn't
spend any minutes on it really quintus
did not spend any minutes on it knight
to c3 did not spend any minutes on it he
had one hour and 32 minutes at this
point after knight to c3 immediately
after the move b5 and this is where his
preparation stopped he already made an
inaccuracy he played the move bishop to
b3 what he was supposed to do and this
is a mistake i mean you cannot just
simply give upon in your preparation and
not go forward with the most obvious
moves in the position because b5 bishop
b7 is one of the most obvious clans that
black has in this position bishop to d3
had to be played i don't understand
h7 e3 yes bishop to d3 attack the pawn
on h7 bishop b7 knight to e4 this is the
way you usually build up your advance
right right right
i'm very confused bishop to b3 the first
thing not a great move but immediately
queen to f5 so you weren't even aware of
what the plans are queen to f5 is not
a great move
once again it's all about the focus
on the attack you kept the bishop on b3
at least try to put some pressure on the
f7 pawn so take on e5 take on e5 and
knight to g5 again
you prepared this at home you dictated
where this game went well follow through
with your dictation and he did not do
that unfortunately for him after queen
to f5 rook 88 bishop to c2
well if it looks like a pawn it talks
like a pawn and it moves like a pawn
then it's probably a pawn because right
now you're completely lost wow bishop to
c8 you have zero compensation
you have zero compensation for the pawn
i'm going to kick your queen
off this battery on the b1 h7 diagonal
and where is the compensation right
where is your compensation i i don't see
it i don't think pedro sees it i don't
think abimanu sees it right now and i
have a feeling that having money is just
going to run away with this one took the
pawn said thank you show me your
preparation you did not show him the
preparation so now i'm going to punish
you
that's such a pity because i wanted to
come here and say
that chess openings deserve a pedro's
attack pedro attack pedro attack okay he
just misplayed it though because that
move bishop d3
what you showed looks so logical
that you're hitting the h pawn and you
want to play knight g5 and it looks like
he just misplayed it but yeah that was a
very spicy pawn sacrifice i must say it
was interesting it it deserves
a better
you know outcome than we're seeing at
this moment have you ever done that
where you
you you come with this excellent
preparation you've been working on this
for months oh absolutely and you get i
mixed the move either you mix the move i
feel it's an even worse feeling when you
get in your prep and then you blow it
you forget it or something no you blow
it
oh yeah that's the worst feeling you're
getting all of it in yeah and then look
at the game viswanathan and non yes or
sarah one it was uh from this bod
uh
that the
you take on you take on d5 and play c4
the bad videos
thank you
and
i
came with this fantastic novelty that
completely rewrote 50 years of theory
i was better with black lose the game
ah terrible terrible terrible okay uh
christian let's turn it over to you what
has caught your eye well definitely this
game guys between a wanderer and karissa
because karissa is going down in this
one and i'm trying to understand what
she's been doing for the last few moves
she hasn't developed
her queen side she hasn't strengthened
at all her king side so she played this
move b5 right now i mean what if i just
simply take and follow it up with knight
to d4 right very natural moves b5 b5 it
completely puzzles me right
what is the point i understand you want
to go b4 destabilize the knight and
lengthen uh the diagonal of the
beachboard g7 nevertheless i don't think
these are your priorities no no no no no
you are a pawn up but i'm coming after
that pawn off with this move bishop to
f4 and now that you're allowing me to
weaken your pawn structure not only that
but weaken the long diagonal as well
give me another target well thank you
very much i'll follow through knight to
d4 how do you continue
your time the position by the way is
completely devastating exactly
if he plays this couple of moves take on
b5 and these are very natural moves by
the way they're not difficult they're
not complex or anything of that nature
you're just making moves with tempo and
strengthening your position in the
process
this is what she's facing right now b5 a
very suspicious move a wonder right now
is thinking counting his blessings after
the opening because
he couldn't have dreamed of a better
opening outcome when he chose this
bishop to e to age for a very aggressive
approach this is exactly what he wanted
to see on the board and right now he has
a great chance of scoring a big three
and by the way if i may be so bold to
ask he played the move bishop f4
attacking the pawn on d6
karissa ignored the pawn on d6 and said
if you want my pawn take it
what if he were to accept that
and say
b5 bishop takes d6 carissa that stops
your b5 b4
bishop takes d6 it's also a move uh
loses some of its advantage after
uh e8 and i was going to take on b5 as
well of course right take on b5 and not
take on b5 but it seems like knight to
f6 again it's still very good for white
very good it's still very good for white
so bishop c6 is also a movement b5 is
all together wrong the problem is
nothing yeah c takes b5 c takes e5
knight d4 it's a plus four advantage
this is not like plus 1.5 plus 2.5
maybe you can come back from that this
is a plus 4 advantage
and once again my pieces are just coming
in with tempo and
it's just very easy to make the moves
with the white pieces right now now my
my question is what do you do after
bishop to c4
this is the only thing that makes sense
to me right because if you do go bishop
f3 then at least your key is not going
anywhere rook to e8 or maybe knight to
d7 i'm getting something right in return
right right so
after bishop c4 it seems like if i
grab the pawn on b5 with either knights
i'm going to have a devastating attack
but also even worse is rook to g1
it's looking bad guys i was about to say
yeah bishop takes c4 check and queen
takes h5
i'm sure that works it's also uh very
attractive to my eyes that that works
too yes uh you have okay
check
exactly exactly nice thank you for that
christian i just checking in the game of
david brosky versus brandon jacobson
because this move knight h5 boy that not
only got david's attention it certainly
got our attention
a move we're not used to seeing this
early
and brandon is accelerating an attack
that we have very often seen by moving
his knight so quickly to f4
he wants to play g5 and g4 without
playing h6 and g5 and doing it slowly
express version yes exactly the
accelerated version and david said okay
well i got a challenge this night
and funny things started happening right
about here knight check king h1 and
queen f
six and i wanted to ask the time
situation uh it's 56 minutes for brotsky
and actually brandon is the one down to
37 minutes that was my question yeah
he's very slow once he's out of theory
wow but is this well i thought
knight h5 he could have
he could have prepped to this moment
right is this
unexpected for me there were just too
many ramifications
from that from the knight h5 position
okay so both players may be on their own
in a double-edged uh position very much
so but let's
let's yes please let's keep on the
juniors because uh we have to update the
andrew hong against christopher game we
haven't looked at it for a while
where is it the third one yep
and a lot has changed this is this this
kg friend french
he did play before he did play b5
against rook no queasy seven somehow
okay
transpose but a queen f2 queen not an f2
exactly and we all we ended up getting
this kind of weird structure
knight e4 takes takes knight d2 goes
knight b8 reroutes the knight that's not
well placed i guess on c6 okay rook c197
okay four it starts to look a bit
dangerous for the black side the queen
of c7
is slightly interplaced right yeah
okay and after b4 c5
b4c5 i like c5 a lot okay uh i assume
bishop takes a c5 just loses to bishop
takes c5 and b a takes b4
makes sense
although maybe that's not completely the
end of the line because there is
some no it might be just be the end of
the line e3 f3 yeah i don't have time
for any tricky
yep okay so he takes on a3 and andrew is
actually thinking after uh b takes a3
because at least in my eyes the more
attractive move let's call it that way
is not to take the polaron a3 but
actually sidestep it with b4 exactly and
then on a good day you put your knight
here and you've got like this
overwhelming strategic uh
advantage thanks to these pawns but the
question is if it works right i mean i
can undermine the
the team the team
and then you might play c6 um i might
play c6 i might play
i tell you what i think i have the time
to play bishop d5 yeah let me let me
yeah
c4 right i think this is my idea okay
and
i'm
i'll take it i will take it i think i
take the training is working too well
dude i don't think you can go a5 you
don't think i can go a5 i get a pawn on
a2 okay you've convinced me i'll put the
pawn on h all right this does look
threatening
well
i could play i still could play knight
a5 anyway right oh my gosh you just you
just posted it up huh yeah uh i like
preventing you from going a5
sometimes it's not even clear that you
won your opponent on a6
i i actually i would love to get rid get
rid of it
sacrifice on a5 um
this is a double-edged i'll just say
i'll leave it at that yeah okay some
counter play right it's there
it's alive it's alive so that's a and
and such a crucial game for our
standings just to remind everyone who
may be joining us late we're looking at
the game of andrew andrew hong who has
two and a half points against
christopher yu who also has two and a
half points and a victory by either
player oh that's he's going to really uh
cement their lead because uh
yeah because abhimanyu mishra and justin
wang are the only two people behind them
with by half a point it does seem that
we like abi manu's position a lot we
probably should at some point look at
this bala balaji dagupati against justin
wangan because we haven't updated it i
think exactly and justin and it's a tie
for third and let's see what we've got
this looks like
a two knights tonight right g5 yeah
uh a very very rare guess these days
whenever we see the two knights it's
like everybody reaches for their d-bond
and plays with d3 although knight g5 i
would say has gained some popularity the
last absolutely a year year and a half i
want to say about 10 years ago the move
bishop d3 they had some surge
yeah in popularity but okay the old move
bishop e2 and my gosh if you go to my 60
memorable games
uh you'll see bobby fischer annotating
these positions
i think i played that move bishop d3
exactly like
10 years ago in a game against our good
friend varujo nacobia no way yes
in one of those uh us chess league what
used to be the u.s chess league right
was that the telephone league or the it
was it played on the it was on icc it
was a nice it was played on icc yes i
think it was against evolution i'm
trying to remember if it was
maybe not but inquiring minds want to
know how do you do
i won that game
with understanding i i think i think
great understanding i think you picked a
good moment christian barry's not in the
truck
to bring that up because martin's not
here
dennis burrows is telling us uh well i
mean he's calling him right now he's
gonna come down and you know what i mean
those are the good days yeah those were
the good days but uh what's the current
state of theory
with this position are they still in
theory alejandro i don't think so i
think we're way past theory we're way
past therapy knight e1 knight e1 that's
wow
i'm not even sure that yeah it would be
on my radar yeah yeah you got to move
something right i'm kind of thinking i'm
warming up to the idea that knight c4
and
bishop takes c4 you're considering black
you've got to travel
right
because
it kind of telegraphs c5 c4 yeah and i
think you are ready for it despite the
fact that there's discoveries with the
knight on d3 yeah i think the knight
reaches anything
i was about to say this this
pond sacrifice by justin which is very
very common in this whole line
uh is
kind of looking a little doubtful i mean
there's not really what i would call
targets in white's position more like he
has a development glitch little
traffic problems with his pieces but if
he gets them sorted
all right let's try to get them sorted
he um justin has played the move bishop
e5 and how do we untangle
bishop e5 yeah
let's uh let's trade i'll take back look
at some trades takes takes uh
bishop d3 let's trade more pieces trade
more pieces no i won't
say that's what you want to do that's
what i want to do yeah now i don't want
to take on d3 no i i thought that was
very helpful in fact yeah
maybe i go bishop g4 okay uh
i'm not a fan of walking into pins i
definitely don't like it but in this
particular case
if i i feel like if i can get in h which
one sorry rook d5 rook david five okay
and yeah but i agree with you there's
calm
but is that it's shaky comp is that
enough for a pawn i don't feel it i
really don't and maybe five let's keep
going which one bishop h5 i just don't
know what we're going towards like this
just i thought i want to go c4 at some
point you can go very slow maybe right
now
i'll take that but now you just take and
i cannot take back because you take
twice yeah i'll be very happy that
that's a problem i don't want to see
that end game
just a second let let le let's let's
realize
let's feel reality and drives the point
two rooks yeah this is probably
close no no no um okay well uh for
justin who was on the outside he's on
the bubble trying to chase
the the leaders
this would be a big
setback in his campaign and what do you
have for us um christian
well actually i was looking at this game
between malnitsky and joel benjamin
because
we haven't looked at joel in quite a
while actually i don't think we looked
at his game today at all and he uh did
say yesterday during his interview that
he's going to bring it
in the rest of his games and this is
exactly what we're seeing right now so
white started with the london and
immediately this move d6 which
supposedly is not such a great move
because specifically this idea with
knight to c3 and taking advantage of the
center as much as possible so
against the london we know that c5 is
one of the main lines d5 as well is one
of the main lights or e6 g6 and d6 allow
this idea with knight to c3 so this is
exactly what we've seen in the game
queen to e2 e5 take on e5 and now we
have this wild position check this out
knight f6
b3
you have to defend the pawn on c2
somehow now
there's not a lot of ways to do that if
you go bishop to c2 unfortunately knight
to b4 comes on the board taking
advantage of the fact that your pawn on
a3 is pinned and now you're in a lot of
trouble because if you do defend with
the move rook to see what knight way to
is coming on the board you don't want to
see that so b3 is almost forced and now
black has
a big opportunity to uh take the bull by
the horns with the move rook takes a d2
if you do take with the queen we kind of
understand that this position black has
tremendous compensation yes tremendous
compensation in the position after queen
takes e4 the dark squares are extremely
weak for why this is not something that
he wants to see so most likely we're
going to see knight takes d2 but now
we take advantage of the geometry in the
position and we play this move queen to
d4 once again focusing on the dark
squares attacking the rook you play the
move b3 weaken the long diagonal so
right now
after rook to a2 this is not the move
that you want to see on the board right
first of all you also have bishop takes
a3 devastating bishop takes a3 rook
takes a3 knight to b4
good luck defending everything around
the king and your king's side the bishop
on f1 rook on h1 are not playing so
unfortunately it does seem like black
gets a tremendous attack in this
position if you do go rook to d1 well
how easy is this position for white
after bishop takes a3 objectively the
computer says that the position is still
within margins of equality after queen
to f3 but from a human's perspective the
way i look at the position with so much
control over a dark square squares given
by the bishop but also the weaknesses
around this a5 e1 diagonal given by the
fact that you lost the pawn on a3
generally not the pawn that you would
consider such uh so important but in
this particular case it's quite
important and i'm seeing a bishop coming
back to b4 setting up the spin the rook
coming to d1 the knight coming to c5
display on the dark squares really
concerns me for white
and we don't have a move yet we're
expecting rook takes d2 but i have to
say joel benjamin right now has the
opportunity of bringing it as
uh he advised yesterday
the other point to mention is
if you don't play the move rook takes d2
i don't like your position because rook
takes d2 is one it's almost four
sacrifices that works brilliantly well
uh for the second player i wanted to
turn our attention to the ladies games
for a little bit because some things
have really blown up we saw alice lee
blunder
her
much wanted uh d5 pawn
jennifer used game somehow kind of blew
up when we left it we left it at these
parts where um
zoe had just played the move d4 take
stakes we kind of really liked zoe's
position we're thinking we're in knight
c6 get the bits out queen a5 check
something that you also might want to
take a look at win the pawn knight c6's
development development development is
key
she played
a port move bishop e6 in my opinion
knight c7 and then she followed up with
bishop h6 and i think jennifer is
suddenly climbing back into the game
after bishop d3 knight a6
it's weird i i don't know but i think
the
variations that i would be
considering most would be knight takes
check
king over
bishop takes queen takes rook takes
something like this
and give me your assessment what do you
think of these uh positions
uh
night before queen takes a2 why is last
minute of this yeah good for black it
looks like dwight's just lost
just lost lost dang okay so that was
assessment number one
no no no the other one was this one
we don't trade rooks
this one i'm more inclined to play i
still don't like i still don't like
white queen a5 check king f1 king f1
take on e6 i assume yeah i think bishop
takes c1 knight f3 doesn't help the
blacks cause that's awesome
so here we keep the rooks
but
gosh rook a1 is it's a move i really
don't want to play it i wrote one is so
awkward right but
i'd rather play this with white than the
other variation at least i hear have
some defenders of c4 and i have a target
on insects that i can play around with
okay okay the other variation i just
didn't feel good about it right okay
with the light squared bishop on e6
hitting c4 i didn't feel like hold i
held on to that position at all here
maybe i can think of giving up the a2
pawn
and just
i was i was maybe even give up the
exchange yeah
looking at h4 and stuff uh okay well
keep an eye on this one but the one i
really wanted to get to finally is
talia's game look what i mean this
position blowed up remember we left it
around these parts
and knight g6 bishop f47
so talia's doing well interesting okay
she's ready to finally play f4 and then
it's a massive majority it i'm going to
get you
so you take the pawn and she played f4
now talia probably didn't want to play
knight c6
she dropped in with d3 takes takes f5
but isn't
white for choice rochelle is just ready
to take this pawn she's got this nice
little majority and by the way
be careful the move f5 f6 might just end
up get getting you mated i like white
it's a lot of space on the king side
which is at the moment the most
important part of the board once you
fractured your structure on the queen
side as black you took on d3 with that c
pawn
i'm not really scared of any majorities
not anymore short time not long term
doesn't really matter just before this
moment just just to re reiterate what
you're saying you got three versus one
and then once your pawn gets to d3 it's
not a scary image not nearly as scary i
like this movie five a lot
i like the light square control that
white has right and the fact that f6 is
always on top i like i like the way that
rochelle has handled this a lot actually
i think that she's outplayed talia the
huge question for you guys yeah what is
uh instinctively your move at this point
i would yes
f6
probably a bad move f7 f6 just to stop
white from playing it yeah f6 seems to
be just completely losing after queen
takes d3 yeah
now
why i asked you that question is because
the engine is recommending knight to f6
wow which made very little sense to me
no i i mean i get it right after you
look at it a little bit you're trying to
stop f6 right this is a radical way of
doing it it's a super radical way right
because rook f4 is coming queen to h5
okay this looks ridiculous
it looks pretty scary right true
so knight to f6 if she doesn't find that
then she probably still has to go knight
to f6 later on so rook to d8 she can
prepare wait for the queen to uh take on
d3 get away shy away from this d1 h5
diagonal and now play the move knight to
f6 but once again inviting this pawn
structure with an open king and
potentially e5 coming to open up and
include my bishop into the attack
not really looking good from a practical
perspective for black right now but once
again this knight on d5 is such a
monster right right
and she's going the other direction
knight to b6 which might actually just
be a losing move
does that invite f6 or is there
no f6
f6 knight takes d5 sorry
and it doesn't seem like he's going
anywhere uh but i can just take on d3
we could have done that against knight
f6 as well right right right yeah
i wanted to turn our attention to the
game between our seniors our legends our
tournament leader larry christensen
versus max deluge
hardly looks like a queen's gambit
accepted anymore as the pawn structure
has changed since the move bishop d5 let
me just catch it oops
and
blessings um
the times of the players in this game
who's been spending their their time
most between larry and max it's about
even 47 minutes left for larry
christensen and 38 left for delugey for
still 18 moves of chess pretty pretty
standard i would say okay he did play
the move knight c6 by the way did larry
and he did capture the bishop
and it's it's the two knights versus two
bishops the other christian was
mentioned exactly and the crazy part was
that
the engines were thinking black was
perfectly okay
uh we've always been taught that uh the
two bishops versus two knights might
favor the two bishops by an entire pawn
and we're going to get an engine
assessment
right now after this move rook d8 how do
the i mean i like white but
it seems like the engines don't care you
remember what i told you yeah zero zero
zero it still is zero zero wow yep we
have uh d5 excellent zero point
minus zero point two even slight
slightly better for black wow incredible
you would never assess it that way right
no i would see d5 bishop comes back to
e2 and then i start
pushing my opponents if possible right
or g3 bishop g2 and then start pushing
my pawns
it's not looking good for black right
from a practical perspective but it does
seem like black has enough maybe after
e5 here after that knight v8 and knight
to d6 setting up the blockade like that
it's a weird position i have to say
because e5 also allows me to go d6 right
that's an option as well i like that six
yeah i like it too by the way the
computer hates it amazing the computer
right now
the position for my bishops and it's not
good after queen b6 it gives a black uh
quite a significant advantage 0.10
amazing
0.6 0.7 something along those lines wow
it's a very weird position i have to say
the more i look at it and uh it does
seem like maxim is spending quite a lot
of time so is larry so they're not aware
of the assessment they don't know for
sure who's better in the position and
whoever is going to make the better
decisions moving forward is most likely
going to get a significant advantage is
such a complex position that everything
can change with one move one bad
decision everything changes absolutely
uh turning our attention uh to nick
defermion versus alexander chabala the
game that we looked at much earlier
as it was one of those double-edged
super sharp open uh sicilian just before
you go to that one
uh joel did not no
he played queen to b5
no this is a weird decision uh rook d2
was really 62 and 24 was exactly it was
screaming in the position right
but now what he backed off from the
chest
is is that an option just i think he
goes nice i guess you go knight c5 and
you can get the pawn back but
i don't even have to take i can go b4
this is the better move in the position
and it does seem like it gives uh quite
a pleasant edge in the end game right
this is not what joel advertised exactly
to do his interview yesterday he was
like i'm going to take the bull by the
horns and try to get massive
complications on the board this is not
what he's going for right now no he
didn't throw the paddies today um let's
jump back uh to the nick defermion
versus alexander chabal off game again
we left it at the move f4 f5 i was
looking for tactical melee guess what it
really went into some
very very quiet strategic channel
suddenly takes on b3 recaptured with the
c bonded nick bishop b7 and nick said
you know what
it's all about the d5 square i'm going
to
fight for the d5 square with the move
here comes bishop g5
b4 you're not getting the d5
square says shabbat yes i am
uh even if you
take
the idea is that this knight one um nick
is playing this positional fight where
he wants to play knight versus bishop
good night versus bishop even at the
cost maybe of his queen side queen takes
a2 queen takes b2 he'll say i'll put my
knight on d5 e4 burn me put my rook
maybe on c6
and
let's go
so this is turning into a
strategic
fight
first impressions alejandro i like white
as my first impression okay but i've
played this so often
as
a white side player where i take on b3
and then i get i get this kind of stuff
and i get the dream
it's not that good really even after you
get all the things that you want you get
you've achieved the max yeah it always
feels like black has one more counter
chance or the bishop isn't as stupid as
it looks on f6 some e5 east side
throws in or the bishop gets to the h61
diagonal and then you realize there's
only one open file right you can't
really fight for it i see i don't think
that
black's better no but i think that they
have more chances than you think at the
naked eye right
one of the games uh it was from a soviet
championship versus a u.s it was a
soviet u.s match it was arnold anchor a
u.s champion versus vasily smithslav now
the americans
really fancied themselves because we
really didn't know anything about the
soviets and the soviets killed us but
there was one game that was played that
made a huge impression on future
generations and that was against myself
versus danker whereas mieslav did get
that white square ideal position one
very very very smoothly and then after
that all of the american players said to
themselves oh you can't play these
positions as
uh black the engines today say yes you
can as you can
but that that one game really just like
oh boy terrified
it terrified us so uh we'll keep an eye
on this one and where would you like to
take us let's go to the david broski
brandon jacobson game all right it's one
of those games that uh
you you just
you you can't take your eyes away yeah
you just look at this position once in a
while you're wondering what on earth
what happened here we left it at queen
fc yeah clear knight f5 looks like a
very decent move it finally attacks this
knight on f4 right the knight retreated
to g6 okay and then broski said you know
what bring it ring it f4 man dang what a
move throwing and he said well look
you've played f4 there's no way
there is no way i'm going to allow you
to open up the f-file i didn't guess he
didn't want to touch the pawn because
yes you went upon but then at the end of
the day you say well my bishop is out of
the game my knight on c6 is out of the
game so the most challenging brandon
took this one and that's what we've got
on the board
how will david brodsky
follow up
this challenging f4 do you think you go
g4 here
[Laughter]
sorry christian defibrillator
i got tasered g4 is the best move that's
over right yeah
the guy goes f4 you gotta go g4 that's
true what are we playing the game of the
century or something
the immortal immortal yeah the evergreen
well i want to play a5 and knight e4 but
you're so much worse right i have no
idea i was just throwing my pawns
forward i was hoping that what bronski
then made sense so so you're trying to
uh trap my queen basically correct yeah
we're close to that yeah he's trying to
do something crazy i like this see this
is a spiciness i mean i like this is
like the what is that gambit where you
go danish gambit
yeah is not looking good for black no no
no this looks terrible so let's try to
make space for my queen with knight e7
my g7 knight after g4 after g4 knight
yes g
e7 correct oh just giving a square not
give that that much thought
well okay well let's go lie e5 e5 i'll
think take that what if i just think man
you're not a man easily uh
you stopped
okay all right let's see i'm channeling
my inner alejandro let's go queen g6 by
the way this is a chat that's a problem
you know which one i really want to make
but there's no way this works what's
that it's like some bishop f7 stuff but
like it doesn't work
i thought you were going to reach into
the crypt and play some
genius i i wanted to do something
similar but it was too many pieces
especially
no no this is over yeah
hold on we gotta we okay just a second
knight g7 we've played e4 f4 g4 d4 we've
got the four pawns attached we have
something here we've got to have
something don't h4 rook a3
any any uh wait sorry you just made that
whole speech and then you came up with
the move rook a3 i didn't give a speech
yes yes e4 f4 g4 and now you're going
okay hey development man that's what
it's all about you know there's no
i mean you know we can do this because
it's david brodsky's position
we can ruin anybody's position we do it
well we do it very well uh all right
let's just let's click on f5 okay
uh you take on f5 after okay three yeah
yeah i
guess i'm taking or maybe i should just
play normal chess bishop e6 like what if
i just continue developing my pieces
bishop e6 sure
well at some point don't i have to take
on d4 you do but
that's kind of what i want to coax you
i'm opening up the av
your your pieces are getting what i
wanted oh it's not right i mean even if
we do it like this and leave the night
can i take it i'm not feeling it for uh
david i know 97 i think it's a very good
move
um but
is there another approach beside g4
because g4 really it wasn't on my radar
g4 is the best move um really also 97 is
not the only one nor the best one by any
means actually knight g7 gives white a
slight advantage um
actually no now now that the engine is
thinking a little bit knight g7 is fine
bishop to d7 is also a move
really wow
what now i'm trying to understand what's
the point of this ah just give up a
knight like this and then why didn't you
change that yeah bishop c6 check
fancy engines roy bishop scene
check yeah yeah is a nice move very nice
oh my god nice idea a nice concept uh
what if you just take on d4 right
but it doesn't feel like it's connecting
very well your last few moves right he's
taking on d4 with the knight yeah take
on d4 with them did he yeah yes he did
take on d4 with the knight okay but what
if i just pick up the phone now right
how do you skinny or attack
i i don't see no i'm thinking queen b3
knight f3 but and then i don't want my
pawn on g three either way three let's
go castle exactly bishop h3
such an annoying threat you're you're no
yeah where is the atlanta exactly
black's for choice for sure right what's
the compensation and it actually feels
like white's king is a bit what's
actually
exactly foreign
i like black no yeah i i
me too
puzzling decision to go uh for this pawn
sacrifice and right now i mean brandon
is just asking the point of questions
give me the point and show me the
compensation exactly
somebody who's asking
pedro is being asked to show
the conversation as mishra is
pawn to the good uh pedro made a very
enterprising you called it spicy
spicy fond sacrifice that's
not worked out well for pedro he didn't
follow it he didn't follow it up well as
the problem and uh mishra looking good
there carissa's game we haven't checked
in on her for a while we didn't like her
move b5 not one little bit
and a wonder said you know i just played
the move bishop f4 attacking the pawn on
d6 you didn't defend it
i'll take it
and he did
and after rook d a castles
boy it sure looks like white is having
all the fun energy for it feels very
speculative
pardon me
yes
and uh carissa's king
all
the puns
are disappearing from her king this is
over the bishop
and bishop f6 i'll give you the
assessment it's plus six
yeah i mean this is not a surprise not a
surprise for us sometimes it's a
surprise this one
not not so a wonder bouncing back uh
don't call it too early he had plus 10
yesterday a good point it was plus 10
yesterday a good point and with one
single move going from plus 10 to minus
and we actually called it yesterday we
said that wonder is going to take this
yeah we really jinxed him yes he did and
we showed this variation with queen g3
oh my goodness oh yes yeah this is over
uh i wanted to turn our attention to our
tournament co-leaders you might just
resign yeah
it's bad it's bad andrew uh versus
christopher you remember we had this
moment where b4 takes a3 yes and we were
speculating about the move b2b4
and you know trying to keep these pawns
as a team
uh on b4 and c5 and we were following up
with knight c4 anders i don't like that
pawn getting to a2 he recaptured bishop
t5 and move i wanted to play queen 2
queen c6 rook c3
and
you know the more i i like it this is
what french defense players live for the
counter-attack
you know that initial wave where you
know white is gushing forward he gets e5
and you know he gets all of his things
going um
it seems to me like christopher
stabilized his position as black he's
okay you've got the passer but i've got
a blockade i got a counter attack and i
i
think
christopher is going to be happy with
the outcome of the opening we have queen
g3 on the board we're caught up to the
players your take on this position
alejandro do you play
have you played the french defense yeah
you did yes i mean i played the french
defense pretty pretty often and
you still play it you like it today
oh the engine's giving you trouble no i
mean i played once in a while okay i'm a
french defense player i i have a pretty
varied repertoire but i played french
defense at the us championships for
example i remember drew kamsky 2012 with
the french 2014 in the french also so i
i mean i i played it i got destroyed by
vichy once in an olympiad it happens it
happens
uh and what's your take on this position
no this looks lovely uh this for black
that is this pawn on c5 just seems to be
in the way for white's pieces right the
fact that black is controlling the b
file is actually pretty nice yeah i'm
even wondering if you can play
immediately the move work b2
not just just keeping the tension on the
tension because
if you ever do take on f6 right i'm not
unhappy about recapturing with one of
the pieces yeah the structure is off you
do have these double pawns on e6 and on
um e4 but you get a lot of activity
right around these pawns and the cement
of the bishop on d5 is just such a nice
strategical concept
it's so it so often happens that you
take that e4 pawn put it on d5 put the
black
bishop on d5 on some awful square like
c8 and it never left never lands there
no the bishop is actually the lord of
the lord i mean it is finally get its
revenge after so many losses for the
french defense with the bad septic
bishop the bishop looking good and i i
feel like this queen specifically on g3
not making a very
tangible impression you're going nowhere
it doesn't actually make any sense to me
where was this queen before i went to
cheese it was on f2 it was on e1 he kind
of crawled it
along the first rank remember yeah no i
i
don't have to go that back okay sure
sorry i didn't it's like i love it
uh no i don't i mean i understand that
got to g3 i don't understand what the
queen's doing on g3 is just i don't
think there were a lot of good options
but somehow it feels that white has got
an outplay in this position i don't like
white's position okay it feels that way
to me too another move another
approach i want to say that christopher
could possibly consider
might be a little bit risky but you know
the idea of you know
gifts me the bond if i can take it and
put a bishop on f6 even at the cost of
an exchange i'm really liking it black
central play by the way rook b2 a move
that you liked has appeared on the board
christopher looking pretty good
against an incredibly well-prepared
andrew right uh guys i think i should
move to carissa's game just do this i
have a feeling we're going to see a
resignation
not surprising the bishop is on f6
there's a checkmate threat knight g6 is
going to be met with rook to g1
everything comes by force and you're
actually just simply losing a piece no
this was knight g6 we're going to see
rook to g1 instantaneously played i
think at the end of the day
you you can get away with a lot of
things in lesser tournaments but
these juniors are unforgiving they're
very unforgiving these are very strong
grand masters i mean exactly we use the
word juniors very often but if you just
want to look at this tournament from the
point of view how strong is this event
this is a tournament with eight players
that are basically grand master level
uh players and and uh pardon me and uh a
wonder excuse me it's not 2700 yeah he's
not your average grandmaster either
either right so you play some kind of
dubious kings indian i mean the guy will
make you look bad exactly because he
knows the ins and outs he's very
talented he's an incredible attacker
king of faith and he's using i think i
mean he plays allah temple look at him
he doesn't need to think this
right
the problem carissa knows what's going
on after bishop says g6 yeah h8 king f7
rook c8 you cannot take the pawn of the
bishop on f6 because of 95 knight c7 it
doesn't matter right yeah it's just like
i mean
everybody everybody who's ever played
chess has at one time another gotten
into these kinds of pins that you can
never escape from and whether you lose
the rook by f4 bishop here or as you
were saying christian knight takes b5
knight c7
you're gonna lose on the board bishop
takes three
immediately played bishop takes g6
excuse me rook takes g6 rook takes c3
immediately bishop takes rook h8
and you're in this awful awful pin
bishop takes b6 bishop takes b5 is going
to come on the board i assume or f4
oh f4 is is is a move that
begs for a resignation exactly any media
the resume
yeah
yeah just
bishop e5 might allow knight cc he's
going for it but f4
uh
prepping bishop e5 and if you go bishop
e8 i i take on e8
if you go bishop e8 i think you'll take
c8 bishop f3 and he doesn't have knight
stop the horse is dead stop beating it
oh the floggings will continue
yeah absolutely wonder is going to be
pleased but i tell you nothing's he's
still angry about yes
he's still angry about it yesterday yeah
he's still flying out the door because
he has i mean
this will kind of
bind the wound a little bit but it's
still a wound one and a half andrew
pardon me a wonder liang why did i say
andrew i wonder liang uh gets his first
victory our top seed an important
victory for him one and a half points
for a wonder still a little bit of a
disappointing event but at least he
bounces back and for carissa i mean
after the two draws in the first two
rounds she's
now tumbled to two losses yeah that's
not i mean she wanted the challenge
right of playing in this open section
and i'm glad that she she went for it
but uh i don't want to see her you know
just making draws and
you know you want to say you're winning
yeah i want to see her throwing some
patties and especially with the white
pieces yesterday was very uh
disconcerting that she got a
disadvantage i would say out of the
opening she has played some of the
tougher uh okay players in this
tournament i would say between brandon
jacobs on one of the higher seats i
wonder one of the higher seats abimanu
one of the higher seeds
she's had a tough tournament so far
we'll see what she asked for the rest by
the way check it out uh justin did win
back this pawn uh he uh
balaji did not play the bishop d3 move
that weak thought in the game
yeah
and not after knight e1 f3 bishop takes
c2 rook takes c2
and justin's feeling a lot better about
his position as
he's a he's a half point behind the
tournament co-leaders coming in today's
round
and it feels like
well he's still worse funnily enough but
it's a step in the right direction and
christian what do you have for us
well actually guys i was looking at the
game between brotsky and brandon
jacobson and i was trying to understand
where's the compensation
i'm starting to see something right
because i'm not convinced about this
move queen to f6 in fact the queen on d4
sure it can get stuck but it was keeping
the knight in check almost especially
after castle which i think was the best
move in the position bishop to d7 is
also a move that is recommended by the
engine maybe the more correct approach
to immediately play this move or at
least attempt at playing this move
bishop to c6 putting a lot of pressure
on the long diagonal he did not do that
he played the move queen to f6 but this
allows my knight to get back into play
right with the move knight to f3 and it
does seem like if i managed to get
bishop d2 bishop c3 well i can't see the
compensation and this is exactly what
we're seeing right now my guess is that
what brandon is looking to do is to
actually target the queen as soon as
possible with this plan knight to e7
the knight is dominated by the pawn
structure that white has set up right
now with the pawn uh the spear on f4
controlling the knight very nicely
nevertheless it also gives black some
initiative on the king side potential
initiative on the king side you
overextended a bit knight to e7 i like
this move with the idea to go queen to
g6 if i manage to exchange the queens
then i am upon up i'm going to be very
happy with the outcome of the middle
game so this is what we're seeing right
now it does seem like white doesn't have
anything better than to accept
the queen trade but
once again we're looking at the
practicality of everything and accepting
the queen trade with the pawn down is
generally not an easy thing to do from a
psychological point of view if brandon
fights the move knight to e7 i think he
will be in poor position to uh take the
full point home
thank you for that christian i see an
enterprising exchange sacrifice by jenna
jennifer you
i like her decision we were looking at
the these sharp positions where there
was this queen a5 check that was really
throwing
uh jennifer off that when the queen
comes to a5 check we're going to end up
with our king on f1
uh so wait she took on a6 and on e6 we
were only considering taking on e6 right
exactly i was at least and why we got
here
but why
why didn't i go queen a5 instead of why
didn't i pick up the knight with the
queen
bishop takes c1 okay queen takes c1
queen a5 oops sorry right here queen a5
check i'm missing something
isn't this like
much stronger version because if you go
beef i think you have to go b4 right
that's the only thing that makes sense
but then you go queen 26 and then rook
c8 right
uh what what what are we missing uh
why did she go queen why didn't zoe play
queen a5 check i mean
queen a5 was a great move yes
was a great move and she should have
played that move whoa
so once again jennifer is like dodging
bullets yeah sometimes it's automatic
moves right recap captures b takes a6
not considering the fact that somehow
she didn't play it instantaneously she
actually thought for seven minutes
so she was considering she was
considering queen to a5 she was probably
considering bishop takes c1 as well
queen a5 check
so was she
put off by
why she kings on you too right of course
i mean i'm trying to
i'm trying to imagine that she saw
ghosts
uh in the play i can't imagine any other
movie sidereel v1
so lost though right it's terrible
it's terrible so you see what happened
is i just was flashing around positions
i was just checking yeah yeah and i
thought to myself oh well look at this
jennifer has an exchange down down but
she's got this dark square bishop she'll
get bishop e5 ish there's a nice ugly
structure on the queen she's got a
passport right right i didn't know how
she got here right but this doesn't look
bad i mean yeah maybe maybe you prefer
black because exchange is an exchange
but precisely it's a game right right
and on a good day if i ever get to play
moves like bishop e5 maybe
you have ideas right and that i didn't
realize she was busted before she got
quite if i was bust the bust right
that looks terrible queen a5
boy but she's got i love this look of
absolute composure
when you're completely busted yeah yeah
you could do that larson had perfected
that you know he just had this perfect
look of like everything's under control
and we have a guest with christian over
to you christian we do indeed we are
here with wander liang after a
devastating victory against karisa i
wonder first of all you came into the
studio and i could see it on your face
you're still harboring some
disappointment from previous rounds tell
us about that
yeah after the first two games i thought
it was normal just
a bad tournament which happens from time
to time
after yesterday i i was sure that um
someone maybe abi abimanyu um sacrificed
a few years of their life to to take a
few games from me because uh i was just
like okay there's no way this is
happening um
but but yeah i mean i think it's it's
fine i mean it happens every once in a
while i think i've i probably haven't
started this poorly in
um almost like a decade so
it's like a once-in-a-lifetime event and
um
yeah okay i got i'll get it out of my
system after this event and hopefully
it'll be better from there well still
plenty of rounds to go but how do you
deal with uh that disappointment how do
you just put it to the side
um yeah i'm not sure if it's up to
standard with the dress code but
i decided it was dire measures so i
decided to bring my lucky hoodie with me
i don't think i've lost the game with
this hoodie in like four years so dire
so i mean it ended up working pretty
well i think um yeah the game was pretty
short absolutely let's talk about
today's game you came up with this idea
of uh bishop to e2 against the king's
indian did you expect karisa to start
with the kings india
yeah i think it's her main opening um
pretty standard choice for her
um probably in
like the current state with modern
engines it's a little dubious
um
yeah i saw she played c6 before
and so yeah i was gonna just play knight
f3 in some normal
position but um i analyzed this h4 line
like for some bullet games and at the
board it's just yeah probably it was a
bad decision but i couldn't help myself
i just
go for this h45 i mean i think the
engine says it's decent but nothing
spectacular probably black can hold
um yeah i wasn't sure about knight h7
pro probably i was just misremembering
something i thought maybe 98 is the move
um
but yeah either way i think it's
it's pretty much fine for black i mean
some slight advantage for white nothing
serious
um yeah and the game probably i i mixed
something up because i couldn't recall
what to do after hg
and
probably i should just take on f7 and
take on g4 and that way at least i'm not
done no actually bishop takes g4 was the
right move okay okay so yeah i i i
wasn't really sure what's going on okay
i see f5 is also a mistake um
did you feel like she was out of her
theoretical knowledge or did you know
she still knows something here i thought
it's very unlikely that she knows
anything too serious um actually here i
was a little bit concerned because i i
missed that after knight h3 bishop s7 h5
um black has this move e5
and somehow i kind of
i don't know yeah my head was sort of in
a weird space but probably it's still
okay for white but
yeah i was
it's a little unpleasant to miss things
like this
and yeah i think the game the way the
game went i
i really wasn't sure but
it probably looks like there's
nice compensation all around like
i think probably b5 was just not a good
move but
um
but okay yeah i see i see the bar
it's already too bad
keeps going up
so so i'm not too sure what she could
have done better in that case yeah
probably not these six i think at that
point she was supposed to uh develop her
pieces as fast as possible in 97 if i
remember yeah yeah probably i mean it's
hard to say it's still very difficult
right yeah i mean as long as i'm not
like completely lost in the center like
stuff's not collapsing i think basically
it's enough compensation long-term
initiative on the g4 and right yeah
always knight d4 is coming and it's hard
to protect all the pawns
so
absolutely and after the move b5 you
felt like you're in full control yeah
yeah b5 was very strange i i don't know
okay
bar didn't like queen takes d6 but i
thought this end game is just completely
lost for black
there's
yeah there's just no development and
everything's hanging
and you delivered almost a checkmate she
didn't allow you to get the checkmate
but you got the full piece after that
i wonder you're playing brandon jacobson
uh top competitor tomorrow uh with the
black pieces how are you going to
strategize that game are you going to go
all in um
yeah okay i actually didn't know i was
playing him so thanks about information
um
yeah i'm not sure it's just another game
i think
yeah we'll just see what happens
nothing too spectacular probably as soon
as the event is over um this is probably
going to be a good day but
um yeah yeah we'll see i mean it's just
it's just another game so still plenty
to go and uh still a championship to
play for guys any questions yes i wonder
uh you're playing in this tournament and
i always thought think of it as a kind
of a qualifying event to the open
championship but my understanding is
you're already qualified for this coming
u.s championship am i right in thinking
that
um i don't think so maybe they updated
the rating list and i'm not too sure i
didn't get the invite yet so okay that's
on your guys's end actually you like it
if i qualify yeah uh but
but either way yeah it's always it's
just good to play some chess um i kind
of skipped some of the other big opens
like the world open in favor of like
this one game a day format and it's good
to be back in st louis um obviously i
wish the event could have been
going a little bit more in the right
direction but
yeah either way um
i mean it's just a good opportunity to
play some chess irregardless of the us
championship qualification spot
all right thank you wonder good luck in
the remaining games uh right your ship
yeah absolutely good to see him bounce
back with the victory
who qualified that's what i'm thinking
from the junior last year yeah yes yeah
he won the wee junior last year and the
one before that it was um
the saint louis university student oh
gosh john burke
you mean from webster universe webster
universe yeah john burke qualified for
the last one right yes because yeah the
u.s championship is playing catch-up
with the pandemic and i
uh let's take a look at the talia
cervantes game because we have a huge
development assault i think coming this
game i unless i'm missing something but
maid is uh
very seriously dreading threatened isn't
it
yeah big trouble here huge trouble i
think
no i look dead right when you see when
you see this pawn and queen this pattern
i think was drilled into it yeah like a
hundred times
yeah i think that wow but uh for
rochelle
help me out here she won yesterday she
wants her this will be her second
victory in her room
yeah yeah actually catches up with talia
if she manages to defeat her by the way
the queen coming to f5 actually comes
with a tempo against the g5 i was so
mesmerized by the queen g5 i was
thinking how am i going to deal with
captures
where's the mate do i go bishop h4 you
don't have to think that much nope queen
takes c5 we're getting ready for a break
i want to just remind everybody that we
love your questions so uh do reach out
to us via social media and i don't know
we got something prepared for the
audience or is it just a break
i think we're just taking a break on
just a normal break a normal break
yesterday we'll be back in a few minutes
uh for more of round four here at our
championships in st louis
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
we all know st louis is a championship
sports town from the 11 time world
champion cardinals to the stanley cup
champion blues
but i bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the world chess hall
of fame westport social and topgolf and
now even our own mls team so whatever
sports your team is into you can always
bring out your a game in st louis
oops sorry
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody we're here round
four of the junior junior girls and
seniors we only have one result so far
of our 15 games of the day i wonder
liang easy victory against karissa gibb
just destroyed her opponent a little bit
of prep really did a little bit of prep
a little bit of understanding and that's
all it took for this over 2600 player to
take down crazy yes let's be fair 2700
player in fact
20 2700 invitational ratings right 600
feet it okay but i see these
invitational ratings all the time either
you have a picture of the playing hall
and uh larry christensen um
versus max delugey
as they come into this round as
tournament co-leaders along with igor
novikov and this was like the two
bishops versus two nights game and larry
somehow
i think has really baboozled a little
bit his opponent because it feels to me
like after this move rook on a1 to e1
things are going in larry's direction
yes i understand you have a protected
pass pawn yes
i have a protected postupon but the fact
that i'm coordinated
on the open e-file and the fact that my
bishop on e5 controls the pawn i feel
like it's gone in larry's direction your
your take on the position i feel you
said it very well the fact that this
bishop can control both sides that means
that it can control the b pawn as well
as make threats on the kingside is worth
more than this knight yeah rook g6 just
played and i assume
right just keeping an eye on everything
you're right
and when this bishop does drop back this
open e file
uh max will
well you'll have to excuse me that was a
my mouse slip queen f4 on the board
uh he will have an awkward defense let's
just leave that there let the players do
joe benjamin game remember that
sacrifice non-sacrifice how did he not
make that sacrifice is that a pawn right
well we left it this was the moment that
we were kind of pounding the table right
here
for the exchange sacrifice rook takes d2
we did some analysis rather christian
did some very nice analysis on rook
takes d2
feeling that the position was difficult
for white
joel
didn't go for the exchange sacrifice
instead
sacrificed upon himself
i think we're up to date with the play
right
now
uh
joe's struggling it looks like a pawn
pawn looks like a very good partner
really joel's struggling i would say at
this point to hold the game
and the time situation is not very
beneficial igor with 29 minutes and joel
is down to nine for the remaining 17
moves hmm not good uh quick check whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa not a quick check
what happened to the gay [ __ ] permian
versus
shabba-dabba-doo it blowed up on us uh
why what yeah
uh
i don't know how this happened we left
it weird
dynamics of the position right so much
for that no
one blew up bishop g5
nick said look if i can get in f6 i'm
doing it
shabbat said
okay
i want the rook
nick said
i want your bishop so far so good that's
a check
ooh did we have to put our king here i
think he wanted to get the tempo right
because as the game continues queen e3
you have rook c7 here of course you
wouldn't have rook c7 if the king wasn't
on each one there would be a back rank
issue
so that prompted rook b a and knight g f
and believe it or not we're caught up
with the players
and
uh
i think
nick is having the fun yeah but let's
actually analyze because this is right
so let's let's start with queenie four
just okay just to see what am i lost
right right
you started looking at knight g6 i said
well we do
and i think that's
that's a cruncher isn't it i don't see
the finish yet uh f takes yes let's just
so let's show one
yeah i mean this is the puzzle rush
check
knight e7 me that's clear so you have to
take the other way yes
and that's good
takes h7 is not made anymore no it's a
perpetual but i can't find more than a
perpetual
knight h6 is a perpetual a 97 you can
play but i don't
i think i can run yeah you think you're
just running yeah yeah king
i have seven and you can give another
check on h7 no that's not the way we
want it okay so once again knight queen
takes e4 let's pause it here
not that many options right because i i
am taking on g2
and
by the way knight
yes
knight
was played uh
while i was thinking about knight takes
oh rather before i was thinking about
knight takes g6 i was just wondering
in terms of the positional sacrifice
right
where
you know i get a position where my
knights somehow in the world of magic
dominate the rooks
remember there was this one game that
bobby fischer had played he was black at
night on c3 and somehow white's rooks
couldn't move because there was this
knight e2 check all the time and the
rooks were dominated a knight on d6 it's
something nice knight on e7 hold on i
got it just a second
let's see this again so knight takes g6
can we just have yeah knight g6
f1 takes
spinning my wheels here so we see the
perpet
but
we don't see more than the perpet
because there's this line king h7
knight f7 yeah but again the king runs
to e6 and i'm not actually mating you
you're just up a lot of material
knight g5 doesn't work even close to
anything no no no no no it's just a
perpetual perpetual
well maybe we're blundering something um
jump right in on this one uh christian
it looks like a fascinating fun tactical
position but we're just seeing a perpet
i thought you never asked guys
yes it is just zeros it is a perpetual
after the move queen takes c4 but i have
to say that's not the most testing in my
opinion i think queen to d2 or queen to
d3 and queen to d3 actually came on the
board now it does seem like you have to
go to g1 right okay if you go to e1 then
no no queen takes c4 that's a problem
right and if i go to even though you are
mentioning that endgame is not as clear
if you go to f2 then queen to d2 once
again it's a problem and that actually
king to f2 is on the board guys oh my
goodness this is a big problem why why
why keep it going queen to d2
king let's say f1 king to f1
and check this move out right now
rook bc8 say what the game is over
in one move
yeah you made it sound very convincing
but i'm still analyzing it
how do you continue tonight
if i just try to give you a perpetual
what is the as before yes
f6 and then i'm giving you
this is clear this is clear this is over
right
queen takes h6
so he finagle queen d3 check and queen
d2 covering
but he was supposed to go king to g1
right
so g1 would have kept the balance in the
position the zeros
not king to f2 king to f2 allowing the
queen to get with tempo on d2
and this is over not only with that
that's the problem not only rook to c8
which is also bishop takes e4 is a move
and then just simply take on f5 so queen
takes e4 takes on f5 yes gotcha that's
clear
yeah this is actually this is more or
less clear right because yeah rooks i
could potentially have even root g8
ideas exactly in that position so agreed
you don't want to see that
a5 seems to also be winning by the
engines eval but rook to c8 is so
convincing yeah that's a very pretty
move actually if it's possible it's a
beautiful move because you cannot take
it and then take again because you're on
a pair right it's over you're going to
lose this one and you don't have any
attacks
um
no this one is looking great for black
if he finds rook bc8 and this is the
type of move that
shabbalov should be able to find because
shabba is such an explosive and tactical
player he should be able to find rook b
to c8 after queen to d2 now the key
in this position is that with this
inclusion of queen to d2 you control in
that force line the h6 square right it's
such an important square and you have
that move queen takes h6 not an easy
find over the board right we've been
critical of shabala poor defensive play
has cost him
uh some half points in this event but
we've all we've never doubted his
attacking ability and he's looking this
over he
i mean he senses that this is the
critical moment you can just see him
bearing down uh into the position there
is queen d2 check followed by rook c8
what a spectacular move that would be uh
will he find it i just turned and just
to kind of uh close this game out to
show you why king to g1 was so much
better because it's still not as clear
what are you going to do after queen to
d2 how are you going to continue the
attack well i would just just queen to
h4 now i am threatening to take on g6
and you cannot take with the f pawn
because queen takes h7 is checkmate so
let's say i go h5 right right now how do
you get to h6 and this uh is the
critical moment now you play this move
h3 wow h3 so you can go
only move
so that you make space and then your
threat is in fact knight takes d6
because you cannot take with a queen
queen to g5 would come and i'm invading
and i'm giving you the checkmate
so
very intriguing position
right now
these are all computer moves these are
very difficult to find with only 12
minutes
on the clock they're difficult to find
with an hour on the clock right now
let's wait and see
if he manages to find this idea queen to
d2 followed by rook to ca this would be
a huge victory for shabala the first one
in this tournament after a quite
difficult start and a painful start i
have to say especially that game against
it seems like he had it in the back for
a draw uh let me speaking of the game of
the copian for just a moment charlotte's
good gregory kaidanov
uh kind of we this was this benko uh
sicilian i'm not calling it i'm calling
it the banco sicilian look it up
rook the c1 by uh gregory and lots of
moves but you know again
very sharp sicilian turned into a very
strategic
sicilian at at the end of the day it
does feel like with these structures
usually you know favorite black
it's precisely i wanted to say that i
thought i think
that vladimir has actually played a very
nice
game and
i am actually uh
liking uh vladimir's position
uh as we're heading towards time control
yeah 14 minutes for uh grisha 22 minutes
for vladimir uh
i like the open c file i like the fact
that black will always have a target
whether it's d3 or e4 once you make the
d4 break yourself exactly and it all
really stems to whether white has any
counter play with the move knight f5 and
something like rook g3 coming quickly
exactly but
that's what it's based on you also don't
feel this is enough not when the knight
is on e6 it's a great great defender yes
we'll keep an eye on uh that one and
where would you like to lead us
christian oh sorry uh alejandro why did
i say christian you're sitting right
next to me ellie andrew one day yeah
well let's go to the grievage game
against uh igor navikov he was also one
of our leaders okay so we need to pay
attention to that one because i feel
that today we're going to have a lot of
leaders
tumble
really i feel that
uh okay we left it around let's say
these parts a long time ago
yep and uh well dimas got the two
bishops and he's got some some action
some action and i think specifically
after what happened in the game bishop
f3 somehow rook b8
queen d4
and i this is the current position
correct i just don't know how you defend
this queen side
a7 is a blaze uh
is that
that's not much of an explanation
no i'm sorry wait sorry what happens
after after rook v8 he could take on it
on a7 yeah i actually just noticed that
i think he could take on a7 uh i i
suppose it was bishop
pardon me rook a8 queen d4 the same as
in the game knight d7 and maybe this
bishop is actually
weirdly
unable to defend the pawn
really even c5 is a funny variation in
the effective that final position if i
could make it work i don't know if it
works or not but
it's kind of a funny move bishop takes
a7 yeah knight 2497 i was thinking maybe
c5 works
can i take the bishop you can i go c6
how about you think about the point
never mind what am i doing
i the queen is defending the rook
yeah that explains
that
right but we do have queen d4 on the
board and we have 97 as a response all
right let's start with the logical if i
take on a7
i'm assuming i'm taking on e5 it's the
only move right
wait wait wait wait i'm i suddenly yeah
bishop b6
you're starting to wonder if you lose
immediately i think you don't i don't
that's good news i think of knight f3
that is a check so i will have to
recapture and i think the queen somehow
magically stays tethered to the rook
queen f4 queen e5 both seem to kind of
work but isn't this like it looks like
you're on the verge of defeat i have to
say horrifying pin
even bishop e3 here yeah yeah i think
just the
this looks terrible yeah this was like
the carissa yeah
yeah yeah
he's winning for
no no no no no we can't do that so queen
takes no but you have no choice if
nothing improves your position queen
takes e5
queen takes e5
not to go into that uh position where
the rook at the end of the day
uh ties me uh completely up and on g3
you're actually going g5 no i'm going to
go back uh so i want to meet any bishop
f4
plans i mean you still might want to
play bishop f4 and give
win control over the d5 square i like
the two bishops
um
man c5 though i just you sorry no no it
can continue at g3 or c5 in this
position c5 and you just like white i
just don't feel like you're going to
make any moves
true right i'm suffering i'm not here
i'm not a happy camper i'll definitely
give you that
my pieces really do seem to be in a kind
of a traffic jam
and what happened in the alice league
game because that's a big one for the
standings we should definitely update
there in the junior girls because sophie
moyes suzuki is looking to punch her
ticket two four out of four let's take a
look at the end game that they
eventually did
they should zip on up that's pretty good
that's very good uh sophie is trying to
make it forward a row yes right how easy
is this end game though she doesn't have
a lot of space well exactly and i want
to do something about that whether it's
based on the move g5 or f7 f6 i want to
just
open up this bishop and
if i can get my bishop to d4 check
then you know i'm humming with gas i
would say
humming with cats yes
i love it uh
let's say
i could ignore you for now right because
h6 is hanging at the end i could play
like 94 maybe king f2 but in both cases
at the end of the day now i feel like my
bishop at long last is actually doing
something i mean
you're going to be tethered to this pond
whether it's with a bishop or
some of your pieces i'm liking what i'm
seeing
i like black's chances of converting
this a lot right it's it it's it's
definitely looking very good
um
and let's uh ask christian uh christian
why do you what caught your eye well let
me give you an update on a few games
please critical games uh let's start
with this one david brosky versus
brandon jacobs enough yeah knight to f3
we said knight to e7 will pose some
problems for white and that's exactly
what brandon understood as well you want
to focus on exchanging the queens if you
can manage to do that you are up a pawn
you will have a better end game and this
is exactly what he played f5 was the
response proposed by david brodsky g6
take take
and this was the critical moment because
he played the move queen to h4 which in
fact leads to a losing position after uh
queen takes h4 knight takes h4 bishop to
h3 everything comes with tempo you're
actually dropping your pieces backwards
while i'm developing my pieces and
improving my position as black not a
good sign for white you're also upon
down after castle which is a very
natural movie in the position has not
been played yet it just feels like uh
brandon is most likely going to go on uh
and get the full victory in this one now
the question is
could have uh white done anything else
at this point
what do we have do we have we have g5 g5
most likely also are giving brandon
quite a nice advantage but a time
situation is not clear for the players
right i can see that it's about seven
minutes each seven
seven minutes for uh brandon yes and 16
minutes
for david brodsky nevertheless how
difficult is this position for black
well i mean i
see a lot of nice moves that i would
like to play quickly yes
right right i mean look i i think
brandon is in full control right now i
agree
right on up castle is on tap it's going
to be very difficult to stop me from
doing that you can play the move bishop
to f7 but that just
takes me to a better score i'm going to
go king to d7 it's not looking pleasant
for white at this point but he did have
an opportunity and this is what i wanted
to show please at this point instead of
queen to h4 which was played
instantaneously he had the option of
playing the movie e5 and i think this
would have given him uh great chances
fighting chances exactly because of
course if you take then i can take back
with the queen but this is obviously
much better looking yeah an improved end
game right
who knows maybe white is actually better
here
better at this point exactly knight f7
bishop f7 is coming
the central files are open right now so
i will be able to use my rooks uh to
deliver checks very unpleasant tracks
against the king so after e5 what you
have to do is drop back with a queen to
g7 and then i can go queen to h4
sacrifice another pawn you can take that
if you want but at least my queen is
ready to go to the central e4 square as
well as maintain it on the board this
would have given in my opinion at least
practical chances to white what we have
right now it does feel like brandon is
going to uh go on uh to a victory now
sgg
disaster strategic absolutely disaster
uh i'll be money what is up money doing
right now so
i was looking with the engine and
apparently he did not find the right
move
at this point he played the move queen
to e7 after knight to d2 c5 would have
given him a devastating advantage plus
three right now wow plus three i
wouldn't have guessed plus three
plus three if you take bishop to h2 this
is the idea king to h1 rook to e5 a very
very beautiful uh concept queens gets
very beautiful concept that's exactly
whatever it is it's such a nice concept
right c5 bishop h2 rook to e5 wow not
easy not easy not easy and by the way c5
would have been the only move that would
have given him the plus three advantage
he did not find that queen to e7 and
allowed him uh allowed his opponent that
is espinoza to get back into the game
not the way he played it bishop to f4
putting immediate pressure on e4 would
have been the right way
the advantage is starting to dissipate
for a black and actually it is uh white
who's getting very very close to
establishing once again the balance in
the position now queen h4 h6 and f3
this was a shocker in my opinion i did
not understand this move allowing the
move knight to d5
and in fact after knight to d5 pedro
stopped and think for 35 minutes
went down and by the way at this point
after the move f3 i mean money only had
10 minutes left on his clock
for 17 moves so
he was struggling
to find a way to maintain his advantage
and pedro just allowed him to do that
with this move f3 very strange decision
i have to say by white knight to d5
spent 35 minutes back to 15 minutes for
pedro against 10 minutes rook to e7 but
this is just an easy endgame right now
and this is not the game that we're
talking about
this is brandon versus david brodsky
we're talking about abi manu there we go
who to be honest right now has a winning
position
and he can take on e3 which is what we
expect this is just a winning position
now
it is a pawn
that's pretty it is opponent i have a
feeling you have the initiative and the
initiative right yeah and i think you
can take what do you take with the rule
right i think with the rook taking with
the knight and pinning myself seems a
bit
uh counterintuitive i i think taking
with the rook makes the most sense by
the way i wanted to turn our attention
also to the game of jennifer you and zoe
tang
because jennifer had sacrificed the
exchange we thought she had a bad
position before she sacrificed she had
her she got her opportunity and she's
fighting back
and i'm seeing a three result game and
maybe i i'm actually preferring uh
jennifer's position despite
her exchange down the bishop's looking
good it's hard not to take white in this
position exactly difference in material
is minimal right this is about as little
as it gets you get an exchange in a pawn
yep um
but you're bearing the bishop is so well
uh
situated on d4 and you start to think
that hey look man i've got uh i've got
tricky ideas and what let's just be
honest the king difference is huge right
black king is actually under some fire
the white game no problems whatsoever
this rooks gets to e3 i can already say
white is clearly better so it really
depends on the next couple of moves
exactly we'll keep an eye on this one by
the way guys breaking news shabalov did
fine yeah the right way uh the right
continuation not the rook bc8 which
would have uh killed the game on the
spot but bishop takes c4 good enough
yeah we saw this line right bishop take
c4 good enough very soon c4 take on f5
we're getting to this position
if we get to this position and he finds
this move e4 what this would kill the
game now is the same cons very similar
concept to that abi manu gaming wow
getting ready to invade the other fifth
rank with the rook open up the fifth
thread and then take it oh very
beautiful once again
once again this idea of r25 rook to g5
improving the quality of my races yeah
of the rook on ba that wasn't doing
anything with the spawn sacrifice e4 if
he finds that that's actually really
really beautiful yes it really is e4 and
rook b5 to stop queen it's not the only
move it's the most precise no it's
definitely what do you like to see
is we expect him to take back with the
queen the reason we do
say that is because knight takes f5 as
logical as it might seem
allows black to simply put a rook on ca
exactly the open file open file
challenge this powerful rook you don't
have a mate thread immediately at least
not i can see
but but that is the killing blow right
after queen takes a 5 e4 if he finds
that
and he is going to play queen takes f5
now
the question is
will uh
not an easy move to make not an easy
move to see no
no but it cannot be the only move right
no i was thinking that he was going to
go queen takes f5 rook g8 for some
reason i was like centered
a rook g8 because i wanted to
attack the pawn on g2 but it might not
be such a big deal right i could take
the rook and g3 or something yeah right
right i was actually
yeah
somehow i thought that was like and here
we go queen five yeah
with e4 and rook e5 but e4 and rook b5
is just so can you do it the other way
around or do i have any problems
queen
you're going to have to go g4g4
h6 or c8
rook c8 also it's all oh oh
yeah rick says
so you got to be precise by the way
dmitry loved what you did against me
and he went for your line uh did uh
dimitri
uh oh he went
yvonne uh igor novikov and navikov
actually said yeah you know i have to
play the move g5 i can't allow this
bishop f4 move let me take a second as
we move away from the board here we go
and this is where we left it and you
really like grabbing this and playing g3
i actually went back with the queen and
then i got stifled after c5
i was trying to meet the move bishop f4
with e5 igor said no i can't allow
bishop f4 i'm going to play g5 h4
king f8 on the board and
i think igor is in big trouble i just
look at the pieces look at the quality
of the piece of the rook on v8 the
knight on d7 the bishop on c8 i don't
want to play it
but but i could take twice on g5 right
and uh then take on a d7 at the end
somehow it's like you i feel like you're
yes you're cashing your chips
you took one and you took two pawns
it's pretty good if you're gonna catch
your chips
i mean the resulting end game might just
be mathematically won right king e7
uh king yes or
bishop pack i will either okay king is
up you got it you got me
take i do have a check you do have a
check maybe it's smarter to go queen c7
instead of uh takes b7 right okay king
e7 queen c7
i was gonna try to grab the a3 pawn you
can
i'll go kings g2 let's go
and here and bishop takes b7 or maybe
queen takes b7 i'm not sure
either way this looks yeah i'm suffering
i mean black is suffering no question
about it black is suffering i just
wanted to check in on uh on the nick the
fermion game because this is the big
moment right for e5 e4
and if he does it wow that would just be
great larry christensen versus uh
max
delugi uh are two
two of our tournament co-leaders coming
into the event
into the round pardon me king h2 king h7
g3 on the board not too much has
happened could i ask you once again
about the clock somehow
i got this tiny tiny claw i mean
what's the clock time 16 minutes for
larry christiansen in six minutes 30 for
maxine lugi a little bit of time
pressure as we are a move 34 so not that
many moves but we like
why the extra 10 minutes yeah
it's not bad the position is also great
right
i like that
larry kept his dark squared bishop but
it feels that white has done some
progress on the king's head and black
immediately
rushed all of his pieces to that side of
the board rook on g6 knight on f5
and that suddenly at some point this
move bishop c7 could be an issue yeah
there might be an a5 pawn it'll be an a5
pawn okay uh also i just want to check
igor who was pawn up against joel
benjamin
is he uh winning he's still up upon but
somehow i think sometimes
really uh fighting his way back into the
game a little okay right back to the
juniors for just a quick second that's
the carissa yep game i wanted to go to
where is christopher
there you are andrew versus christopher
he's got it in the move g5 it feels like
a lot has changed in this position wow
where did we leave it we left it after
rook b2 i felt yes rick v2 bishop rook
b2 bishop d1
rook d8 h3
f5
wow
different approach altogether than what
i was expecting yeah
g5 queen c3
back you go
and i see
six right
yeah but isn't bishop a4 gonna
be an issue
and i'm i'm afraid
that the blockade is going to be lifted
well let's have a look shall we all
right you can do it i guess i have to
play queen c7
i mean you're keeping this why don't we
start with the rook to d3
let's start with rook to d3 in instead
of knight g6 yes let's start with that
and
i've
got to
protect uh and then knight g6 my guys
okay is there a big difference well here
you might go questions entertain queen
d5 oh 25.
you could entertain it i didn't
no but okay queen c7 i mean
either way
f4 is also a problem this feels like a
mess this feels like a mess somehow
instinctively i like black because i do
notice that you got me off my blockade
on c6
you're right man c7 i don't think you're
he's he's that that's a good blackbeard
that's a good blockade
it's funny you should say you like black
uh one of the things i oh my god b3 he
did it oh yeah that was played with a
lot of intent
force force
boom
that's called posting up
maybe uh break a light
but
when the time trouble comes around it's
already here king vulnerabilities oh i
always liked having the save king once
you start to see that f4
you know
these kinds of things around your king
feels for the moment like
black's king is actually safer uh this
this is such a hugely important game for
our standings and it's looking good for
christopher right now
okay
g6 really how do you defend this
position
queen is bishop for the only move and by
the way i think
it's on the board it might not even be
the knight
yeah it might
it's one of the maybe i should just you
know like
yeah just kind of back it off back off a
little bit the problem is that you know
that the next seven moves or eight moves
are extremely important and you only
have five minutes left on the clock
exactly
there are so many threats in the
position that you have to deal with and
you have
to be ready for
this is a very difficult situation for
andrew hung i see that christopher you
is developing a bad habit that boris
gelfand has as well
a bad habit it's a terrible habit i
think so terrible it's terrible it's
distracting it's nerve i i think it's
very very very bad you should distract
him from who
this for your opponent you're trying to
but he's hiding it well right yeah it's
disturbing i mean the guy's spinning the
pieces like you you have a you you have
a visual of the board right and it's not
just that you're looking only at 64
squares you're looking at beyond the 64
scores and there's your your opponent
spinning
but boris does it in front of his uh
yeah divorce nothing
exactly exactly no it's a very bad habit
rid yourself of it if you're uh
if you're new to the game just don't
pick it up it's like just don't do it um
in any case uh andrew is facing some
difficult decisions and four minutes
left for him so we might as well stay in
this one just because it's a crucial
game i'd like to see the little bit of
the time pressure here four minutes for
andrew he needs to come up with the
moves how many moves uh
eight moves so eight oh that's quite a
bit actually that's
that's a lot we're looking at both
bishop a4 and rook on c4 to c3
as the most likely is there another
decision guys yes breaking news yes
shabbat found e4 yeah last year he
played it
doubt this man's attacking capacity a4
came on the board queen takes c4 and if
you play the e4 you're going to go
there is no follow-up because g4 is met
by rook g5 that's the purpose yes you're
just making your rook really strong
maybe queen h6 is always a little bit
queen g5
by the way you have to be a bit careful
do you have rook c8 here say what
what
no
why not
wow
what a visual so maybe you have to be a
bit careful oh my gosh sorry i think age
six
oh my goodness he did not
he played queen takes b2
and queen to h4 came immediately yeah
the nick didn't have there's a knight g6
on tap threat
for a perpetual right right does it win
or oh queen takes b2 he was trying to
pick up the f6 spawn right that's why we
see ch4
all right
what's going on the game goes on guys
games
can i go g8 does that move
rook g8 i take i take g3
yeah but that's a completely different
story right right right that's okay
i don't know do i i have a couple pawns
right i mean let's go rook g8 take take
g3 i pick up a2 with check i'll pick up
b3 as well and on from b3 i defend f7
should i start with picking up a two
with check that's also a good question
dwight i mean b1
cut
as we bring back
that one up because it suddenly got very
very i thought we were gonna stay with
the andrew
uh they're like a game fighting for
competition
[Laughter]
they sure are where are you there we go
we are here
now we could take
queen a want check and we can kind of do
a little dance and take a pawn with shaq
yes but i noticed it was nick who was
got the three minutes
past the time right so maybe not
uh queen a1 now you you mentioned rook
g8
yeah should we just take a quick gander
at that for a moment yeah i take and you
take and you're threatening
g2 but i can deal with that
all right so g3 and now
no i agree you can take the pawn on a2 i
will okay
but can i dance my way to h3 dance your
way to h3 if you felt like it i'll give
it to you but i'll take both pawns
ah covering f7 and
so he played queen a1 he's probably
going to take that pawn on a2 as well i
think so it's kind of free
[Laughter]
why not right and there he goes
and i don't think that white has a lot
of options you go to the third rank
you're just giving me another pawn for
free so you might as well go to the
first rank and he does that king f1
right
and guys just uh
before we continue watching this one
yeah
let's take a look at what's happening in
the game between larry christensen and
maxine lugi because that one well maybe
you can think of developing as well we
left it off somewhere around here and we
did say that the bishop
uh by uh it's uh um
stands in the center
watching both sides of the board just
gives white a nice advantage dominating
but check this move out f6
huge blunder
by black because it cuts the action
of the rook on g6 and now allows me to
post up as you were mentioning i really
like that idea of posting up with the
rook on e6 right and this is exactly
what happened bishop to b2 the exchange
of the rooks knight to d6 yeah rook to
e6 and i would assume this is what he
calculated the problem is
that it's a flawed calculation f5 is
going to be met with bishop to e5
railroad and this is pretty much game
over because right now if you take on e6
i take and then take on that i just
haven't played by the way that's a
problem
exactly f5 is hanging and you're forced
to go into this end game
which you're probably not going to
survive right no there's
do we believe that he can survive this i
understand you're going to try to use
this pawn
as a decoy force me to take it and then
take on e6 and try to survive
that position five pawns versus four
pawns but i'm not sure do you even get
there no i don't even get there what if
i go here
well i see queen d7 is a killing threat
i gotta go b3 don't i b3 yes exactly
really okay is this survivable yeah what
if i go here take no no this is winning
why why would i take though i got you
enough seconds go queen to f8 only move
by the way
yeah only
huh i would be extremely surprised if
you managed to survive this and this
queen to g8 once again
all right that that was beyond my
opinion
[Laughter]
he's in trouble oh wow whether he's
losing or not
take the pawn and then find out yeah
queen takes that back
larry's in the driver's seat there sorry
we're just going to go back to the nick
deferming game what do you have for us
in this game he did play king f1
and in the andrew uh andrew's game uh we
have some moves we might want to update
those sure where are we where are you
christopher
christopher you oops i've got it
sometimes
this is not the position oh this oh
sorry i have to refresh there we go
andrew hogg against christopher you if
we can bring up the analysis board okay
we left it after the move knight g6 and
we thought either rook c3 or bishop a4
were our main considerations and he did
and we were worried about this f4
and he's
captured
three let's go
and that's a discovery against the rook
on c1 as well as
well i don't know i kind of like the
pawn there i don't know
f4 okay
show do your worst um i've got to make a
move clock is ticking i'm feeling it i
don't want to allow rook b1 i'll go here
kill me
what's the killer
i want you to take on g2 and allow me to
play the move bishop to g4
and i'm i feel like i'm back in the game
with a shout guys i just want to draw
your attention and maybe we can see that
as well as the camera to the game of
rochelle wu and talia cervantes
we thought that game was in the bag
there is one more move that she needs to
find right now yeah if we can get the
position we got it
right here
right here this isn't a puzzle rush test
the critical moment and i don't think
she found it what do you mean
she played rook to f3 i think it was
rook takes f7 this allows me to go back
to g6 what is this
whoa
what have she missed an opportunity here
what does rook have seven
rook e f a rookie eight so let's go back
and maybe we can uh show your board okay
we're over here
yeah we thought we she was completely
winning right yeah right after rook
takes d6
okay i'll just
i'll quiz you guys yep find the winning
move find the winning move here yeah yes
there's only one
we have three is still advantage but
check find the the move that forces
resignation forces
nation
i
i'm constantly looking at these rook f7
ids hold on the queen is also tethered
to the rook on decent no rookie one
makes no sense why would i
chase the queen to a better square
rook g3 check rook g6 where's the
follow-up alejandra it doesn't doesn't
seem like it's there right
i don't see anything after rook g3
richie sucks no me either
rookie 8
feels slow
keep digging keep digging rook e a no no
g6 not repeating g3 it forces
resignation in one move
wow wow once you see it it's just like
explosive right it's just explosive
gotcha it's one of those moves that's
just once you see it
it's there
boy it's hidden again there's only one
defensive piece that black has the rook
on f8 oh my god it's rook d7 rook d7 oh
that's beautiful
yeah because it's a pin against the
queen on d1 as well of course yeah it's
one of those
it's a shish kebab
a skewer as uh we would say
she did
now after rook f3 rook g6 okay it's a
game game flare is a new it's a game
because after rook f7 i get it you take
my pawn but i can just sidestep i can go
rook to d8 right where's the mate
and the pawns are still equal so if i
manage to exchange the queens somehow
queen d6 is coming that way and maybe i
have some chances right yeah a dream
come true this is still a game wow
italia fighting her way back into this
game
while we're here i might as well just
check in on jennifer you for a second i
like her position alice lee
um
now she's down two points and now she's
down two pawns should be
lost she should be lost
okay sorry i'm going to jump back to uh
the senior section just checking in on
the nick deferming game
rook
be8 was throwing in at some point now
notice that he does it with the queen on
b1 yes so there's no knight g6 right
right so no knight g6 checks uh that
would be a double pin right right you
can't take with the pawn f on rook
and nick dropped back with his rook
not a good sign
uh rook to c4 no he's hoping for queen
takes b3 i guess
let's show everybody what alejandra
please take the pawn and oops
that's a visual i know this maid has a
name that's about the extent of it right
right that yeah i cut the king with the
knight yeah and there's some this is the
name by the way
no probably not right that's something
else no idea but
that mate with the knight on e7 and the
rook coming to the h file it's worth at
least two points in the puzzle rush
oh yes
no no i'm saying that that two puzzles
come out ah
yeah yeah queen h7 and
uh
um rook c4 on the board the clock times
it looked like seven minutes two minutes
on 21 for nick deferman chavalo 6.
can
uh shabala slow play the position with
a5 you're asking if white has any threat
at all that's my question yes andrew
hung down to his last 45 seconds oh
we're going there too
give us an evolve here before we leave
so that we don't jump this much black
black is looking good black is looking
good okay black is a little we'll take
that
there nothing has changed in terms of uh
e valley still minus like
five
okay
sure and they're going to refresh my
board
winning
oh he did put his i wanted to put the
bishop on g4 as a kind of a defensive
piece he went the other way did andrew
bishop his last 15 seconds
how much 10 seconds five and counting g
takes f3 this is what
exactly it cannot be this must be losing
no the bishop should be on g4 right not
no
it's the wrong side wait what happens if
i type with the knight well that is
that's the question
because he did it
uh i have to move my king i don't want
to give up the rook no you give up the
can't give up the rook here no
what's the point of that king
g2 that is a little bit
question-ish king h-1
all right all right he feels that it's
safer on g2
okay he does have an idea c6 c7 let's go
that's a good idea too yeah push him
okay so let's go forward getting up from
the node with 40 seconds on his clock
let's go for the material guys nine nine
d2 why not that is a four that's a fork
here yeah but there's a queen g4
sighting isn't there so you want to go
queenie too
g4
i'd rather go after this bishop than
this night
queen the eighth how is that position i
think dang i think green date is
maybe winning maybe
that's an important thing
i don't care he's going 46
uh
and they've made 40 moves
is very strong
understanding is very important
yes
by the way christopher holding his
knight like
am i sure
[Applause]
your with understanding comment just a
second ago inspired me to remember a
line of uh bent larson
bent larson was asked
ben how come you never became world
champion
and here comes the answer you ready for
the answer it's a fantastic answer
well there were better players than me
great understanding right
he shows understanding uh guys yes
please christian
is talia just fully backing the game
right why
no way if she finds queen decision takes
f3 queen takes away he takes f and she
found it that's it from you is it whoa
the tactics worked out the training
of the
hours
spent on tactics finally turn around
three and that is one unhappy rochelle
oh my gosh
like how did i save this game coach is
gonna say
remember all of those tactical puzzles
that all of our tactics that we trained
for and talia said it is a drunk it's a
trend it's a drug it's a drop wow what a
safe
incredible rochelle must be furious with
herself
and that makes the game of sofia so that
much more more irrelevant yes
alice lee versus sophia
okay alice has one no
i was about to say alice won back no
alice brown is dead it's two pawns two
pawns still two pawns i'm that dead dead
nothing to discuss okay jennifer is on
her way to victory as well what a round
oh wow is she actually oh yeah
she's going through rook h3 oh my gosh
how did this go is zoey's king
zoe's king just got f6 and by the way
these ladies are playing on increment
right now because there's still six
moves to go and they both are under 40
seconds on the clock wow well jennifer's
just played
great chess during this whole
time scramble she's every move has been
you know
very salient to the position
well she has a bit of a threat uh rook
h3
would be an unescapable mate so what do
we do here i guess if you take on d4
that's just over
late wait how does that help you
don't think that helps
we're expecting rook you give one check
but do you give more than that after
king to h2 i don't know
we're expecting rookie h3 h3 rookie one
king h2 and that's the end of your
checks unless you give up a rook with
rook h1 i think you have to play queen
age seven but again this this threat of
maiden i don't know why
by the way are you encouraging me to
play bishop takes g6 or f and even
f7 at the end of it f7 just wins now
that bishop takes g6 is really just take
your choice yeah there's so many winning
moves i i this is it this is right and
she's played queen h first
um
but now bishop takes g6 you said f7 as
well oh sorry but queen takes h7 and f7
after
that f7 that's it yeah that's it no no
you take first i think it's more
accurate take first and she's i think
she's going for it because she's reached
for the queen she sees it
queen takes h7
no
she played queen g3 wow
yeah that's a very good idea
but f7 immediately what was the answer
there's no answer to any move yeah
escape f7 rook takes f7 queen
she did not give a check on e1 oh she
played between h7 first okay i've got
the wrong position my apologies i uh
but now after queen g3 this just looks
over right yes bishop takes g6 you give
one check but that's a spike check i go
king h2n oh
bishop b7 bishop b7
king h2 bishop b7 spike check no oh
you want to give us fight mate despite
this
but i have queen b8 we have queen b you
have f7 you have a choice of uh
choice of victory queen b8 is cruel yeah
so the problem is you probably have to
go queen takes h3 but after queen takes
c3 rook h7 you have f f7 as always yeah
that's the go-to move there or queen
takes h7 and f7 after that and there's
no way to
stop the pawn stop
the vultures the voices are arriving
right
and the times of the player one minute i
guess 30 seconds
and counting for tang yeah but i think
this is irrelevant at this point
got her hawk-like look on i mean she and
she's looking at the clock just uh you
don't want to see this girl fired up no
you know she can win a lot of games in a
row she started slow two draws
two wins in a row for this one i mean
this one game must be completely over
brooke f7 take the queen no i'm taking
the pawn on g6 yeah i think take the
ball on g6 right
take on g6 open up black's king's
position exactly
i must say that once the players got
into the time trouble it just seemed to
me that jennifer took a new
[Music]
yeah sometimes you feel the difference
of strength in players exactly yeah
exactly by the way bishop takes g6 queen
takes h3 guy assists oh sorry the bishop
is still on is that is that really that
clear no no no no i i forgot that the
bishop was still on c8 what what are we
playing here by the way
if i take the q if she takes the queen
you take with the rook it's
not rook h4 good enough
because again queen takes h4 queen takes
h4 rook h7 our favorite f7 move wait but
now do we have queen to b8 uh queen beat
oh
that's a beauty that's a visual queen b8
check yes look at a
f7
you don't actually need f7 but it's good
enough oh but it's so nice
though no you could
oh no you're right you do need to
because if you take on a fade you i have
rook h1 yeah yeah
by the way dimitri gray which we had
said that his position was done very
good did beat igor navikov that's a huge
result for the seniors one of the
leaders going down exactly you kind of
called that early by the way uh pretty
sure about that one right f7 that's a
visual that that's you know it's going
to go on the chess.com puzzle rush
you know and that forces resignation
yeah it's a pretty move losing
everything with chuck
that's where you stop calculating that's
it
nice nice manicure by the way
that's resignation
big victory there jennifer you're
definitely
not a clean one no but a win is a win as
we've been saying very often in this
tournament exactly and she jumps back
into three points out of four still
fully in contention for first place but
there is a person in the junior girls
that we think is gonna go not three out
of four not three and a half out of four
good four four out of four and that girl
is sophia sophie mori suzuki is still
nursing those two pawns they just
finished their time control so they have
plenty of time to figure out anyway
it used to be one pawn
now it's two pawns exactly yes so now
it's pretty much game over uh a game
that kind of slipped away from us is the
game between ellen and rue yang yan and
it well uh big material big big big
material win
for ellen and at this moment
she's an exchange and
a pawn to the good and by the way guys
we do have another result brandon
jacobson did win his game against david
we also call that one as expected
all right let's go to uh
for me
how come my
thing is ah because i'm using the wrong
key
and let's take a look at the results uh
uh alejandro yeah we had a lot of
results come in a row especially during
time pressure this one was huge rochelle
what a save what a safe but what a miss
by rochelle honestly uh drawing that
game against talia cervantes talia thank
you for lucky stars but she's currently
in second place alongside jennifer you
as they uh i expect will trail sophie by
a full point another result that we had
we have this one which is jenny for you
beating zoe tang we just saw this one a
big result for jennifer zoe not finding
her stride in this tournament but if i
remember correctly she has played some
of the top seeds so there's still plenty
of chests to be shown by this young girl
and we have as we said dimitri grivich
besting igor namikov now dimitri has
been on the back foot i felt in every
game so far right especially against max
especially against max lugi in the first
round but in the one chance he was given
he took it he took it so he's on plus
one two and a half points by four and of
course we had in the juniors
brotsky losing with the white pieces not
a great tournament for him so far one
point out of four two draws and brandon
jacobson bouncing back from a very slow
start actually ended up losing the first
round drawing the second and two wins in
a row but what uh wins they have been
these companies bringing the heat with
black
the joco pianos uh very very nice by the
way the game that dimitri gervich did
win went directly down the line that you
had a spouse oh yeah yeah it captures
captures and the queen and bishop versus
the queen and bishop and that's too
strong it was just too much
and igor novakov went down i wanted to
pick up the game that had our attention
the players have made the time control
and that's the one between nick the
fermion and um alexander shabolov
you can see the vestiges of a kingside
attack and you're kind of shipwrecked
essentially if you're uh white here uh
you were you were going all gung-ho
there for a long time but there was a
moment when we thought the move rook c8
might uh
you know change the course of uh who's
attacking who it looks like it's time
it's time yeah rook city looks very
strong i'm wondering if i throw in queen
d2 first but
but i didn't think i needed it because
yes i understand what you mean too like
you would play queen d2 jack and well i
assume you go to f3 because that was
already where the king was oh i'm sorry
yeah they made a repetition to make time
control okay and i thought about that
nick will repeat because i think if you
go to g1 i go to queen e3 and i'm i made
you without the rooks oops
okay so king f3 and now i think you go
rook c8 you don't have the thread on h7
that i can see it's important to show
why because i can interpose the queen
yep
that's why
right so
and rook c3 i take the rook but now i'm
facing oops
let's look at c3 yes i mean this king's
not surviving no i don't think so so can
well keep an eye on that one
my pick to win the tour tournament joel
benjamin definitely on the back foot
can he save
well
yeah not so bad right wait a minute i
mean
igor's extra pawn
hasn't made any impression in the
position as far as i can tell pawn on c2
is not dangerous and this night on c5
wait a minute guys you know
give black some moves here
i mean what you know black could easily
be better here how did i get to it okay
i'm not sure
why i think black can be better i
understand i was being a little bit
facetious but only by a little i mean
i'm not i'm not so sure right
uh
how do you play this as white if imagine
you played knight c4 and i played bishop
take c4 uh
would you want to play white
no that one for sure not exactly right
but then what do you do you got to
retreat right well you have the knight
a4 right do you have any threats in the
position uh other than bishop takes c4
which was mike no no no no
nothing in the initial position i don't
want to play knight c4 okay i understand
i'm gonna make a pretense that the move
f5
is
something i'm something i consider i
don't know if i want to play right away
probably if you give me a free move i'll
play bishop e6 and
yes i understand maybe i'm not better
but so in that case let's try to do
something as white let's go g4 g4 g5 g4
g5 okay g whiz
uh and then i go rook h3
you know it's funny if i could just get
my bishop to be able to attack this pawn
on e4 yeah it's difficult uh but i'm not
even i kind of want to
encourage i feel the move g5
right
what is this nonsense rook h4 let's do
it all right let's go g5 this guy's
going to trick me and i'm going to
i'm going to be doing that xp but i'm
going to i still want to see it right
g5 rook takes g5 rook takes e4 i assume
the engine has some move here no no i i
haven't took the engine route g8 that
would be andrew k4
[Music]
oh
i had kind of stopped after rook g8 i
hadn't seen rook a4 i don't know if like
this is bad because rook city's house
okay but no no no i just want to play
normal chess knight c4
normal chess
i think i want to go to a8 i want to get
to a8 with my rook understood i mean
that one makes sense there's only one
weakness in black's position and that is
the pawn on asap he wants to get to it
maybe all right
wow
um
i think uh i think uh joel is fighting
his way back in the game we'll keep an
eye on that but in the meanwhile we're
going to go back to christian who is uh
has a guest well we have a lady that is
definitely counting her lucky stars
what an escape
yeah i almost couldn't believe it thank
you
take us through the game because it felt
like out of the opening you were doing
fine and after that something really bad
happened because you ended up in a very
difficult position
right so i did prepare a little bit not
specifically the line that she played i
was kind of looking more at bishop takes
e5 and that is the main line right right
right so it's very interesting actually
like bishop takes um knight d7
bishop f4
um
six perhaps yeah knight of six now and
the idea is that now you do have knight
c7 because if bishop b4 there's going to
be visual d2
so um
kindy eight and then knight a8 queen e4
92 queen eight and there's some wild
stuff yeah it's it's crazy but somehow
i'm also the lions my keys okay even if
it's on the eight and i have the queen
side pawn so
it's not it's not like anything crazy
for black but it's just a game so i
thought it could be interesting
uh but she took away the pawn and i
didn't remember most most of the and by
the way but this preparation i had here
it did feel like you surprised her in
the opening with this idea of b5 and e5
right that's very rare i don't surprise
many people
um
but yeah so i thought i thought i played
normal and then all of a sudden my
position is just
so difficult to play um
yeah especially here i feel like knight
d3 is probably my only move i could
consider going back to c6 but then f5
comes
and um i felt like this was just the
worst version of something um similar to
what happened in the game
take with the knight or uh
probably
oh i have that
bishop
right
is f6 still
[Music]
possible i wasn't always i was never
sure
[Music]
if those of six like she's just going to
sacrifice the exchange
it looks very scary it does it does
maybe you don't even have to take on f6
maybe you can go bishop takes b2 be even
uh
more hungry
oh
okay
kind of goes on style yeah so maybe this
was maybe this was better i felt like i
was completely out playing the position
and i didn't know exactly
like if it was just one moment or
a combination of bad moves probably that
but it just felt like and you fell into
this very difficult position right and
let's uh speed things up a little bit
and go all the way down the biggest show
is that my pieces are on the opposite
side so nothing can help the king side
like my bishop luckily i have that
bishop e3 that just
at least you know puts it to use but
but in general my position is just so
bad
however you just basically had to wait
for her to find something
right yeah i felt like i had some hope
because i i saw this whole thing so
let's stop here yeah did you see the
winning move for white
at this point no
there's a winning rule there is a move
that forces resignation
oh my goodness
no i just your your only defensive piece
is the rook on d6 how do you distract
that oh there's rook d7 rook december
that is so beautiful i yeah i didn't see
that at all i was hoping that i mean
my position is still worse i felt but i
was hoping that at least now i kind of
survive and we knew that you're back in
the game after this
she told me that she missed the rook d6
you only saw queen takes e6 and
obviously that doesn't work and here i
was like okay i got to survive after
queen d6 but then i was thinking a
little bit longer and i actually just
have queen of three so that was that was
uh very lucky
talia a big escape for you still
congratulations
and we're looking forward to seeing the
rest of your games thank you keep
fighting keep fighting tell you wow what
a save come on coach
and i had written that one up
life
insurance was it
the compensation was already here wow
wow but we've had a number of results
and we have more guests coming in yeah
we're gonna wait a second for them to
get plugged in uh let's take a quick
look to the andrew hong and christopher
u game let's do it it's such a crucial
game for the standings of course and
they're actually following
an analysis that we made
all the way down to queen d8 which we
really liked this was the knight d2
yep yep yep yep and queen
within a c rook b7 but right rook b7 got
tossed in there too but this queen d8
moved now
and
i i think i gotta take on e6 right
you can't i go rook f7
oh it's check check check check yeah i
apologize you're right and because there
is no queen e6 i think i'm just calling
this game it's just right it's terrible
in that case uh okay queen e4 go ahead
kill me
what is it just put me out of my misery
she would be the easiest i think
i know rook f7 and maybe rook here right
rook f7 looks winning
yes like decisively it looks
like
five also looks like it picks up
material i mean do you need anything
else outside the rook at four yeah you
don't really like queen a5 attacks the
bishop on a four and a half between two
eight
that's a pretty good doublet that's a
pretty good attack
we think that christopher you is on the
verge of victory but we have another
guest with us
brandon another day another win with the
black pieces in the joko piano another
incredible idea in the opening do you
consider yourself already an expert in
the joko piano do you want to play black
every single game
well i think i just got lucky that my
opponents played lines specific movers
that allowed these ideas
the main way of playing with rookie one
h3 doesn't really allow any interesting
ideas and you kind of just have to go
rookie bishop e6 and play something
normal um but i was definitely happy to
see knight d2 over the board because
this net h5 i mean i don't even know it
too well myself but i looked at it for a
few minutes and it's pretty unexplored
it's only been played a couple times at
the gm level um and it was uh three
games and none very conclusive for sure
and i like i couldn't find a clear event
past an advantage for white and at least
i'm going to get an interesting game and
not something that i've hundreds
analyzed so yeah already d4 i think is
probably inaccurate
um because the point is in all these
lines where i'm not castled he always
has to watch out for something like g5
and knight f4 queen f6 comes with like
an extra tempo before i before i castle
um so here knight b3 i believe is the
best move knight b3 knight b3 yeah
so it looks a bit though in the wrong
direction right just to make room for
the bishop but like if knight f4 for
example then bishop b3 i'm not really
creating any threats and if you go queen
f6 instead of
queen f6 and bishop g5 followed by
bishop e3 i think is totally playable
um it's actually kind of funny after
knight b3 i was planning on yeah i think
we have six was played in the game
before
um
but i think after knight b3 castle is
supposed to be better and it's pretty
funny so bishop g5
knight f6 is the best move and okay
there there are a bunch of moves here
for white but one of the best moves is
knight bd2 backwards
so you're getting like a normal kind of
line except i forced him to play this
bishop g5 and then you can play like h65
and you get an interesting game but it's
kind of a funny way of getting back to a
normal position i hate the joker piano
my hatred has been confirmed as well he
goes g3 which felt wrong to me and i
have a lot of options here i mean i
probably spent too much time looking at
all this like h5 instead of h6 um
queen f6 at the right moment there are a
lot of different options for black but i
figured h6 knight g5 was like the most
principle then um
and here you spend a lot of time on this
move queen f6
yeah for sure so what was the reason for
that
so okay i want to take on d4 of course
and then he has knight f5 which is the
which is what i actually missed from a
few moves before
um and it actually gets very dangerous
for me um
i think perhaps i can play something
like g6 here and i was trying to
evaluate this then he goes knight takes
d4
i can go knight back to h3
but in all these lines like there are a
lot of these positions where i can win
the d-pawn and let's say he goes f4 here
where like my knight doesn't i'm not
losing my knight but it's just kind of
stranded in h3 and i can win the d-pawn
but i wasn't really sure how to evaluate
these positions
so it's basically a much worse version
than what you got right yeah
but after cleaning up six i didn't i
think knight f5 was not a good move um
i thought he should do something like
queen f3 instead of knight f5
um
and it's kind of interesting because
like i don't know what white's next move
is but i don't know what black's move is
either like if you go bishop h3 and cast
along you can already start going b4 for
example
um
and another interesting line is bishop
let's say rookie one here bishop h3
rookie one
um i probably wasn't gonna go bishop h3
because knight g6 now
and then i think knight f5 was pretty
scary
um
do you have any crazy ideas like g5
instead of knight g6 back probably not
yeah so i was gonna probably go knight
g6 immediately just my bishop doesn't
get stranded on h3
um and then
he can take the queen but then
it feels like black shouldn't really
have any problems here because i mean
the d-pawn is still hanging
so i thought maybe something like this
should happen and it's probably around
equal um
and you were surprised by the fact that
he gave you the pawn with 95 f4 for sure
how did you assess the position right
yeah so i thought this was just really
good for me but i think instead of queen
takes d4 i didn't need to let any of
this queen h5 i mean bishop h3 here was
was my first instinct
um but i missed this detail that after
e5
um
yeah so i saw that take do you take c5 f
takes e5 queen c6
all right okay f6 because
yeah if eod takes in queen c6 is just
probably winning for black queen c6
uh d5
queen c5 let's say
rookie one
yeah and it's like i wanted to cast
along here and then i thought okay queen
h5 and then it's unclear and i ended my
line here but i miss bishop g2 which i
realize as soon as i move that in the
end of all this i have bishop g2
if he doesn't go queen h5 then i think
his position just sort of falls apart
because where it takes d5 is a threat
and then
this should just be winning so bishop h3
kind of just avoids all this coin h5
stuff everywhere and then i'm probably
getting a better version of the game
um
but okay i think what i did was good
enough
but it got really interesting around
here so
kinetic is the mistake really what is
what is the move then instead i think it
was a surprise yeah i think bishop d7
was what that knight has always
recommended
f3 here bishop d7 um
what was the problem
i think queen f6 is good enough to
maintain a slight advantage okay it's
not that bad yeah i guess i was afraid
of i don't know what i was afraid of
there but okay queen f6 knight f3 yeah i
think seven was very important actually
right
yeah because otherwise it's f5 is coming
but okay instead of f5 there's this
interesting bishop d2 which i think he
should have played
and here i was trying to calculate all
these lines um bishop d2 instead of f5
instead
sorry
apologies
yeah and then i go queen g6
and okay objectively i white should
probably take on g6 and go bishop c3 and
you do have some compensation for that
pawn you have some activity maybe e5 is
going black should be the only one who
can win that but after queen g6 there's
this move queen a5
what yeah
queen and
it looks super scary for black but i i
think i calculated my way out of this i
thought queen takes e4
queen c3
and okay g7 is hanging your rookie one
is coming it looks like black's like in
big trouble here but i think i have this
idea of d5
bishop d3
and d4
d
and i'm just in time with my play and i
bring the queen back i have bishop b6
blocking d file if i need it i think
black is kind of surviving here
um
so
i'm pretty sure this was correct
but so i guess he should he should go
bishop b2 and queen takes g6 and try to
draw that end game somehow but i think
after what i got in the game with the
queen trade and then once that was
pretty much smooth yeah for your brand
for me brandon two uh big victories for
you congratulations tomorrow i think you
have a big game against the wonder uh
are you going to uh andrew andrew hong
yeah okay how are you going to get ready
for that one um we're actually good
friends we know a lot of each other's
openings so it's going to be tough like
to find something that we haven't talked
about before but
well yeah i'll see what i can come up
with tonight well looking forward to see
your game tomorrow thank you
thank you brandon congratulations
speaking of andrew hong let's go
straight into that game i believe that
christopher you is putting the final
touches on that game because we see such
an important game such a huge game
bishop f2 e3 a very nice move in this
position a little bit of a geometry
there uh so we can get the analysis
board up first
there is a rook f7 there's a rook b1 and
what is the killer after bishop b1
bishop b1 i also going to give it up to
bishop e3 now oh please i have to work
right i don't know you have to be three
it's spinned on the g file but d3 check
yeah this one i i saw actually i thought
okay that's pretty
convincing hey yeah so can you give me
the easy balls yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i'll pass it thank you
a softball here softball thank you i
love my softballs all right bishop e1 my
bishop e1 i mean queen f8 looks like
death right queen f8 looks like death
don't ask me uh there is rook be to yeah
can you
but
i is it
can i confuse you somehow you can you
can definitely confuse me i'm already
confused it's been like right
days and nights
yes exactly exactly
can i run
all right let's go let's just chase you
rugby too
i guess king d3
and then i could
play
you know
queen the eight and try to made you
but at least queen d this late but at
this point man i'm just gonna go queen
f5 and say you know what
fine fine get out of
here we have uh christian with a guest
thank you yasser we are with a lady that
is surging through the rankings right
now uh a consecutive victory for you
jennifer congratulations still a shaky
opening
yeah there's something this was just bad
there's nothing to say about it i was a
bit um so i when i prepped against her i
thought she was like she only played um
king's indian so i played d4 she plays
z5 and i'm like oh my god she's going to
play queen's game preparation was over
yeah and i was like okay i'll just do
something random so i played uh i played
bishop four because i was like i don't
think she knows how to play you know
kind of london instruction and i i mean
i've played this enough with black like
i was like i'll just do something and
then i didn't accidentally supposed to
like the grunfeld and in this position i
know like i think the lion is dixie and
then i was just i don't know what i was
thinking i just thought i could do
something to like kind of
um not play into like theory but but
even after dxc it's like a wild theory
going on yeah
yeah
yeah that's exactly why i'm playing this
because you know i wasn't i didn't prep
into this going to the game i think
knight d7 don't allow bishop e5
yeah some wild theory i i think there's
some old games here yeah i've studied
this a while ago but you know i wasn't
really
i don't think she plays as either as
black but i just didn't want to get into
this so um i thought
i realized like what i played was not
that great
no e5 is coming and everything opens up
how did you assess the position at this
point i mean i wasn't a big fan of my
position but i thought i could have some
practical chances just because you know
the knight is pretty strong bishop
switched on but she had she got
a really interesting idea here with
bishop b6 bishop h6
and i wasn't sure exactly what to do
against this
um
yeah and i takes a6 i wanted to take on
a but um
i just thought she looked awful so i
think it was the right decision not to
take it
yeah um yeah i just looked awful and
i thought you know i have some
compensation here just one question here
uh i think the boys were recommending
this move queen to a5 did you consider
it at all yeah i thought queen a5 was
better
um
and against this i'm not sure maybe
i can try
b4 and then
um
the queen c2 but it looks really shaky
yep
still a game
nevertheless still a game you still have
dark square
control so she took on a6 and that
allowed you to get the king to safety
which i'm sure you were happy about yeah
yeah i mean as soon as i took on d4 you
know i think i'm fine um and now i'm
just pushing
and then let's go towards the end
because
there was some wild stuff going on there
yeah we finished off quite nicely
let's go keep going yeah i had a pretty
easy win somewhere and then i just yeah
here i could just take on h7 but i i
like i i played queen g there and i was
like oh queen takes h7 that's just the
fourth win but
yeah i mean i guess it's the winning
it's still winning
and
yeah rook horror was a good move
don't go bishop takes g6 were you uh
tempted about bishop takes g6 instead of
rook h4
well um it was the same thing like a
move ago if she played bishop b7 so i
was kind of uh prepped this was our
initial move and then we realized that
queen takes h3 there's still a bishop on
c8 yeah yeah yeah it was yeah that was
kind of
um that was a close one but i guess it
all worked out
it did indeed uh a big victory for you
jennifer congratulations guys any
questions no just keep it up to zero
do two wins in a row
she seems like not such a nice person
we're being told
i got this in the back menacing in the
other one
congratulations
yeah congratulations jennifer two in a
row you feeling uh
good about your chances
um
i mean i got
yeah i mean i'm playing every game to
win so
um pretty happy i got to win the last
two games because the first two just
started off
just very um i mean they were they
weren't the most interesting games and i
just messed up near the end so
um
i just want to get some momentum going
and then
we'll see
all right well good to see that keep it
going rectified yes always good to see
jennifer play good chess with plenty of
games left uh just checking the game of
alice lee and sophie for a moment
because again
uh sophie 3-0 and about to make it 4-0
no real changes in this game two extra
pawns for sophie mori suzuki over alice
lee exactly that's all i can really say
about this game this one has changed
dramatically what the heck is going on
chavalo by the way did end up
checkmating dick defermion
making a great impression but i'm sure
we'll have shabbat talk to us about that
whoa
white king got knocked yeah that was the
rook ca they weren't exactly in the
lines that we thought of and eventually
the king i mean it it gets made at some
point the king walked all the way across
the board that was nice it's not gonna
survive no uh we have some other games
which i think are about to finish i just
wanted to check in with larry for a
moment larry christensen definitely not
again
uh it's a queen and pawn ending extra
pawn for we'll be we'll be here a while
correct what else did you have for us uh
acts actually in the juniors that we
have most of our potential results this
one of course is very important andrew
hung against christopher
you they're not going down this
variation right
oops excuse me let me just refresh my
board yeah this is the current position
that they have uh bishop e1 not queen f8
but queen d3 instead king g2
uh let's see if there's anything
immediate queen d5 played
yeah this looks lost completely lost
boy just at the moment that i'm
completely confused you say it's
completely lost
why is it oh don't think that's on e5 i
want to take on g5 let's check
but you go rook g7 i know that
i'm saying that i move my king you know
and i'm ready to take on g5 i don't have
a threat you don't have a threat no
after king g1 you can and i could
actually try to hope that you play this
i can play rook g7 and be like okay that
g5 is actually mine i think yeah seven
just three rough g7 is a very very
powerful move yep yep i think this is
just done and the other one that's
actually we haven't been able to look at
it too much but balaji don't go patty
against justin wang has this
fascinatingly weird position i didn't
know how to evaluate this at the
beginning
so maybe we can take a look uh
white is in the on the attack down upon
the mate threatening made in one now
there are some i assume there must be
some sort of counter play but perhaps
there's nothing
um
first of all i need to not get paid
right right but you're you're always
questioning yourself should i throw in a
check and if i do toss in the check
where should i toss it in b1 d1
i mean like what's going on there's also
ideas of rook g2 and knight f4 but okay
so let's ask the sailing in question how
big a threat is rook h a check
i got rookie says that's a good question
all right i assume that i have to give
this check because if i don't i don't
see any
why did you spend so much time
putting your rook on this
now
the usual tactical books
always had us playing queen g8 and queen
h7 but i i see no reason why you would
want to chase the king to f6 so you have
to come up with something a little bit
more impactful at this moment i don't
care if it's knight h4 or something else
maybe it is not h4 though i have to i
think i have to keep chasing this king
around
well you better
nail it right because uh there is a
counter attack coming knight h4 wow this
is double-edged stuff i i'm not 100 sure
what's going on here alejandro but we
have a special guest with christian
thank you guys we are indeed with a
legend of american uh chess mr gravity
welcomes the show welcome back uh to st
louis tell us a bit about your
experience so far in the tournament oh
i'm i'm i'm very happy to be here
players in my tournament i know them for
for a very long time
since the 80s
since the 90s
so it's wonderful to be here and to
watch them i learn i learn from young
players also
they're very good
absolutely a
slow start at the beginning you were
maybe you know it was that for me no it
was it was a very good start because i
was probably in a bad position say
completely lost in round one in with
position in every game at some point so
for me it's not a slow start you managed
to survive in the other one and finally
you actually took over in this game tell
us a bit about this game
well igor navika was a very famous
player and he very rarely loses so i i
wasn't expecting this result that's
pretty much amazing results for me uh
and it was always very interesting to to
play this him prepare for him you know
so he's more or less plays the same
openings so uh being very very strong uh
he
used to be a great politician in that
time
and now he he probably knows all the
openings he played but this one maybe he
he didn't play for a few years so
it was my lucky chance did he surprise
you with this triangle set up or the
he played it before i was choosing some
things against it and
um if i
go for example he offers you to play
normal uh semi slav defense
and
that one he knows one of the best in the
world just used used to be like couple a
few years ago so he knows it all
and and this one uh it's position which
allows you if you if you
different ways to play
one classical movies bishop d2 and but i
prefer nazis
it doesn't give too much but but you got
this position and
i think
right where yasser was with the two
bishops
it is it is a good position i think he
made a little bit of an accuracy because
he didn't have to
probably castle too early but this
position i saw in advance and then you
have to make very exact moves if i you
make one but move you have quincy for
dubious i'm i'm glad to see that because
i didn't know what to do i was uh
considering certain certain moves like
queen h4h4 i didn't see anything
particularly good bishop a7 doesn't do
too much in my opinion i'm not sure it
wasn't that much
g4 or something yeah but i'm not sure
what's going on i'm i'm pretty curious
myself well queen to d4 is not a bad
move it's just
this is the queen of five is a very bad
move i saw it but
i i'm sure white is better but how much
better i don't know so 95 probably it's
the move to consider uh the main move
and then uh i would have played right
away i'm not sure maybe bishop b6 was
one of them sorry to interrupt you
dimitri we have yeah it's i can't wait
position
be saying and i do think uh
larry won that game right yes larry won
against uh maxim he was better he was
better a little bit but in the opening i
thought he was winning completely but
then i realized no probably not max is a
good defender
yeah but this is a probably this is the
move yeah so
yeah this this means for black but for
white but i'm not sure
if i did everything right i mean i
played the most conservative
move
and this is very good position yes i
have to play c5 and after that
position is winning but uh if you make
mistake you know yeah
it wasn't not i think the best thing to
do was not to give a check
but to play c6 right away yeah this is
this is probably he has a little bit you
felt like you're giving him some chances
yeah definitely but it's a old
expression the parts receives a check he
gives it
yeah so this is a position when i was
expecting
to play at some point no this is winning
but could he play something like queen
d6 maybe that was okay in the seven i'm
not sure so
i i think it's one position but it's not
not easy at all i mean if he plays the
correct move
so
[Music]
where exactly up here yeah this is
meaningful this is already winning maybe
one move earlier a little bit but king
the sixth queen to d8 that should be
winning uh
yeah so what is the queen queen d3 yeah
this is what he played yes he played he
did okay okay and after going to f4
okay so maybe here queen to f5 is that
yes it's possible yes this is it and
then
can he play
can he eat maybe
no then c7 no it looks winning it looks
winning more or less yeah he doesn't
have time to get the queen to d6 it
seems like yes yes
it is it looks like it's uh yeah he
offered me if i go for for
the end game this extra pawn it's very
good drawing chances absolutely yes but
this one
gives me a lot of options
uh
to how to play and it's very position
you can you can
choose different plans more or less safe
which should be winning but
of course end game is always
some amazing things happen well the
dimitri are confident victory i have to
say congratulations guys any questions
no just our congratulations uh like you
were surprised you had such bad
positions dima and uh
oh you had such a bad position
very badly yeah plus score is very nice
hey bad positions but no bad results so
you can't complain about that plus i
cannot complain about anything
keep up keep up the good work
absolutely and by the way the seniors
have been very very slow
in terms of victories and suddenly in
this the fourth round the floodgates
have opened and we're three out of three
as we can refresh the results for just a
second
some of the ones that we had uh they
seem to be rushing in a row nick the
fermion lost against alexander chabal of
a brilliant attack there by shabba dabba
in a kind of crazy sicilian both sides
through their chances but black ends up
on top meanwhile larry christensen takes
advantage of a mistake in the negative
imax seemed looging what could have been
a very long queen on pawn end game maxim
actually blunders an intermediate check
and larry c takes the full point without
having to spend all that day in
conversion exactly
and with us of course we have one of the
winners shabba is with christian
we do have uh and in shabbat with us
congratulations uh
a great game for you with the black
pieces how did you approach it you were
having a difficult tournament up to that
point uh
yeah for some reason uh
you know
cannot find my flow until this game and
i
tried a lot of different things
um you know i i played almost non-stop
for a month before this uh this
tournament i
played in
uh world team seniors in italy and then
i played world open and i was hoping
that i'll be here
at least at least not rusty but
well didn't work out so far
but uh
today well thanks to nick's blunders uh
you know
a lot of traveling for you also uh was
uh you playing tennis because we met in
the elevator and you were just coming
back from tennis against ray robson
right make a difference oh ray
excellent yeah excellent player by the
way he's a
college level player and uh well
beats me so
it took him took him two hours to
beat me in a whole match so you know i
was holding it for a while
and
did that give you any confidence for
today's game uh it's more like uh
watching a wimbledon final this morning
that's what gave me the confidence yeah
this looking how uh
composed and
confident
uh noah joker which was yeah that that
was the inspiration perfect let's take a
look at today's game because it was uh
definitely confident uh from your part
despite the fact that you were getting
viciously attacked
did you feel that way
uh
yes i i didn't really have to allow all
this if
uh bishop g5 was a really gamble
i could have just to probably take on d5
and take and take on a2
i did not really see a refutation of
that
just black is up up one
feels pretty safe and take another one
on b2
i know maybe it's uh can he force a draw
probably not you have queen before
uh
quinty four yeah i i know it looks like
white doesn't really have a lot of
threats for two pawns and uh but i
thought i didn't want to give nick a
positional compensation the plan for a
game was uh to get him into
like a
tactical militant and uh
so according to nick himself he he
blundered queen b6 okay and the whole
idea that
quinn will get to e3 and controlled h6
but in fact it was still within the
margins of equality at this point really
yes so knight to f5
okay queen to d3
and i think king to f2 was the big
mistake into g1 still maintains equality
what was your plan after king to g1
how's that
okay possible okay i wanted to pick up
both pawns and come back is that
possible perhaps yes okay
wait just one second
you can go to g3 right can i go to g3
wait wait wait when you when you are on
b2
i think i can go to g3 there's no more
checks
oh no then i don't want it
okay uh
no i i okay let me
stop here for a second uh
okay i need to control h6 if i don't
want to draw right precisely right and
quinto d2 was probably the most
difficult move to answer for white
but after queen to d2 queen to h4
takes g6 knight takes g6 so now you have
to play h5
whoa
okay and now knight takes d6 to distract
the queen
from the defense of uh the c1 h6 that
i'm in
uh
oh wow
yeah i i must admit i didn't see all
that i thought at this point i was
winning but after king f2 you definitely
found
the best moves almost best moves did you
consider rook bc8
this was a nice move that we saw rook b
to c8 rook bc8 instead of bishop to a c4
oh
yeah i'm controlling h6 so there's no
and now this is over also
the best he can do is take on g6 and
going to the losing engagement other
coin for a lot of queen for a lot of
pieces yeah
but still bishop before uh keeps the
advantage and now you found this
brilliant move e4
uh
yeah so the rook can lift and uh
yeah basically i thought that like no
threats uh no immediate threats for
white so i should consolidate and uh
but uh
i think our main consideration started
to defend extremely well for like kind
of
started finding those only moves and uh
we were surprised by queen b2 we
expected you to follow it up with rook
before this rook b5
right away yeah we thought that this was
your intention so queen b2 was a su was
a surprise for us
okay well
i wanted to pick up like few pawns
which we admire
quality yes
and
now as usual yeah the
i made it more difficult for myself and
we like the king chase at the end though
yeah i couldn't decide at which point i
want to play rook c8 and uh
finally
by the way sorry to interrupt this one
is over christopher you takes down
andrew hung in the battle of the leaders
in the junior section whoa yeah what a
game
okay
uh
yeah i was surprised
oh he
okay can he go king h5 but
i wasn't at this point
completely losing no i yeah i can simply
trade questions
yeah that's uh
so nick decided to make it into interest
in the end yeah
spectator friendly and
spectators family
that was
nice of him yeah
alex congratulations a big victory for
you who do you have tomorrow
i have no clue
i haven't taken it one
one game at the
time any any tennis matches uh scheduled
tonight uh
a little warmer than it was yesterday so
i don't know
basically if it's below uh below 90 we
should play it's right but uh i don't
know what it is all right well
we'll let you go check that out and
maybe schedule a tennis match good luck
all right thank you
thank you uh shabbat that's always nice
to see a king hunt i i love it well if
king hunts is what you like to see
yesterday yes let's take a look at this
game between dagu patty and justin one
we have it on the screen right now
between these two players because
three decisive rounds and the juniors
and the juniors as well let's get to the
moment and i really i believe we're
gonna have five decisive in the in the
juniors oh my goodness is definitely in
a winning end game against pedro there's
no way you can convince me otherwise
that's over yeah and this was the king
this is the king hunt with knight h4 h4
yeah as you suggested queen f3 and we
got here we got here and we have the
move g6 okay stop being made in two by
the way
yeah and queen g4 is white's threat so
g7 g6 how do we finish black
off here
or is the follow-up guys right
i feel like uh my puzzle rush tactics
failed me uh
from the talia game with rook the dc
yeah the way to find rick d7 no no that
was really a beautiful uh
finish
okay
um
let's see the king's the king is
right there right there i mean you know
like
hello uh one of the things i really want
to do of course play is queen f7 but
oops rook e won check anything to be
said for the slow play king h2 i mean
it's not like black has a lot of threats
can i just like slow play it or should i
do something more decisive what's your
what's your feel i feel that
yeah black doesn't have a lot of moves
right gh2 might be useful as it does
yeah i was thinking takes and knight f3
is the mating plan he's been he's
actually made a move so we can wait
and see he's whoa
d a
best move best move according to
christian look at that well when you see
it on the board it's one of those that
why not why not rick d5 is such a huge
threat okay so i go
deep pardon me i'll go see for
protecting my queen that's important so
that on rook d5 you can interpose
something on e5 you can't interpret
something on f5 because i'll just take
it right
um
like for example in this position if i
go f5 you as you just said
i'll just take it just take it yeah and
that will be an easy checkmate
okay but no yes or no check me through
the pawn always with the pawn always
true true true honestly that's that's a
ruler
absolutely i'm ashamed
we made a big mistake yeah my my face is
red but i did intend actually after rook
check
um to move my night because thankfully
i haven't blundered my queen i mean i
guess i can pick up a night but i guess
picking up on it is enough and i don't
want to analyze anymore quinji for queen
f4 i think wins tonight
no that's not enough what do you mean
it's not enough it's a night but it's a
night right not enough yes not but
that's not enough come on
you're not there has to be something
much better than this yeah i mean your
night's really off-site you allow some
checks i mean that point on did you say
my night as i was like it's a free night
come on no no no no nobody believes it
not good enough what come on let's go
back let's write something
you guys can mean this isn't just mean
and chess
chess is cruel and then you die then you
die right yes
what if i just leave seven queen f7 is
just winning what if i just take one
episode one because you don't have this
protection anymore because that's nice
this trick is gone right yeah that's the
one because now you got knight f3 and g4
with understanding this is just over
here queen f7 is great yeah
c4 queen f7 is game over i'm sure
there's other moves but this is just um
by the way uh can i do something else
can i go check
just a second excuse me uh not c4 which
i understand i will lose h2 uh and
knight to e5
gift me your queen i will try not to
be
kind give me your queen b1 and kh2 are
on the board
absolutely see that
95 also on the board okay i think it's
the best chance for black
so do we go rook d5 now
rig device pretty
d5 i didn't move i didn't see i just
want to take on f7 with a queen that's i
understand
um
f5
uh oh uh oh i feel
my
is that sometimes you you try to
calculate a forced win
right check check check when we win
then you realize you don't need to
why because black has no threats
right even in a position like this don't
tell me you just go and take the pawn on
c5 like we need three queen c5 please i
don't want to do that like i don't want
to do that but if you did that
it's it's bad it's bad okay so but but i
like rook d5 i mean d5 i think it's just
okay i gotta go f5 i'll go to check
i got g3 and this is kind of my point
that you don't have thrust i go f4
that's nasty that's it right that's just
nasty the knight on h4 suddenly
perfectly placed to
kill to deliver yes that's it f4
that's it uh
balaji he has it he's got the game
one if he finds rook d5 queen g3 and f4
very nice series of moves to wrap things
up and i think he's reaching for that
rook right
that's a big move
and that's huge for the standings as
well i mean again yeah i mean i'm seeing
decisive games all in the juniors and
the seniors i've got to check the ladies
for a moment and he's played rook t5 and
i think that's going to give as those
standings are at the moment this is
going to give a full point advantage to
christopher you because he because
justin gets knocked down justin gets
knocked down and he took care of andrew
hung himself yes precisely that's big
exactly and brandon only has how many
points branches are the result brandon's
on plus one andrew hong is now on two
and a half points as he lost to
christopher you fascinating battle but
christopher got the better of him
absolutely by the way uh
it was the talia cervantes game that i
thought okay the women are also you know
because jennifer has already won
who made the draw well that was as
thrilling
wow what a sacrifice at the end and she
saved it let me just again check in with
alice alice has been
trying desperately to save the position
but no no now this last move is
definitely a clincher the move bishop f5
oops excuse me starting to interrupt yes
we have such a huge blunder in the great
wonder persona game that we probably
have to go to it oh oh we haven't looked
at this game at all sorry this is the
moment i guess to look at it because it
might be ending the players have somehow
got into the same game i don't really
know exactly how they got here but
bishop before i think blunder is just
blundering a piece
rookie one check ricky one looks
horrifying horrifying right because if
you go to k3 no other choice i go right
d1 no
oh and just simply take and take they
can
check and i'm rookie four yeah yes
that's it that's it that's a piece yep
and she will win the game after rook
takes e4 she's done it she's done it and
three
rookies e4 doesn't help you right oh
sorry just a second here right here
and the same yeah king after he played
by the way but i think rook takes care
of rook takes c4 rook c4
picks up a full rook
a full piece yeah full piece i mean like
a full replacement position
exactly we end up up a piece you're
right
no question about rook and uh well that
would be a real turnaround because i
thought gracie actually
had an edge for most of this game you
you could see she's got the two bishops
and then she got control of the open
file like right here
you kind of think that uh what's after
rick right yeah no white's for choice
but she allowed her opponent to
establish the bishop and she's missed it
she's missed it
the only big question is does black find
the move rook takes e4 i think it's the
only winning move here
but it is it does suggest itself because
after all you know you love those pins i
mean uh once you get it your opponent's
piece is pinned up just attack the pin
piece what takes e4 yep basic tactics
basic taxes let's just keep an eye on it
because either she finds it right now or
she she won't find it right uh ellen was
really winning this game
badly like ages ago um is she still
must be right uh
why
that's what i'm wondering what
i i think anne marie did not oh my
goodness she played
follow it up with rook to c4 that's a
hard one to understand how did she miss
that double blunder alert guys yeah that
know that you know
seriously no no no it's not it's the
craziest thing i've seen it time and
time again it's the double blindness
double blindness right it's like it's
like something you know you you say to
your opponent it doesn't exist and they
believe you they trust you yeah this was
a lot of believing
took a lot of disbelieving actually yeah
um but did ellen
i mean again when i left it she was so
much material ahead i don't think
ellen's better
what
how is that
how is that possible we can get off this
game because this one will take a while
between prasanna and villa i believe
that should logically end in a draw
because
but this one is about over
um
putting the finishing touches wait a
second why is this
young opponent it is and it is bishop
takes it
she's going to play bishop takes b6
right check but i am not going to take
that mission
it's all yours
you keep your bishop
yeah
it's true
oh
you should be fine wait a minute wait a
minute
that's a clever little thing though that
was more clever than bishop v6 yeah it
doesn't work but who cares
nice nice bishop g2 check she knows it
yeah of course she'll play
the last remaining cheapo stalemate
stalemate
no stalemate please they'll meet me take
my bishop there you go mexican move
bishop g2 and that's the end of the game
that's wrestling nation alice lee
what a terrible tournament for her
really she could be oh and for except
that on the other hand
what a great tournament for sophie more
suzuki
four games in a row guys
incredible
wow
wow i'm kind of stunned uh truth be told
we've we've been uh having a lot of
results today i'm just seeing a lot of
victories
across the across the board yeah and if
we want to update another victory i
think i'll be manu
no but he's putting the final touches so
it's a good time to go to him all right
i'll be mind you against chester pedro
espinosa no oh sorry the other game yeah
yeah that one excuse me
uh if we can get the game between pedro
spinoza and abby mitch this is over yes
exactly the three pawns
that's a lot of pawns that is a lot of
pawns yeah i only need two of them i
mean even without the f pawn you would
still be losing oh this is just over he
resigned actually
well there you go
good time then good timing yeah
you can and justin mark he's also
playing i was actually playing the line
that we thought of queen g3 chuck right
and on king f6 i mean f4 left
right that's it finishes the game yeah
the spot
king f6 f4 we've seen
could i
in view of the fact that i i'm so busted
so lost after king f6 f4
is there anything to be said for king h5
it's made in
years
well can you have f4 i mean rookie five
is winning right rookie five is just
completely winning but i'm trying to get
some no no no but go f4 come on what why
no sorry sorry sorry q5 actually just go
knight f3 can i go rook e5 okay i want
to take in queen g6
and this is the and this is me this is
the nice one with the pawn with
understanding the understanding
yeah no king king king h5 doesn't uh in
any way
already f4 played yes this game is over
and that's a and he knows it that's the
clincher right that's a clincher
balaji making a comeback as well right
he was on
minus
wait he wasn't 50
50 he won one game he won one game he
lost one game he lost to andrew kong in
that four night sicilians andrew hong
yes right
by the way i sure looks to me like uh
benjamin is hanging on he's
he's been a pawn down and in the tough
struggle for some time but it looks like
he's got this great dark squared
fortress going for himself exactly at
this moment yes do you require if i just
rip it apart with rook d1 d5
rook d1 rook t5 and it's a joel benjamin
game that worked yes he played bishop to
d5 i don't like bishop d5
uh neither do i you have a very good
point though
because i was thinking wait what did you
want to do
he wanted to play rook to d1 check i
think
with the bishop on c6 there's always no
with the king on e6 i wanted to go to d8
i understand
what you were saying but right i want to
get to the eighth rank somehow i can
understand bishop d5 now he wants to
move out of this knight takes a c6 kind
of business business and now that i see
that this makes a lot more sense i think
that white
has a pretty clear path forward and
now you play rook to d1 because knight
takes a6 is no longer on tap i was
trying to play f5 f4 you know frankly
yeah that was what that was all about
uh he did not play that joel instead
drawback with the king king e7 and now
this was the dark squared portrait
actually yesterday just to have yes go
to uh
i saw some uh some funny stuff please so
after f5 yes i can go rook h1
you take on e4 with a pawn and i give
you a check
i wasn't going to take on h4 with the
point no come on take it thank you okay
make me happy okay
have some happiness go rook h6 take my
bishop also yes
thank you that's c4
that guy he's so happy with it i don't
know why we invite him
uh but how did you intend to meet f4
i think i can corral that point so i'll
give you a check and then i'll pick up
on f4 and then rook h4 how do you do
that um that's uh that's simple
yes
the thing is if you look at this i was
hoping to try to get my king to e5
that's what it was all about yeah if you
look at black's position with this rook
did he just play the move fc he played
f6 he's a brave man uh
seventh rank just like that
oops it's kind of a funny looking move
bishop d5 h a f6 and rook h8 and we're
caught up with the players but now the
bishop goes back to c6 right
what's the plan i need to get my king
involved somehow is rook b8 rook b7
igor's plan
that's
that's a compelling one
the problem with that is that i can't
take with a rook right and then go
knight d7 and put the knight on b8
that's a that's an awfully passive
[Laughter]
a strong horse that is
holds the game together there's no way
oh dear um
joel is definitely suffering in this
game
suffering might be just that lost it
might just be isn't it easier to go r8
followed by bishop b7 i just didn't know
what that did because you can always
take on b7 okay rook is defended right
no rook a7 and then i exchanged an a7
how do you catch my pawn oh okay eight
oh that's a big question yeah should be
seven
we can look at yasser's analysis
and uh rook takes a seven
and i think
oh no no he paused he's ready to
sacrifice
zach on c5 he sees a yummy on c5 he says
i'm going to take that
i mean that would be too connected past
pawns i mean if you get that you're
winning yes
with the bishop on c6 followed by no no
it's just completely lost that's not
good
but what do you do about it i gotta move
the knight i don't see a choice and
you're going to move the knight
to e6 and then you're going to do what
you just said you're going to put your
bishop on b7 and your rook on a8 i'm
going to cry
i'm actually curious that if do i have
any like
more wins but no that's good enough
right oh yeah
there might be he might be but
c5 c4 or c45 as well
this looks like joe's going down yeah
yeah we haven't seen um
gregory
and uh
vladimir putin
for some reason because it's a bad draw
oh well i just got here yeah
i was i showed up i was hoping there'd
be a party and it's just a draw the
party was not your place okay good good
to know um
wow we're gonna have a lot of four
victories and the seniors how many do we
have in the juniors let me tap that
again
four victories in the
juniors
and the one draw that i'm seeing was the
talia game which was amazing so far it's
the only draw of the day like what that
this is crazy we're seeing a lot of
victories today uh
why christian
well uh one victor is actually with us
right now in the studio the leader
the only player in all three events
still perfect after four rounds
congratulations sophie welcome back to
the show how did you live this game
i feel great
um
yeah i
i'm really proud of myself i guess
you played this uh greenfield inviting a
fight
was that a strategy early on
yeah
i'm just it's
it's really early so i'm just trying to
play for a win every round
every single game white or black doesn't
matter and
you guys uh ended up in this position
knight to d7 bishop f4 did she surprise
you by the way with this early h3 was
that the line that he looked at or was
that a surprise didn't look at that um i
looked at bishop e2
i did not look at h3
but i thought i could just kind of go
with the same ideas
absolutely and you did let's keep going
bishop to f4
and this was the moment let's keep going
for a few more
d5 queen to a4
what what were your feelings when you
saw this move land on the board queen to
b1
um well i was surprised i
like when i was thinking about queen a4
i
or when i was i mean queen of four was
like my idea in this position anyway um
of course i need to calculate some
things um
but i'm pretty sure the only move for
white is like yeah queen b5 or queen b3
i'm pretty sure one of those is forced
correct i um
looked at i mean i saw it registered in
my mind that queen b1 was a possibility
but i really wasn't expecting it to be
played um i actually didn't see knight
takes d5 like when i was calculating it
when i was thinking about queen a4 but i
only saw it after like why i actually
played queen b1
so that was um a nice surprise how long
did it take you to see to spot the move
knight to d5 i think i saw like almost
immediately
and then you spent a few minutes to
double check yeah make sure you're not
missing anything and after that
how close did you feel like here uh in
this endgame from
victory um
not until like i was up two pawns like i
thought it was pretty tough up until
like i
i don't i i don't really know what
happened around here but i
ended up winning like a second pawn
with f after f5
even here i wasn't really sure what was
happening but i think it was like i
think i really registered that i was
like winning on when i
played f4 and f3 finally exchanged
double pawns now it's uh clean two pawns
well
and after that the clinical
uh victory and uh conversion in this
winning end game sophie
what's there to say four out of four
just a brilliant performance up uh to
this point uh how do you feel right now
you must be in cloud nine
yeah um i feel pretty
amazing is this the best start that
you've had in a tournament
yeah i think like um the second best
start that i've had in a major
tournament was like three and a half out
of four so this is new for me
[Music]
well
big congratulations guys any questions
no whatever it is you're doing keep it
up because it's one of them it's working
four out of four we're going to call you
miss perfect keep it going
you can't say anything against
perfection and there we have the
head-to-head alice lee
disappointing event for her
what can we say we had great hopes for
her after the american cup she she wowed
she really did but she starts the event
with one out of four oops and sophie
she's the big winner guys four out of
four perfect she's gonna be asking uh
fabiano carona to be on
exactly
i can do that give her the magic dust
whatever it is and another result we
have pedro espinosa did lose against
abhimani mishra misha a gift yesterday
but a convincing win today catapults him
to three points out of four which
actually means i think he's in second
place uh in the juniors
thanks to the fact that andrew lost and
justin will lose also
and they will be stuck at two and a half
yeah also guys is yes gracie just
completely winning right now oh sorry i
was just looking at the wrong game i was
looking at igor's game against joel igor
did sacrifice the exchange by the way i
see that b-pawn i mean i understand you
took the h-bomb box how do you stop my
beats
you don't
i mean
it's a full it's a full queen pretty
much over wait a minute this is the game
where
it was playable played she had the
option of picking up a full piece now
she's completely lost oh my goodness
that is
what a turnaround that would be
that's a rough one
turn around it is because there's
absolutely no way to stop that pawn no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no it's
it's dead this is over
it's completely lost i'm just going b6
b7 rook c8 if you put the rook on the
eighth rank and that's it doesn't even
help their kings on f8 no the king is on
the worst spot of all uh
on f8 i mean if it was on g7 it would be
better chances what happened here was
she in time why did she take on h4 she's
not in time pressure she has eight
minutes on the clock
it's it's puzzling my goodness
why would you go for the king side
right
um
experience guys this is what a lot of
players come here it's a tough
tournament right game games are tough
and a lot of people well they come here
to learn against the best and this is
going to be a lesson for anne marie
can't take that king side when there's a
potential passport it's not about the
quantity of fonts but the quality
of the pawns we say that very often in
end games
and there's a good reason for a good
reason yeah this part of v6 is not
stopped this game is over uh another
game that is over gregory kaidanov did
draw that game against vladimir kopi and
we had a call down when it was a dead
draw some time ago nothing's changed all
right uh joel benjamin is clinging on to
dear hope but i don't think he is yeah i
think he's suffering suffering
okay we do have one idea for black right
if the if joe can get his king to b6
pardon me to c7 to control
the break b6
you're not on time no you're not it's
just the bishop on d5 it dominates
okay so no i'm gonna have to go back to
b8 so wait a minute we just see c4
king d7 let's
sorry to rump this is over and i just
saw
an awful blunder no what in ellen one
against riyon young another one like a
humongous blunder this is a very basic
blunder actually oh oh what happened now
this is this is a simple rock end game
like as simple as they got oh no
so
two moves ago
and she didn't find it
guys four fourth fifth hour of chess
it's tough for professional competitors
we see fabiana karana we see hikarana
kamura we see all these players blunder
on the fourth fifth hour when you have
people that are coming into this tough
tournament fourth fifth round fourth
fifth hour of that round
it's common to see mistakes oh
absolutely it's absolutely common we see
this kind of mistakes all the time if we
go back a couple of moves uh this is a
drawn end game it's a known drawn end
game
as prasanna this finish off that game
but if we can go back to the analysis
board
in this particular position i mean at
some point you should you should throw
in king d7 at some point you need just
to stop just to stop rookie 8 rook g8
coming from at some point right exactly
it doesn't have to be now but it has to
be at some point your king does belong
on d7 rook g3 or king hd4 and here
white is actually threatening
e8 right uh which i think wins
here it does i mean it's uh i mean
you're down you're you're you're offline
yeah then i'm going to go uh rook g6
you just moved the king out of the
little seven h7
h8 right but this was missed king 86 was
played instead perhaps the players both
thought that this was an easy draw
nonetheless
and after king d7 i think it's again a
draw because now you don't have this
mechanism the only way to establish the
mechanism is to go through the a file
but that gives black an extra tempo
because you get the king closer
exactly that's how this end game works
and the king will be uh
stuck stuck in the in the corner yep
yeah i can put the pawn on h7 first
maybe that's
yeah the pawn on h7 and just to have
rook g8 in this particular position but
then you never you never extract the
king no
you're you're uh the king is too close
yeah yeah
wow
um
big
missed opportunity there for ellen as uh
yeah yeah it's a loud rook e8 it's
experience right that this this rook end
games
they're simple
but they're you need some precision you
need a lot of precision and there's so
often that at this time of the day
people will make impositions to have
this sharp hawkeye look
for these moments
where you can actually turn the game
around and and this one now at this
point i think is just that drawn
and i think a game that is about to uh
finish if white does find the right
moves
is uh the game between
malnitsky
and joel benjamin well that's easy right
i think i go if
this one is going to be a yeah this one
is we can go away from this one yeah
this one is over i think you push b6 and
a7
if you play b6 the game is over yes so
b6 king b8
c
6 that's one way yeah takes
push
and a7 no stopping that
runaway train
the a train
yep that is it that that's that's it
let's review a couple of the results
that we just got in uh they're coming
fast they're very
in a great game from start to finish
does defeat justin wang that's the
second victory in a row for balaji yes
and that means that he is now on plus
one recovery from the minus one
inflicted by andrew hong justin started
one with a big victory against the
wander liang but two draws in a row and
now a loss is on 50 percent
in the head-to-head between these two
great players great legends gregory
kaidanov draws against vladimir akkopian
a fascinating sicilian but at the end it
kind of fizzled exactly and uh four
victories in the seniors wow what a
strange uh
it's been in a game that really could
have gone
either direction it really defies logic
near the end and that's normal because
once you pass the first time control man
it's tough to keep your composure yeah
and i think this is what happened in
this game gracie prasanna takes
advantage of that and wins her game
against anne-marie villa sometimes
endurance it's it's an endurance contest
it feels like as uh
that moment board guys b6 checked yes
this is bad news for joel right now yes
it is he realizes it
and there's nothing you can do king to
b8 i don't even have to go c6i yeah i
was
yeah i was being uh c6 is the most
forced right and he has done king b ap
anything
capturing on b6 then the move a7 is so
much easier
so king b8 is
trying to give igor an opportunity to go
wrong with
i
[Laughter]
probably doesn't win right right yeah i
think you get stuck it might lose
yeah yeah but if if he can replace b7 i
think we'll we'll ask him to come back
another year
because you don't play b7 no you don't
yeah you did but you're right can you be
i was being uh well direct yeah offhand
you finish it you finish the game
there's nothing wrong with this king b5
perfectly sensible
nothing is stopping c6
and c7 uh once you get your king to b5
so that game uh really is over
yeah and look at this all decisive games
all the sizes yeah juniors 100 wow
yeah they do swing with the fences don't
they i really do
i by the way christian i i have to
remark on this all of the guests that
you've had come into the studio you're
very gracious you're very good with them
but when demetri gurvich came into the
studio this is the first time i ever
heard you say mr girvich welcome to
i was about to say i made a star struck
there you have to respect the legends
guys nice nice
and we doing it have another guest that
is a gracie prasanna after an incredible
victory first of all gracie welcome to
the show welcome to st louis this is
your first time at the u.s junior girls
how does that feel
what does this tournament mean to you um
it's very exciting like i've heard of
this tournament and i've always kind of
wanted to play in it so being able to
compete against all these amazing
players that i've heard about never like
played in like this big of a menu it's
pretty great take us uh through the
first four games specifically yesterday
it was such a tense battle against the
leader of uh this tournament and then in
the end you resigned in a drawing
position
um yeah that was really upsetting
obviously because i thought i was losing
i didn't actually see the queen h6 idea
and it's kind of weird because usually i
don't resign in that kind of position
but
yeah i just tried to bounce back from
that i guess
it was strange for us because you played
all the way up to that point with down a
piece and then
you resign when you finally got the
knight but today you bounced back a big
victory for you take us through uh
today's game um i thought that the
position was kind of drawish to be
honest like i was about ready to offer
the draw but then i was like well let's
keep playing like worst case like we're
going to go for a three-fold so
and then a3 knight takes d4 yes and uh
you came up with this idea knight to f5
to pick up the two bishops
how did you feel the assessment of the
position is at this point
um well i didn't really like that night
on d5 it was kind of like invading my
position i didn't feel that my knight
was doing the same for her position like
i thought she could kind of maneuver her
pieces around it so i just kind of
wanted to
trade that off for the bishop see if i
could do something with that
and
let's keep going
when is the next critical
moment of this game and by the way uh
sorry to interrupt you this game is
indeed over kamelnitsky picks up his
first victory of the u.s seniors
championship for him
congratulations eager
let's keep going
bishop to d2h5 rook to a1 now tell us
the plan behind this move work the way
you want um i mean here i think i was
just trying to make time control and i
was thinking maybe a4 at some point um
try to bring my
rooks over to attack basic spawn but
i didn't really think that was going to
happen i was trying to make moves at
that point
and then
a big moment came when you played the
move a bishop to e4 let's
let's go to that moment did you realize
that she had this move rook takes e4 at
that point let's keep going
right here
did you realize she has no rook takes
before yeah she does say that
um
or was this a mutual blind spot it seems
like yeah probably um yeah that was that
would just be lost for me
i can't believe i missed that
but she took with the bishop and she
gave you another chance not only that
but it does seem like your king is much
better place right yeah were you already
playing for a victory at this point yeah
here i was playing for a victory because
um we could have gone for the threefold
i just tried to
see what would happen if i tried pushing
this pawn here
and i figured that hurricane couldn't
like catch up in time so that's kind of
what i went for she's just way uh too
far a big victory for you uh gracie your
first time at the u.s juniors
championships what are your ambitions
for this event
i'm just trying to get some good games
in hopefully get a few points and just
try to enjoy the event because it's a
really big event and i'm glad to be here
definitely a lot of experience you will
gain from this one congratulations for
the victory and we'll see you in the
rest of your games thank you
congratulations gracie well done
and there was one left but not really
because not much of a game the rook upon
end game draw
and that one is going to be a draw we
have absolutely oh because this is where
the king gets trapped okay there's not
zero to talk about in this position
where they work on the file christian
what do you think of the round today so
many decisive games
like what happened today the damn burst
exactly i guess we're getting closer and
closer to that midpoint of the
tournament and we know the players are
getting a bit tired a lot more chances
are arising on the board and we see some
of the players taking advantage of that
i feel this is the explanation and oh my
goodness no no don't forget about
yourself
congratulations i mean i'm proud of you
i'm kind of proud of
you
but guys
shame on us right
and in the
well i wander with us bounce back mishra
with the wind christopher you with the
wind jacobson with the wind okay these
commentators know something right all
right today was a good day it was a good
day for the comments seniors i got a
feeling joel
did not bring his best out oh but that's
just happy dennis is happy shabba dabba
with a big victory ako piano kaidano
christian we split our point can't
really complain about that one but i
need my boy to start collecting some
football likewise
i feel the same
and we are expecting a handshake here
how much time do the players have
because it could still go on i know it's
not like the handshake is coming i was
really hoping she was playing her cafe
perhaps they're still trying guys all
right let's see
stays on the f file
tried there for what what exactly
christian rook check not much
[Laughter]
uh that king is we are not hoping on h8
rook f8 would be nice though would be a
nice finish
understanding yes
actually i don't think it's
understanding because you're finishing
the game from an inferior position
when you watch her take him out
i don't know this is nonsense we're
talking about
commentators getting ready to go to
dinner
and he's talking about an inferior
position stale made a stalemate dude
he's superior
an extra pot
nope no no no handshakes rook f7 would
really be understanding
that was close
ooh
rook f7 it's still a draw by the way
yeah there we go the handshake tom
called it he said i want to i want to
stay for the handshake and he wouldn't
let us go no he wouldn't let us go but
we have it that's every result for the
tournaments perhaps we can look at the
standings
of our tournaments uh let's take a start
with the junior girls even if we don't
have it updated it's not a big deal well
i know who's got four
oops that's not the girls well we are
the junior girls yeah those the juniors
yeah christopher you he catapults
himself to first place defeating one of
his rivals andrew hong huge result there
abhimayomishra he goes from potentially
having a disaster of a tournament to two
victories in a row now he has three out
of four and is where you would expect
them brandon jacobson also regaining
ground after losing in the first round
he now has two victories as well as does
balaji dagupati who is also on two and a
half both of them joining andrew hong in
third in the senior tournament we had a
big victory by larry c
of defeating one of his other people on
two points
maxine plugy and that means that larry c
is currently in first place and in
second second alone by the way
surprise
and a shout out to him because i believe
he is the lowest rated player in the
event all right and a big big tie
at 50
yes
and finally in the uh girls section
i think they're still updating that one
oh sorry that's slow silence okay well
we'll go with christian for some final
thoughts of the round and i think we
know who the leader is and the girls i
sure do well uh finally guys we're
starting to see the cream rising to the
top we see a jennifer you picking up
some speed larry christiansen as well we
knew coming into this event after we've
seen what he did last year we knew he
will be a force to be reckoned with and
he's showing that uh up to round number
four and again christopher you
definitely showing his stuff as well as
abhimanyu mishra after surviving a
miraculous game against a wonder now
he's picking up the pace i'm definitely
looking forward to see what we're going
to have in the next few rounds all right
thank you christian and as we have the
junior girls standings after four rounds
of chess as we mentioned sophie morris
suzuki definitely in a great spot four
out of four wow perfect sophie she's
followed a full point behind by jennifer
you and talia cervantes and surprisingly
only uh riyang yan on a plus one score
two and a half fourth position for her
at the moment i don't know what it is
but it's been a very very very decisive
rounds and this one look says it all
yeah jennifer
she's done she's got this
waiting for her opponent to resign
import a victory for jennifer
back into this event we didn't like her
opening but now she's in second place
yeah i know she's she's fought her way
to a second place that start but uh
she's getting her groove absolutely
well thank you everybody for joining us
today we will be back tomorrow as we
have more chess in store join us at 1pm
good night everyone
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you